HOW IT WORKS?
WELL GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO
THE JOINT OVERSIGHT HEARING OF
WAS HIS ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON HATE CRYING.
AND THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE.
HELLO FIRST OFF ALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR INTEREST AND
BEING HERE TODAY.
I AM KANSEN CHU I'M THE CHAIR OF
THE ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
HATE CRYING.
AND I'M.
THIRD TO CODE CO CHAIRED THIS
HEARING WAS ASSEMBLY A ELMER SIX
YOU WHOSE TO CHEER OFF TO JOIN
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE. TO
WILL COME BICU TO TODAY'S
DRAWING OVERSIGHT HEARING
[inaudible]
I STARTED THIS A SELECT
COMMITTEE ON HATE CRIME LAST
YEAR -- WAS
EITHER A MEMBERS IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
IN RESPONSE TO THE RISE OF HAY
CRYING THROUGH ALL THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IN ADDITION TO MYSELF WHAT
BECOME MEDIA MEMBERS MADE UP OF
TEN OF MY COLLEAGUES IN THIS THE
STATE ASSEMBLY.
THERE'S THERE'S ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON HATE CRYING SERVE
AS A TOOL. TO FOSTER A COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT AND OPEN DIALOGUE AND
COLLABORATION FOR ETHNIC AND
RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATIONS
[inaudible]
LGBT TQ GROUPS LAW ENFORCEMENT
NONPROFIT AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS.
AS MUCH AS KALRA FUNNIER HAS
DRIVE TO BE INCLUSIVE AND
PROGRESSIVE.
WE WILL HAVE THE HIGHEST NUMBER
OF HATE GROUPS.
AND AND A SHARP INCREASE IN THE
HATE CRIME.
EVEN THROUGH HATE CRIMES ARE
GENERALLY AND UNDER REPORTED.
I WON'T GO INTO DETAIL AS WE
WERE HERE FROM OTHER EXPERT ON
ON ON THIS ISSUE.
AND AND AND THAT'S WHY I
REQUESTED A STATE AUDIT ON HATE
CRIME. TO GET ALL THE FOOD
PICTURE A FULL PICTURE OF
CURRENT EFFORT.
AND I IT IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITY TO
DEVELOP POLICIES TO REDUCE THE
FREQUENCY OF HIS BIAS RELATED
CRYING.
THE OTHER CAME WHILE ON ME
THIRTY FIRST AND I GOT A CHANCE
TO A HOW BLUE OF BRIEFING ON
THAT.
AND I FELT WAS VERY
COMPREHENSIVE.
THE OPEC LONOKE THE MOST LIBERAL
--
AND AS THE SCHOOL OF
UNIVERSITIES.
AND AND SO A AND ALSO A BIT MORE
CONSERVATIVE.
AREAS IN CALIFORNIA AND AND TO A
ROOM KNOWN OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES INBETWEEN [inaudible]
SO --
TODAY'S HEARING WILL FOCUS ON TO
THE STATIC DESCRIBED DISTRICTS
KEY FUNDING FROM THE AUDIT
REPORT.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY GOOD COMEY
HE THAT ARE IMPACTED --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AL MURATSUCHI
AND I A IN THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
OF ALL THE COMEY V. O. WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF OUR TO VOTE EFFORT
AND REQUEST.
AND MAKE THIS THE OTHER COULD OF
THE POSSIBLE [inaudible]
AND FOR YOU TODAY WOULD HEALTH
--
WILBUR BREAKING DOWN IN THE
STREET OF COMPOUND THOSE --
FIRST THEY ALL LIKE TO TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE THE
PUBLIC HEARING.
WILL FOCUS ON THE SENSITIVE
TOPIC AND I EXPECT EVERYONE TO
CONDUCT IN THE VERY RESPECTFUL
MATTER.
I AM SAID THE PANEL PANELISTS TO
KEEP THEIR PRESENTATION TO THE
TIME ALLOCATED.
ROUGHLY AROUND --
FOUND SEVEN TEN MINUTES.
AND IF KERN THOUGH WILL BE
FOLLOWED BY A Q. A NAY PORTION
FOR MEMBERS ON THE DAIS. TO ASK
QUESTIONS --
ON ON OFF TO PRESENTED AND THERE
WILL BE THREE PANELS AND TIME
FOR THE PANEL COMMENT IN IT.
AT THE END.
WAS THAT I LIKE TO ONLY INVITE
--
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI.
THE CHAIR OF JOINT AUDIT
COMMITTEE TO MAKE A OPENING
REMARKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
SOME WOMEN TO END AND THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
ADDRESSING THIS A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
AND THANK YOU ALSO FOR A LEADING
THEY ARE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ACCORDING TO OUR CALIFORNIA
PARTNER JODY.
ABOUT TO SPEAK OUT LOUD HERE
LOOK IT SHOULD I TURN DISTANT
DOES ONE OF TURNER.
I CAN HEAR ME OKAY AMERICA.
THANK YOU AGAIN ASSEMBLYMAN YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN REPORT HATE CRIMES IN
CALIFORNIA.
HAVE INCREASED 17%.
THERE WAS A 52% INCREASE IN HATE
CRIMES.
COMMITTED AGAINST LATINOS.
ANTI MUSLIM ANTI ISLAMIC AND
ANTI SEMITIC HATE CRIMES ROSE BY
21% LAST YEAR.
AND INCIDENTS INVOLVING A
PERSON'S REAL OR PERCEIVED
SEXUAL ORIENTATION JUMPED NEARLY
19%.
JUST THIS MORNING I OPEN UP
TODAY THE BREEZE AND AS READING
ABOUT THE A HATE CRIME THAT WAS
COMMITTED LAST WEEK --
AND TURLOCK I BELIEVE.
GO BACK TO A COUNTRY TWO MEN
YELLED AT A TURLOCK RESIDENT.
WHO WAS BORN IN PUNJAB INDIA?
HAVING LIVED IN THE UNITED
STATES MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE
YEARS RAISING FOUR CHILDREN WITH
HIS WIFE.
AND ATTACKED WHILE HE WAS
PUTTING UP.
LAWN SIGNS BOOK FOR LOCAL
POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS.
HE WAS HIT ON THE HEAD.
BY WOODEN STICK.
A CURSE AT HIM AND TOLD HIM HE
DIDN'T BELONG HERE.
AND THEY SPRAY PAINTED A WHITE
NATIONALIST SYMBOL IN THE WORDS
SHOULD GO BACK TO YOUR COUNTRY.
ON IS PICKED UP.
SO I I THINK WE'RE ALL SEEING.
IN HEARING ABOUT THESE TYPES OF
INCIDENTS.
AND SPEAKING FOR MYSELF I I KNOW
THAT I AM SEEING [inaudible]
AND INCREASING.
LEVEL OF HATE AND DIVISIVENESS
--
EVEN IN MY OWN COMMUNITY.
AND I CAN'T HELP BUT FEEL THAT
THIS INCREASING LEVEL OF HATE
AND DIVISIVENESS [inaudible]
IS.
IF NOT BECAUSE AT LEAST RELATED
TO THE INCREASING LAB LEVEL OF
HATEFUL AND DIVISIVE.
POLITICAL RHETORIC THAT WE'RE
HEARING --
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
STARTING --
WITH.
ARE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
SO I WOULD LIKE.
TO I WELCOME ALL THE TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY TO FIRST OF ALL GET.
THE DATA THAT HAS BEEN ASSEMBLED
BY OUR STATE AUDITOR TO HEAR
FROM THE REPRESENTATIVES OF THE%
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
--
AND TO IN PARTICULAR ASK THE DOJ
TO RESPOND TO THE STATE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS.
AS TO HOW --
THAT DOJ CAN TAKE LEADERSHIP AND
INCREASING.
STATE'S ABILITY AND
EFFECTIVENESS IN ADDRESSING.
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE OF HATE
CRIMES.
BUT ALSO TO HERE.
TESTIMONY AND EVIDENCE AS TO
WHETHER OR THERE IS IN FACT
BECAUSE THE CONNECTION BETWEEN.
THE RISE IN REPORTED HATE CRIMES
AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE IN
TERMS OF AN INCREASINGLY HATEFUL
AND DIVISIVE PUBLIC DISCOURSE
[inaudible]
COMMITMENTS WHICH THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY.
MURATSUCHI AND WILL ALSO JOINED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAY
OBERNOLTE.
AND GO MARC LEVINE SO --
WITH.
EITHER ONE OF YOU WANNA MAKE
SOME OPENING COMMENT
[inaudible]
PLEASE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I AM
HAPPY TO BE HERE THIS MORNING
THE ISSUE OF THE RISE IN HATE
CRIMES CALIFORNIA IS OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE BOTH TO ME AND TO THE
PEOPLE I REPRESENT.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM TORRANCE THAT I
THINK THAT THIS SO THE RISING
HEAT CRIME IS.
LINKS TO A RISE IN --
DIS TOLERANCE IN POLITICAL
DISCOURSE ALTHOUGH I WOULD SAY
THAT'S PROBABLY ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE.
AND I'M LOOKING FOR TO SEE WHAT
OUR PANELISTS HAVE TO SAY ABOUT
THAT AND HOW WE GO ABOUT FIXING
IT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND EMISSIONS CHAIR IT'S I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
LEADERSHIP THAT YOU DISPLAYED IN
REQUESTING THIS AUDIT THANK YOU
FOR THE LEADERSHIP OF THE AUDIT
COMMITTEE.
ARE FOR APPROVING IT I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THE AUDITOR AND HER
STAFF FOR OF THEIR WORK ON THIS
TIMELY ISSUE.
ALL OF US --
THROUGHOUT THE CITY CAO BY THE
INCREASE IN HATE CRIMES OF THE
INCREASE IN IN INTOLERANCE OF
THAT.
THAT WE CAN FEEL THIS REALLY --
THEIR MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
SAID HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY THIS
AND DIE IN SOME LOOKING FOR TO
THE HEARING TODAY THANK YOU.
PARTICULAR MUCH WHEN ALL START
OF FIRST PANEL WAS PROFESSOR
BRIAN LEVIN WAS A CIVIL RIGHT
ATTORNEY AND A PROFESSOR OF CAL
STATE UNIVERSITIES.
THE US SAMPOERNA DO YOU KNOW
WHERE HE SPECIALIZED AND STUDY
HATE CRIME.
AND ALSO HOW THOSE FIELD AUDITOR
YELLING HOW WHO HAS BEEN SERVING
THE STATE FOR THE LAST EIGHTEEN
YEARS.
HE IS JOINED BY HER STAFF
KATHLEEN FULLER TURN AND NICK
FELT.
I THINK AUDIO FILE OF ALL THE
PRESENTERS ARE AND HAND OUT.
PROFESSOR YOU GOTTA GO.
FOR HELLO I'M BRIAN LEVIN I'M
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER FOR THE
STUDY OF HATE AND EXTREMISM AT
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SAMBAR DID YOU KNOW I'D LIKE TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES.
INCLUDING A PROFESSOR KEVIN
GRISHAM JOHN REITZEL AND THAT
JAMES NOLAN FROM UNIVERSITY OF
VIRGINIA.
IN ADDITION --
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THINK --
KANSEN CHU WHOSE CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
MISTER MERRETT JACI WHO IS A
CHAIR OF THE G. LACK
[inaudible]
UP.
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO SAY WE
ARE DRIVEN BY THE FACT BEHIND
EXHIBIT NUMBERS THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE TODAY.
THAT THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES.
THERE ARE DEVASTATED BY MANY OF
THESE ATTACKS AND THE SOCIAL
SCIENCES AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THESE KINDS
OF CRIMES.
SEPT PEOPLE MORE AND THAT'S WHAT
WE WROTE WHEN WE ARE WE'RE
PUTTING TOGETHER BRIEFS INDIA
LANDMARK HE CRIME CASE OF
WISCONSIN VERSES MITCHELL TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AGO INDEED TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AGO THE FIRST TIME.
I HAVE THE HONOR OF A TESTIFYING
FOR THE THIS LEGISLATURE AND
THINGS HAVE BEEN DE CHANGE BUT
REMEMBER WE HAD BUILDING BLOCKS
THAT WERE PUT TOGETHER.
ESPECIALLY GERMANY A EIGHTIES
AND NINETIES UNDER PRIOR
ADMINISTRATIONS AND THE AUDIT
THAT WE SAW I JUST THIS YEAR I
THINK SAYS IT OR BUILDING
BLOCKS.
ARE INDEED FIRM BUT WE HAVE TO
COORDINATE THESE BUILDING BLOCKS
AND THE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN CHARGE
OF PUTTING TOGETHER A BIT
BETTER.
HERE'S WHERE ARE LATEST RESEARCH
SHOWS AND THAT IS FOR TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHEN WE
LOOKED AT THE TOP TEN CITIES AND
THIRTY EIGHT CITIES THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES TOURS ABOUT A
12% INCREASE [inaudible]
HOWEVER.
CALIFORNIA'S INCREASE AGAIN WAS
MORE AND WE'VE BEEN SEEING MULTI
YEAR INCREASES.
WHAT ARE SOME THE THINGS BEHIND
THIS WILL LONG TERM SHIFTS WITH
REGARD TO DEMOGRAPHICS
ECONOMICS?
AS WELL AS ANXIETY RELATED TO
CHANGES THAT ARE GOING ON AND
POLITICAL POLARIZATION.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE SEEN CATTOLICA
VENTS CAN CAUSE SPIKES.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE IN AN ERA.
OF NTERNATIONAL EURO
NATIONALISM --
IT'S ONE THING TO TALK ABOUT
PARTICULAR ISSUES IT'S ANOTHER
THING TO TALK ABOUT RELIGION
RACE AND ETHNICITY.
AS A BASIS FOR UP MAKING THESE
POLICY DECISIONS AND
UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS TAKING
PLACE INDEED JUST RECENTLY A
CANDIDATE FOR A CALIFORNIA
SENATE GOT ALMOST NINETY
THOUSAND VOTES TO SING JEWS
SHOULD NOT BE INVOLVED IN
GOVERNMENT.
SORRY TO SAY THAT.
SOME OF YOU A FINE THAT OPINION
A MOVEMENT MANY OF PEOPLE ALL OF
YOU FIND THAT WRONG --
IN ADDITION WE'VE HAD
INTERFERENCE FROM FOREIGN
ENTITIES.
WHEN WE DID A STUDY OUR LAST
YEAR WE FOUND THAT VIOLENT
PUBLIC DEMONSTRATIONS?
ARE ACTUALLY DOUBLED IN THE
FIRST THREE QUARTERS SEVENTEEN
OVER.
SIXTEEN AND CHARLOTTESVILLE WAS
THE BIGGEST.
WHITE NATIONALIST RALLY THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN DECADES.
ALSO WE SEEM AN EMBOLDENED.
WHITE NATIONALISM SINCE
CHARLOTTESVILLE THERE'S BEEN A
BIT OF IMPLOSION WITH REGARD TO
THE LEADERSHIP AND THE
COORDINATION THESE GROUPS BUT
ARE THE UNDERLYING MESSAGES ARE
STILL THERE.
THESE EXTREMISTS ARE AND BY THE
FACT THAT CONFIDENCE IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS HAS DECLINED IN
RECENT DECADES AS THIS CHART
SHOWS AND I KNOW I'M GOING
THROUGH THIS FAST BUT ALL POSTED
TO OUR CENTERS WEBSITE.
AFTER AFTER THE HEARING THIS
WEEK.
IN ADDITION OUR PEOPLE FEEL
ANXIETY OUR LIFE EXPECTANCY
UNITED STATES FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN DECADES IS ON THE DECLINE AND
A LOT OF THAT RESULTS FROM
THINGS SUCH AS SUICIDE.
AND DRUG USE.
MORTGAGE SHOW YOU ABOUT
INTERFERENCE FROM FOREIGN
ENTITIES JUST KEEP YOUR EYES ON
THE THE DARK.
THE DARK --
COLUMNS THERE THAT SHOWS THAT IN
THE RUN UP TO THE ELECTION WHEN
WE HAD AN EXPLOSION OF HEAT
VIOLENCE.
I THINK RUSSIANADVISE ON
FACEBOOK [inaudible]
TRIPLE.
JUST IN THE MONTH BEFORE.
AND HERE ARE SOME OF THE FAKE
THAT BY THE WAY THIS IS NOT A
REAL REPUBLICAN.
OUR TWITTER FEED THIS IS A FAKE
RUSSIAN TWITTER FEED.
SAYING OBAMA WANTS OUR CHILDREN
CONVERTED TO ISLAM HILLARY WILL
CONTINUE THE MISSION.
HERE'S ANOTHER ONE BY THE SAME
--
RUSSIAN ENTITY TALKING ABOUT
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE.
SO AT A TIME WHEN WE ARE AT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE THERE ARE
FOREIGN ENTITIES THAT ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THAT VULNERABILITY.
HERE'S WHAT HATE CRIMES LOOK
LIKE US IN THE TOP TEN CITIES WE
SEE SINCE ABOUT.
TWENTY THIRTEEN TO FOURTEEN
NATIONALLY THOUGH HE CRIMES
BOTTOMED OUT --
FOR ABOUT A QUARTER CENTURY LOW
IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN I HERE'S AGAIN
ANOTHER REPRESENTATION THAT WE
CAN SEE THAT --
HATE CRIMES --
PEAKED AROUND A TWO THOUSAND ONE
ALTHOUGH A RACIAL HATE CRIMES A
HAD THOSE SURPRISES DURING THE
NINETIES PARTICULARLY --
FOLLOWING SOME CATALYTIC EVENTS
THAT --
EIGHTY ELDERLY SPEAKING TODAY --
THEY SAW SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
ARE AN ANTI SEMITIC CONCERNS BUT
WE WANT TO KEEP YOUR EYE ON IS
THE VIOLENT ONES [inaudible]
BUT IT'S A TRICKLING UP BUT THE
ASSAULT WERE NOT UNTIL MOST
RECENTLY AND WE SAW THAT WITH
ANTI MUSLIM ATTACKS TO ANTI
MUSLIM ATTACKS OR NOW AT A
RECORD THE SHORES ASSAULTS.
OR EVEN MORE SO THEM AFTER NINE
ELEVEN EVEN THOUGH THE AGGREGATE
NUMBER.
DOES IS IT WAS NOT AS GREAT.
I HATE GROUPS IN THE UNITED
STATES HAD RISEN AS WELL AND
CALIFORNIA FOR THE SECOND YEAR
IN A ROW --
HAS THE MOST HE GROUPS ACCORDING
TO MY OLD COLLEAGUES AT SOUTHERN
POVERTY LAW CENTER.
KEEP YOUR EYE ON THIS AS YOU ALL
RIGHT.
ORGANIZATIONS AND LEADERSHIP
HAVE IMPLODED THERE IS STILL A
VERY BIG ELASTIC POOL OF FOLKS.
WHO AGREE WITH WHITE NATIONALISM
9% IF YOU LOOK AT THE FAR RIGHT
9% OF AMERICANS ACCORDING TO AN
ABC WASHINGTON POST?
POLL OF LAST YEAR SAID THAT NOT
SHE VIEWS ARE ACCEPTABLE.
AS WE'VE SEEN WE'VE HAD AN
INCREASE.
IN HATE CRIMES IN CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND INCREASED DENSITIES
TEND TO BE LARGER THAN THE
OVERALL INCREASES.
I AND THAT WE FIND BOTH
NATIONALLY AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA HE CRIMES IN CITIES
ROSE 19% ACCORDING TO OUR STUDY
AND SEVENTEEN POINT 4% IN THE
STATE OVERALL ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA AGING.
AND AND THERE WE HAVE --
THEY'RE THEY'RE CHARGING --
IT AGAIN FOR A RACE CONTINUES TO
BE THE THE THE LARGEST A COHORT.
OF VICE MOTIVATIONS --
IN IN THE STATE BUT WE ALSO SEE
IT'S ORIENTATION IF YOU LOOK AT
THAT ABOUT HALF OF THE RACE.
CRIMES OF OR AGAINST AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND HALF OF THE
RELIGION CRIMES OR AGAINST
JEWISH PEOPLE.
MOST RECENTLY IN THE FIRST HALF
OF THE YEAR THIS IS THE LATEST
STUDY NOT AVAILABLE ANYWHERE
JUST RELEASED THIS WEEK.
BUT SHOWING THAT HATE CRIMES IN
THE FIRST HALF OF THE YEAR IN
MANY OF THE MAJOR CITIES ARE
ACTUALLY DE NOW BUT REMEMBER A
LOT EAST COAST CITIES HAD BAD
WEATHER FOR CONSTRUCTIVE
SNOWSTORMS IN MARCH ALONE.
AND ALSO THERE SEEMS TO BE AN
INCREASE GOING ON WITH RESPECT
TO AS THE YEAR PROGRESSES.
BUT LOOKING AWAY AGAIN REMEMBER
WHAT I TOLD ABOUT ASSAULT.
HE CRIMES IN LOS ANGELES FOR THE
FIRST HAVE TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
YOU'RE NOT SEEN AS ANYWHERE ELSE
THIS IS JUST OUT THIS WEEK --
WELL THE HATE CRIMES HAVE
DECREASED IN LA FEE DECREASE
LESS.
THEN ANY OF THE CITIES THAT
SHOULD HAVE SHOWN A DECREASE AND
MOREOVER THE VIOLENT HATE CRIMES
LOOK IN THE MIDDLE THERE.
CRIMINAL THREATS ASSAULTS
AGGRAVATED ASSAULT OR PULL UP
AND IN THE SECOND QUARTER HATE
CRIMES IN LA WENT UP.
WHAT ELSE DO I WANT TO SHOW YOU
LOOK AT THAT?
IF YOU LOOK AT THE FAR RIGHT.
THAT SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT NUMBER
THAT BOX CHEN DUTCH NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY SIXTEEN THAT WAS THE
WORST MONTH FOR HATE CRIME IN
THE COUNTRY.
SINCE THE FIRST ANNIVERSARY OF
NINE ELEVEN SHOOTING SAYING IS
THE CYCLIC HOURLY THE ANNUAL
CYCLIC COUNTY THAT WE SEE WITH
HATE CRIMES CHANGED IT USED TO
BE.
THAT IT WAS MORE EARLIER IN THE
YEAR AND NOW IT'S COMING LEADER
PROJECT WE WHEN WE HAVE CONFLICT
CONFLICTS WILL ELECTIONS. THREE
DAYS AFTER THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION WITH THE WORST THREE
DAYS FOR CALIFORNIA THE ONLY
DAYS WE HAD DOUBLE DIGIT NUMBER
OF HATE CRIMES IN CALIFORNIA WAS
IN THE THREE CONSECUTIVE DAYS.
AFTER THE THE LAST ELECTION
SOARING SAYING IS YES IT'S NICE
THEY WERE HAVING A DECLINE BUT
WE MIGHT BE IN A QUIET APPEARED
DURING THE EYE OF THE STORM.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW.
VIEW YOUR AGAIN YOU SEE THE
INCREASE FROM ELECTION DAY
FORWARD WE SAW SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES.
WELL ALMOST A TRIPLING.
IN THE DAYS FOLLOWING.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDIT.
CONCLUDED LAW ENFORCEMENT IS NOT
BEEN DOING ENOUGH TO IDENTIFY
REPORT RESPOND TO THESE CRIMES
AND I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT BUT THE
COMPONENT PARTS THAT WE HAVE.
OR GOOD WHAT WE DO NEED IS
COORDINATION TRAINING
[inaudible]
OUTREACH.
POLICIES AND LEADERSHIP SO EACH
ENTITY ERA OF THIS CHAIN.
KNOWS WHAT THEY'RE DOING WITH
RESPECT TO THE REST AND THERE'S
SOME KIND OF CONTINUING ABILITY
TO MEET AND COORDINATE OVER TIME
NOT JUST A ONE OFF AND IN
PARTICULAR WHAT I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUT IS TO REVOLVE WILL
COMMUNITIES.
THAT REALLY DO NEED THIS OUTRAGE
SUCH OF THE TRANSGENDER
COMMUNITY THE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY WHICH I WOULD HOPE
MAYBE WE COULD MAKE.
LAWS THAT ARE BETTER TO PROTECT
THEM WITH RESPECT TO REPORTING
CRIMES IN GENERAL --
AND HE CRIME AS WELL AND ALSO DO
AND YOU'LL HEAR FROM A FOLKS IN
THAT COMMUNITY AS WELL WHAT
WE'VE SEEN NATIONALLY BUREAU OF
JUSTICE STATISTICS THE BIGGEST
GAP WITH RESPECT.
TO UNDER REPORTING IS OFTEN WITH
THOSE MOST VULNERABLE
ESPECIALLY.
THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY I WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR HAVING ME
TODAY --
THIS LEGISLATURE IS SO WONDERFUL
I I THINK THAT YOU WERE TAKEN TO
HEART THE MESSAGE FROM.
OUR PRESIDENT GEORGE WASHINGTON
WHO TOLD THE TOURO SYNAGOGUE IN
SEVENTEEN NINETY WE GIVE. TO
BIGOTRY NO SANCTION TO PRODUCE
NO WHICH EXISTENCE YOU ARE
MAKING THIS HAPPEN THE MAIN
THING THAT WE HAVE TO DO IS TO
UNDERSTAND THESE LAWS ARE NOT
SELF EXECUTING AND WHAT WE HAVE
TO DO.
IS TAKE THOSE COMPONENT PARTS
WHICH WE DO WORK TOGETHER SO
WELL AND GIVE THEM A BIT OF A
TUNE UP AND THAT'S WHERE I THINK
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO DO THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW WE HEAR
FROM THE AUDITOR'S.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
CHAIRMAN MERIT TUCCI FOR THE
RECORD MY NAME IS ELAINE HOWELL
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR.
ACCOMPANIED BY ON MY LEFT IS
KATHLEEN FULLER TEN MS FULLERTON
WAS THE AUDIT MANAGER ON THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT ON MY RIGHT
IS NICK PHELPS MISTER PHELPS WAS
ONE OF THE TEAM MEMBERS ON THE
PROJECT.
I'M I WILL BRIEFLY DISCUSS OUR
SCOPE AND HIGH LEVEL KATHLEEN IS
GOING TO GO OVER AT A HIGH LEVEL
THE THE KEY FINDINGS THAT WE HAD
IN THE AUDIT REPORT.
MISTER PHELPS WILL BE DISCUSSING
THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
CURRENT STATUS AS YOU KNOW
MEMBERS AFTER WE ISSUE AN AUDIT
REPORT -- WE
EXPECT FOLLOW UP RESPONSES FROM
EACH OF THE ENTITIES THAT WE'VE
AUDITED AT AT SIXTY DAY SIX
MONTH AND ONE YEAR SINCE WE
ISSUED THIS REPORT ON MAY THIRTY
FIRST.
WE HAVE RECEIVED A SIXTY DAY
RESPONSE AND WE DO HAVE --
STATUS INFORMATION FOR YOU ARE
WITH RESPECT TO DOJ THE LOCAL
ENTITIES THAT WE VISITED AND
POST OP.
THE COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING AND
MISTER PHELPS WILL GO THROUGH.
AGAIN AT A HIGH LEVEL IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE STATUS OF
THOSE THERE HAS BEEN --
PROGRESS MADE PARTICULAR.
BUT AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL MISTER
CHU AND MISTER LEVINE I KNOW YOU
REMEMBER THE REQUEST OF MISTER
RICHARDS YOU OF COURSE --
WAS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT APPROVED THE
AUDIT ASKED US TO LOOK AT DOJ
WHAT KIND OF GUIDANCE OR THEY
PROVIDING --
WHAT TYPE OF OVERSIGHT AS YOU
KNOW DOJ IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
COLLECTING INFORMATION FROM
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
ULTIMATELY WE COULD?
ACCOMPLISH CONDUCTING --
AN OVERALL ANNUAL REPORT
SUBMITTING THAT INFORMATION TO
THE FBI SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT LOCALS REPORT CORRECT
INFORMATION TO DOJ SO WE LOOKED
AT WHAT IS DOJ DOING FIGHT
OVERSIGHT PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO
LOCALS.
KEY KEY ISSUE AND THE REPORT OR
KEY WORK THAT WE DID IS VISITING
LOCAL ENTITIES AS YOU INDICATED
MISTER CHIU WE VISITED.
A LOS ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT.
ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF STANISLAUS
COUNTY SHERIFF AND AT THE
REQUEST OF THE MEMBERS WE WENT
TO A CAMPUS POLICE AND THAT WAS
SAN FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY
POLICE.
OUT TO SEE WHAT THEY WERE DOING
FIRST OF ALL TO PROPERLY
IDENTIFY.
HATE CRIMES ARE MAKING SURE THAT
THEY'RE IDENTIFYING THEM
APPROPRIATELY REPORTING THEM TO
DOJ SO THAT THEY DO ULTIMATELY
GET REPORTED TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO THE FBI AND TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ON AND THEN YOU ASKED US TO ALSO
SURVEY OTHER LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO GET A BETTER
PICTURE STATEWIDE.
OF WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH RESPECT
TO POLICIES PROCEDURES TRAINING
FOR OFFICERS OUT REACH IN THE
COMMUNITY THOSE SORTS OF THINGS
SO THAT WAS THE AND NOT SHELVE
THE SCOPE OF WHAT WE WERE ASKED
TO DO -- KEY
FINDINGS AND AND SEVERAL AREAS
FIRST OF ALL IDENTIFICATION AND
AGAIN MISS FULLER TEN WILL GO
THROUGH THESE IN MORE DETAIL BUT
WE FOUND PROBLEMS WITH PROPER
IDENTIFICATION OF HATE CRIMES
SOMEWHERE I IDENTIFIED AS AN
INCIDENT RATHER THAN A CRIME SO
IT'S NOT GONNA BE REPORTED.
SO IMPROPER IDENTIFICATION UNDER
REPORTING EVEN THOUGH SOME OF
THE LOCALS HAD IDENTIFIED A
CRIME AS A HATE CRIME IT HAD NOT
BEEN REPORTED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND AGAIN THAT DID
NOT ULTIMATELY END UP IN AN
ANNUAL REPORT.
OR REPORTED TO THE FBI NOW IN
WASHINGTON.
WE LOOKED AT UP PROSECUTION
RATES WE DUG VISITED OF THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IS IN
THE FOUR LOCATIONS ON THAT I
TALKED ABOUT SAN FRANCISCO
ORANGE.
A LOS ANGELES AND STANISLAUS
COUNTY --
AND TALK TO THE DA'S ABOUT THEIR
PROCESS FOR PROSECUTING HATE
CRIMES AND WHAT THE ISSUES WERE
UP BECAUSE WE FOUND THAT THE
PROSECUTION RIGHT THE SUCCESSFUL
PROSECUTION IS MUCH LOWER THAN
OTHER TYPES OF FELONIES AND
WE'LL HAVE SOME INFORMATION
RELATED TO THAT. TWO OTHER KEY
ISSUES RELATED TO THE DATABASE
THE ACCURACY OF THE INFORMATION
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
HAS IN ITS DATABASE PART OF THE
PROBLEM IS THE LOCALS.
NOT REPORTING EVERYTHING --
DOJ WE BELIEVE CAN AS YOU SAID
MISTER MERRETT TUCCI REALLY SHOW
LEADERSHIP ARE IN THIS AREA
AGAIN AND MISTER PHELPS WILL
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE TO THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE AND THE
ACTION THEY'VE ALREADY TAKEN.
A WITHIN THE IF THE FIRST SIXTY
DAYS AFTER WE ISSUED A REPORT
AND THEN OUTREACH TO VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AGAIN IS A STATE
DOING ANYTHING FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE BUT CERTAINLY
FOCUSED A LOT OF EFFORTS WHEN
WE'RE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AT THE
LOCAL ENTITIES WHAT ARE YOU
DOING. TO PROVIDE OUTREACH TO
THESE VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES TO
MAKE SURE.
HOPEFULLY GET THEM COMFORTABLE
IN COMING FORWARD AND REPORTING
--
AN INCIDENT THAT.
ULTIMATELY WILL IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD IS A HATE CRIME SO
THOSE WERE THE KEY AREAS THAT WE
LOOKED AT I'M I'M GONNA HAND IT
OVER TO MS FULLERTON AND SHE CAN
GET INTO MORE SPECIFICS ON EACH
OF THE AT THE KEY AREAS.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU KATHLEEN
FULLERTON STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
--
SO AS A SENATOR MENTIONS WE HAD
SEVERAL KEY FINDINGS AND THE
FIRST ONE IS THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS NOT PROPERLY
IDENTIFYING HE CRIMES.
SO THREE OF THE FOUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND SEES THAT WE
VISITED --
EXPERIENCE THIS ISSUE WHERE THEY
ARE IN FACT --
RECORDING A AN EVENT AT AS
SOMETHING OTHER THAN HE CRIME
THERE EITHER RECORDING AS A HEAT
INCIDENT WHICH IS NOT CONSIDERED
A CRIME.
OR THEY ARE RECORDING INTO SOME
OTHER TYPE OF CRIME.
SO AT LAPD WHAT WE FOUND IS
ABOUT 20% OF THE FIFTEEN CRIMES
WE REVIEWED WERE INAPPROPRIATELY
A CLASSIFIED AS A HEAT INCIDENT
RATHER THAN A HATE CRIME. 53% OF
THE FIFTEEN WE REVIEWED AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE WERE ALSO
CLASSIFIED AS HEAT INCIDENTS
RATHER THAN HATE CRIMES.
AND THEN AT ORANGE COUNTY
SHERIFF WE FOUND --
ONE INSTANCE OF A CRIME THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN CLASSIFIED AS A
HATE CRIME BUT AGAIN WAS NOT.
SO WE FOUND THAT THIS IS A A
PERVASIVE ISSUE OF THREE OF THE
FOUR ENTITIES THAT WE VISITED.
AND ULTIMATELY THIS RESULTS IN
THESE CRY BEING REPORTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AS HATE
CRIMES AND THEREFORE UNDER
REPORTING THAT THE CRIMES THAT
EXISTED WITHIN THESE FLEAS THREE
JURISDICTIONS.
AND THERE ARE THREE PRIMARY
CAUSES WE FOUND OF THIS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND THE FIRST ONE IS
INADEQUATE TOOLS AN EXAMPLE OF
THIS IS A SUPPLEMENTAL HEAT
CREDIT REPORT.
AND WHAT THIS IS IS A AS A FORUM
THAT PATROL OFFICERS CAN USE TO
HELP THEM IDENTIFY WHAT TYPE OF
EVIDENCE IS NECESSARY TO
IDENTIFY A HATE CRIME.
WHAT TYPE OF VICTIMS THEY SHOULD
BE INTERVIEWING WHAT TYPE OF
EVIDENCE THAT SHOULD BE
GATHERING?
AND WE FOUND THAT THE
SUPPLEMENTAL HE CRIME REPORTS
WERE ONLY USED A TWO OF THE FOUR
ENTITIES WE REVIEWED --
IS AN ORANGE COUNTY AND
STANISLAUS DIDN'T USE THAT I
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT POST
RECOMMENDS IS A IS A REALLY
CRITICAL TOOL TO USE.
WHEN IDENTIFYING HATE CRIMES?
AND THE SECOND ISSUE WE FOUND AS
A CAUSE WAS INADEQUATE POLICIES
SO SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY FOR EXAMPLE.
WAS ARE USING INCORRECT
STATUTORY DEFINITION OF HATE
CRIMES IN THEIR POLICY AND AS A
RESULT THEIR OFFICERS WERE NOT
ABLE TO CORRECTLY IDENTIFY
CRIMES.
AND FINALLY TRAINING --
AND PERIODIC TRAINING IS
ACTUALLY NOT REQUIRED OF
OFFICERS IT'S ONLY REQUIRED ONE
TIME AND THAT'S WHEN THAT THE
POLICE OFFICER ACADEMY.
AND WE FOUND THAT THIS IS AGAIN
IS A BIG ISSUE NOT AT THE NOT
JUST THE FOR ENTITIES WE VISITED
BUT STATEWIDE.
WE FOUND THAT 50% OF OUR SURVEY
RESPONDENTS --
IT PROVIDED NO SORT OF PERIODIC
REFRESHER TRAINING REGARDING
HATE CRIMES.
AS WE KNOW THESE ARE NOT STATIC
ISSUES THEY REALLY REQUIRE UP TO
DATE KNOWLEDGE ON WHAT'S GOING
ON AND UNFORTUNATELY --
AT LEAST HALF SEE WIDER.
REFRESHER TRAINING FOR THEIR
OFFICER.
OUR SECOND KEY FINING RELATES TO
PROSECUTION AND THE BIG ISSUE
THERE ARE WAS THAT PROSECUTORS
ARE ONLY AVERAGING CONVICTION
RATES AT ABOUT HALF THE RATE FOR
HE CRIMES.
THAN THEY ARE FOR ALL FELONIES
OF THE STATE SETS ABOUT 46% BY
THE PROSECUTION RATE FOR HATE
CRIMES.
VERSES 84% FOR ALL TYPES OF
FELONIES --
THEY'RE A LOT OF FACTORS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO THIS OF A PRIMARY
ONE IS PROVING MOTIVE THAT'S
DIFFICULT TO PROVE.
A SUSPECT'S MOTIVE TO GET A HATE
CRIME CONVICTION.
BUT WHEN WE INTERVIEWED THE FOR
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS WHAT WE FOUND
WAS A LACK OF IDENTIFIABLE
SUSPECTS THIS IS ABOUT 30%.
OF OF HATE CRIMES ACTUALLY DON'T
HAVE A SUSPECT IT'S IDENTIFIED
AT ALL WHICH CONTRIBUTES TO
DIFFICULTY IN PROSECUTION.
WE ALSO FOUND LACK OF SUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT PROSECUTORS SAID WAS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THEM.
WHEN THEY'RE TRYING TO PROSECUTE
HATE CRIMES IT IT HAVE ENOUGH
EVIDENCE AND ACTUALLY POINTED TO
WORKING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT --
IN A BETTER WAY SUCH AS USING A
SUPPLEMENTAL HE CRIME REPORT
WHICH WOULD ASSIST THOSE
PROSECUTORS AND HAVING BETTER
EVIDENCE TO CONVICT.
THOSE SUSPECTS OF HATE CRIMES.
I IS A STATE ARE MENTIONED ALSO
UNDER REPORTING IS A BIG ISSUE
SO THIS IS AND THIS IS IN
ADDITION TO IDENTIFICATION OF
HATE CRIMES THIS IS HOW WELL OUR
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND SEES
REPORTING THE HATE CRIMES THAT
DO A CAR.
HOW WELL ARE THEY REPORTING
THOSE ISSUES TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND ULTIMATELY TO THE
FBI?
AND WE FOUND THAT THERE ARE SOME
ISSUES THERE AS WELL IN
PARTICULAR 14%.
OF THE HATE CRIMES THAT OCCURRED
IN OUR FOR JURISDICTIONS WERE
NOT REPORTED TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
AND THE MAJORITY OF THAT TOOK
PLACE AT THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
AND AGAIN WHAT WE FOUND THERE IN
TERMS OF CAUSE WAS LACK OF
OVERSIGHT LACK OF ADEQUATE
POLICIES --
ON AT THE LOT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT LEVEL.
BUT WE ALSO REALLY FELT LIKE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE COULD DO
MORE TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT AND
GUIDANCE TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES.
WITH RESPECT TO REPORTING.
OUT WE REACHED OUT TO TO ALL OF
THEM -- ALL
OF THE FOR WE DISCUSSED WE AND
THEY ALL FELT LIKE ADDITIONAL
GUIDANCE BY ONE FIRST OR BY
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL.
IN FACT OVER 80% STATEWIDE OF
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
THAT WE SURVEYED SAID THEY WOULD
LIKE MORE GUIDANCE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
RELATED TO REPORTING HATE CRIMES
THERE'S DEFINITELY SOME
CONFUSION THERE THAT COULD BE
ALLEVIATED IF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WERE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL OUTREACH --
SO WE REALLY --
FOUND THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS UNIQUELY POSITIONED
TO PROVIDE THIS SORT OF GUIDANCE
AND OVERSIGHT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND THEY DO HAVE MANY
RESPONSIBILITIES WITH READ
RELATION TO COLLECTING ANALYZING
AND REPORTING HATE CRIME
STATISTICS --
AND THEY ALSO HAVE A UNIQUE ROLE
IN PROVIDING GUIDANCE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR OUTREACH.
AND SOME OF THE EVIDENCE WE
REVIEWED SUGGESTS THAT OVER 50%
OF HATE CRIMES ARE NOT EVEN
REPORTED TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND TWO OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WE REVIEWED SAID
PROVIDING OUTREACH TO THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES IS HELPFUL --
AND TARGETED OUTREACH IN
PARTICULAR.
AND SO --
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AGAIN
HAS THAT ROLE WHERE THEY CAN
LOOK AT P. CRIMES ON A STATEWIDE
LEVEL AND PROVIDE THAT SORT OF
TARGETED OUTREACH TO THE LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
AND AGAIN OVER 80% OF THEM SAID
THAT THEY WOULD REALLY BENEFIT
FROM THIS TYPE OF RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
--
IN PARTICULAR ANALYZING WHERE
THE HATE CRIMES ARE OCCURRING
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTIONS AND
POTENTIALLY GETTING ADDITIONAL
GUIDANCE FOR HOW THEY MIGHT
BETTER ENGAGE WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES. TO ENCOURAGE MORE
HATE CRIME REPORTING --
AT MISTER PHELPS IS GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE IN
RELATION TO THIS --
AND PARTICULARLY ONCE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
INCREASING THAT BITES AND
OUTREACH.
WE GOT MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY PHELPS WITH
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE.
I AS A RESULT OF THIS AUDIT WE
MAY TWENTY ONE RECOMMENDATIONS.
SEVEN TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE SEVEN TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY SIX TO LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
SEVEN TO THE STATE LEGISLATURE
--
OF THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS WE HAD
SEVERAL KEY RECOMMENDATIONS --
THE FIRST WAS TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
TO REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO ADD REGION SPECIFIC
HATE CRIME FIELDS. TO TAKE CRIME
DATABASE.
OUR NEXT KEY RECOMMENDATION WAS
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AND IT WAS FOR THEM TO UTILIZE
THOSE DATA FIELDS PROVIDE --
ADDITIONAL ANALYSIS.
AND PROVIDE NOTIFICATION TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
I WANTED TO TAX CROSS
JURISDICTIONAL IT CRIMES
OCCURRING.
AT THE LOCAL AGENCY LEVEL OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE FOR THE
AGENCIES.
TO UPDATE CERTAIN FACETS OF
THEIR HATE CRIME POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES.
AND MAKE USE OF THE SUPPLEMENTAL
A CRIME REPORTING FORMS
RECOMMENDED BY POST.
OFFER POST ITSELF WE RECOMMENDED
THAT THEY PROVIDE COPIES OF
THEIR HATE CRIME REFRESHER
TRAINING. TWO THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THAT THEY
CERTIFY --
AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER WE
RECENTLY RECEIVED THE SIXTY DAY
FOLLOW UP RESPONSES --
FROM THE AGENCIES THAT WE
AUDITED.
OF THE SIX AGENCIES THAT WE MADE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO FIVE PROVIDE
RESPONSES.
WITH THE ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE RESPONSE DEPENDING --
OTHERS RESPONSES THAT WE
REVIEWED VIA.
DOES THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
HAS FULLY IMPLEMENTED ONE
RECOMMENDATION TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL NOTIFICATION RELATED
TO THEIR HATE CRIME RAPID
RESPONSE TASK SINCE.
HAS PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTED FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND AS TWO RECOMMENDATIONS
PENDING.
AT THE LOCAL AGENCY LEVEL --
LAPD HAS INDICATED THAT WILL NOT
IMPLEMENT ONE OF OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND HAS ONE RECOMMENDATION
PENDING.
THE STANISLAUS COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE HAS NOT YET TAKEN A
ACTION WITH REGARD TO A
RECOMMENDATION.
AND THE SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY HAS FULLY IMPLEMENTED
ONE RECOMMENDATION TO UPDATE
THEIR HATE CRIME POLICY AND
PROCEDURES.
AT HAS PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTED
ANOTHER RECOMMENDATION.
AND FINALLY POST HAS FULLY
IMPLEMENTED OUR RECOMMENDATION
TO PROVIDE THE REFRESHER HE
CRAMMED TRAINING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
QUESTION PAULA DEUS ARE LIKE
ALSO RECOGNIZE US SENATOR ALLEN.
JUST JOIN US SENATOR.
NO YOU'RE HAVING CERTAIN THANK
YOU UNLESS CHAIRMAN US SO WELL
AT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION YOU KNOW I I I'VE
BEEN NO --
INVOLVED IN ONE FORM OR ANOTHER
ON THIS ISSUE OF HATE CRIMES.
FOR EVER SINCE A MY COLLEGE DAYS
BACK IN IN BERKELEY IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES BETTER YOU
KNOW IT'S IT SEEMS LIKE A ONE
CONSISTENT THEME --
SINCE THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES
SINCE MY INVOLVEMENT WITH THIS
ISSUE HAS BEEN THIS [inaudible]
THIS SIR --
ONGOING CHALLENGE OF OF OF OF OF
THE REPORTING OF THE DATA AND
YOU KNOW.
I MEAN IT THE IT IT'D TO WHAT
EXTENT IS THE UNDER REPORTING OF
DATA IN ISSUE WHERE YOU KNOW WE
HAVE TO EVEN --
HAVE SOME LEVEL OF NOT
SKEPTICISM BUT EBAY BUT OF OF
CAUTION IN TERMS OF IDENTIFYING
TRENDS OR OR OR OR HAD A DENT.
IN OUR OUR OUR WE SUFFICIENTLY
CONFIDENT THAT THAT EVEN THOUGH
THERE.
THE ACTUAL INCIDENT.
IT'S REPORTED IN NO --
ARE ARE DOCUMENTED THAT THAT
THEY THEY REFLECT THE OVERALL
TREND LINE IN TERMS OF HATE
CRIMES --
YES PLEASE.
THE DATA THAT WE HAVE IS
ACTUALLY VERY GOOD FOR OVERALL
TREND ANALYSIS WHAT IT IS NOT
GOOD AT IS LOOKING AT PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES.
SO WHAT WERE SEEING IS FOR
INSTANCE IT IS IF WE HAD A
THOUSAND RAIN BUCKETS.
PLACE THROUGHOUT THE STATE BUT
HALF OF THEM WERE KICKED OVER.
AND IT HAVE ANOTHER KICKED OVER
OR IN A CERTAIN PART OF THE
STATE.
OR RELATE TO CERTAIN COMMUNITIES
LIKE THE DISABLED COMMUNITY OR
AS WE'VE SEEN IN IN MANY RURAL
AND NORTHERN PART OF THE STATE
WHERE WE HAVE BEEN HAD HE CRIME
PROSECUTION FOR MANY MANY YEARS.
THEN IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
ACCURATE BUT WHAT I CAN SAY IS
THE DATA THAT I SHOWED YOU WITH
REGARD TO THE RISING HEAT CRIME
BOTH NATIONALLY IN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IS CONFIRMED RIVER VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT --
COHORTS SO THE OVERALL TRENDS --
I THINK WELL I'M WE'RE WE'RE
VERY CONFIDENT.
BUT WHAT I CAN ALSO TELL YOU IS
THERE IS A MASSIVE UNDER
REPORTING AND THAT MASSIVE AND
REPORTING --
HURTS PARTICULAR COMMUNITIES
MORE THAT I THE HUB CERTAIN
BARRIERS SUCH AS LINGUISTIC
BARRIERS OR OR OR BERRIES WITH
RESPECT TO VULNERABILITIES
BECAUSE OF AGE OR OR OR OR
IMPAIRMENT.
AND ALSO CERTAIN A CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES ARE DID HAVE A IN
ATTENUATED RELATIONSHIP WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO OVERALL THE
TRENDS --
YES I THINK --
WE CAN DISCERN THAT DID INDEED
OCCUR WHAT WE'RE NOT GETTING IS
FOR SOME COMMUNITIES A WE
BELIEVE --
THAT GET UP THERE IS A SILENT
WAVE OF HATE CRIME THAT IS JUST
NOT REGISTERING INTO THE INTO
THE DATA [inaudible]
ALRIGHT THANK YOU AND DEATH OF
FOR THE STATE AUDITOR I
APPRECIATE --
YOU KNOW YOUR FOCUS ON THE
REFORMS THAT NEED TO TAKE PLACE
WITHIN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND I
LOOK FORWARD. TO TO HEARING FROM
--
REPRESENTATIVES FROM.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AS WELL AS FROM THE
COMMISSION ON A PEACE OFFICER
STANDS IN TRAINING --
BUT I AYE AYE ANECDOTALLY I'VE
EVER HEARD OVER THE YEARS THAT
--
THERE THERE ARE THERE ARE --
SOME IN LAW ENFORCEMENT --
YOU NO WHO --
HAVE A SOMEWHAT DISMISSIVE
ATTITUDE IN TERMS OF THE ALL THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR HATE
CRIMES YOU KNOW THEY THEY FEEL
THAT THEY'RE THEY THEY WOULD
RATHER.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE THEY THEY THEY
THEY BECAME COPS YOU KNOW. TO TO
GO GET THE BAD GUYS NOT TO FILL
OUT A BUNCH OF FORMS AND AYE AYE
--
IN OF THAT THAT SEEMS TO BE
CONTRIBUTING.
TO THE THE THE THE PROBLEM OF
UNDER REPORTING --
AND AND PERHAPS REFLECTS A YOU
KNOW.
THE OF A CULTURAL ISSUE WITHIN
THE WITHIN LAW ENFORCEMENT --
THEM AVERY BE REFLECTED IN TERMS
OF HOW MUCH OF A PRIORITY IT IS
TO UPDATE THEIR POLICIES TO
PROVIDE.
THE THE THE SUPPLEMENTAL FORMS
RECOMMENDED BY POSTER.
AN AND SO FORTH THE DID YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY OF THAT --
IN IN.
AND IN THE AUDIT.
I WOULDN'T SAY THAT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WE TALKED
TO WERE OVERLY DISMISSIVE --
VERY ADMINISTRATIVE REQUIREMENTS
WITH RESPECT TO THIS --
BUT THEY CERTAINLY WERE IT
WASN'T A PRIORITY FOR THEM --
AND THEY REALLY DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE NUANCES
OF WHAT WAS REQUIRED AND THEY
CERTAINLY DIDN'T HAVE AT LEAST
IN OUR IN OUR OPINION ENOUGH
CONTACT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO EVEN UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO DO.
THERE WERE SOME
MISUNDERSTANDINGS ABOUT THE
TIMING THAT THESE CRIMES WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE REPORTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE --
THAT IN AGAIN BECAUSE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS A ROLE
TO COLLECT ANALYZE AND REPORT ON
THESE DATA IT'S REALLY THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
UNDERSTANDS PRIMARILY WHAT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE AND ONCE WE
DISCUSSED WITH THEM ACTUALLY
WHAT THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES
WHERE THEY DEFINITELY WERE
RECEPTIVE TO CHANGING THEM. ONE
OF THE POLICIES THAT SAM CISCO
STATE THEY'VE ALREADY UPDATED IT
TO CHANGE IT BUT THEY WEREN'T
AWARE THAT IT WAS EVEN WRONG IN
THE FIRST.
DID YOU MAKE ANY RECOMMENDATIONS
IF YOU HAVE ANY RECOMMENDATIONS.
HOW TO MAKE THAT THE REPORTING
OF HATE CRIMES MORE FOR
PRIORITY?
WITH A LONG FORCE.
WE KNOW WE DON'T HAVE ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS SPECIFIC TO THAT
IN TERMS OF PRIORITIZING IT BUT
WE DO TALK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF REACHING OUT TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES --
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF BUILDING
TRUST WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITIES
TO ENCOURAGE MORE ABOUT
REPORTING --
AND AND WE DID SEE A TREND AND
AND SOME OF THE AGENCIES WE WENT
TO OF UNDERSTANDING THAT IT'S
BECOMING MORE OF A PRIORITY.
IT JUST AT LEAST WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND CULTURALLY
IDENTIFYING THAT IT IS A PROBLEM
AND BEGINNING STRATEGOI
SOLUTIONS IN TERMS OF REALLY
ENGAGING WITH THEIR COMMUNITIES.
I I JUST THAT YOU KNOW CAN'T
HELP BUT FEEL THAT --
YOU KNOW WHY I THINK JUST LIKE
CRIME RATES CAN BE --
POLITICALLY SENSITIVE --
YOU KNOW WHERE COMMUNITY MAY NOT
WANT [inaudible]
TO YOU KNOW --
BE IDENTIFIED AS IS IS HAVING A
HIGH CRIME RATE IRVINE IN THE
CASE OF HATE CRIME.
THAT THERE MAY BE.
THEIR RELUCTANCE TO YOU KNOW TO
TO REPORT ALL OF THE INCIDENTS
IN THE COMMUNITIES FOR FEAR THAT
IT BE --
BRANDED AS A AS A RACIST OR ANTI
SEMITIC OR ANTI GAY YOU KNOW
WELL I HATEFUL COMMUNITY --
ANY ANY ERA.
AND ANY OBSERVATIONS IN TERMS OF
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES SAY
YOU [inaudible]
VISITED --
COM TO TRY TO ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE.
WE DIDN'T FIND ANY EVIDENCE OF
THAT AS THE CAUSE OF OF THE
ISSUES WE IDENTIFIED A WE DID
LOOK AT DIFFERENT TYPES OF CASES
RANDOM SAMPLES A AND WE DIDN'T
FIND THAT THERE IS ANY SORT OF
PATTERN TO CRIMES THAT WANT
REPORTED.
OR IT WE WE CERTAINLY WANT TOLD
BY THE OFFICERS OR THAT THAT
MANAGERS THAT WE REVIEW THAT
THIS WAS AN ISSUE FOR THEM.
OF COURSE ME JUST INTERJECT ON
THAT.
KNOLL BACK IN NINETEEN EIGHTIES
AND IN MY OF BEST PRACTICES
RESEARCH WHICH IS PUBLISHED IN
STANFORD LAW AND POLICY REVIEW
BACK IN.
NINETY THREE FOUNDED LEADERSHIP
POLICY TRAINING AND COORDINATION
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO A POLICE TO
PARTS CAN BE ENCOURAGED TO HAVE
A POINT PERSON.
DOESN'T AND IN MANY SMALLER
AGENCIES ARE DOING A BUNCH OF
OTHER THINGS COULD BE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE LIEUTENANT
SOMEONE WHO'S.
HAS EXPERTISE WAS TASKED WITH
THAT WHO THEN HAS A CONNECTION
TO THE TOP WHEN THE NYPD STARTED
THE BIAS UNIT.
THE PUT IT RIGHT NEXT TO THE TO
THE COMMISSIONER.
THAT GOT OFFICE RIGHT THERE SO
WHEN YOU HAVE EXECUTIVE
LEADERSHIP THAT SAYS THIS IS A
PRIORITY CLEAR POLICIES.
ACCORDING TO THE PERSON WHO'S A
POINT PERSON IN EACH AGENCY AND
THEN SOMEONE WITHIN THAT
COMMUNITY COULD BE A MAYOR COULD
BE THE FBI SPECIAL AGENT IN
CHARGE WHOEVER.
WE FIND IT WORKING GROUPS BUT DO
WELL AND THAT'S WHY WE WERE
ENCOURAGED BY THE AG WHO INVITED
A BUNCH OF US. TO TO MEET WITH
WITH YOUR EXPERTS AND I THINK
IT'S GOT TO BE CONTINUING
ONGOING THING BUT AS A FORMER
NYPD THIRD GENERATION.
I CAN TELL YOU ONE THING.
LINE OFFICES WILL RESPOND TO
POLICIES AND A MESSAGE FROM THE
TOP AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
MORE AMORPHOUS YOU CAN LEGISLATE
QUITE A BIT YOU CAN PUT THESE
POLICIES.
BUT IF YOU HAVE SOMEONE FROM THE
TOP SAYING THIS IS A PRIORITY
AND IF YOU DON'T GET THIS RIGHT
DURRELL BE CONSEQUENCES IT MAKES
A DIFFERENCE WE SOUGHT WITH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AND WE SAW WITH RESPECT TO HATE
CRIME RESPONSE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS WELL.
JUST TO ECHO WHAT WAS JUST SAID
IS --
HELPING TO PRIORITIZE FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT WOULD REACH WOULD
REALLY BE AT THE SIZE IN THAT
REFRESHER TRAINING COURSE THOSE
COURSES OVER HALF OF THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WE SURVEYED
DON'T PROVIDE ANY SORT OF
REFRESHER COURSES.
SO IF THAT BECAME A REGULAR PART
OF THE DAILY BUSINESS WAS --
TO INCORPORATES MOST TRAININGS
IN THOSE PHILOSOPHIES FROM THE
TRAINING OF THAT WOULD.
HELP PRIORITIZE THOSE ISSUES FOR
THEM.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M OF THANK YOU HA HIGH I I
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS VIA
SERVER MOMENTO HATE CRIME
REPORT.
AS SOUNDS LIKE IS THIS SO I JUST
CUT BY THE POLLS.
BUT NOT A MANDATORY FOREIGN DEBT
THEY HAVE TO FILL OUT AND IS
REALLY UP TO DO YOU A A LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHO GOOD GOOD GOOD GOOD
DEPRESSING TO DECIDE WHETHER? TO
TO EUSTIS US TO HER MIND TO HATE
NOT IT STAY LAW THAT THEY HAVE
TO ORDER FROM THE DOJ. TO
DICTATE THAT YOU HAVE TO FILL
UP.
THIS MOVE BOAT FORM IF YOU
SUSPECT THAT THERE DECRYING.
THE COMMITTED IT MAY.
WE A HATE CRIME.
YES YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT
THOUGH SOMEONE OF WARMS ARE KIND
OF LEFT TO THE DISCRETION OF THE
VARIOUS AGENCIES.
AND WE DID RECOMMEND LASTED POST
THAT --
IMPLEMENTING THOSE FORMS IS
USEFUL --
AND THAT WAS ALSO ECHOED BY THE
PROSECUTORS THAT WE SPOKE TO IT
SAID THEY CAN PROVIDED
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
AND THEY CAN ASSIST FIELD
OFFICERS IN GOING GATHERING
INFORMATION TO THE PROSECUTOR.
UNDER THEIR AND NORMAL LONGER
REGULAR OF THE CRIME REPORT IS
FEAR OF PLAYS VOTE TRIGGERED.
THE GOOD TO USE OFTEN ADDITIONAL
--
OF SUPERMAN WHO.
WROTE HATE CRIME REPORT --
I THINK THAT TRIGGERING THAT THE
USE OF THAT REPORT IS REALLY UP
TO THE DISCRETION OF THE OFFICE
FROM THE FIELD IF IF THEY GET
THE IMPRESSION THAT THIS MAY BE
A HATE CRIME THEM MAKING.
TAKE THAT FORM AND WALK THROUGH
THE VARIOUS PROCEDURES AND WHO I
KNOW HOW THE BILL WOULD TRYING.
TO ADD ANOTHER CHECKBOX OWN ON
THE A INCIDENT REPORT.
THE SIMPLE QUESTION IS
DESCRIBING RELATE IT A HATE
CRIME LATEST.
AND HOPEFULLY WILL.
PROVIDE --
ABOUT HER.
WHO TRIGGER OR REMINDER TO THE
LYING A OFFICER? TO TO HERE GOT
TO THINK TWICE AND THEN TRIGGER
THEM.
TO FILL UP THIS OF THEM ONTO A
HATE CRIME.
A REPORT SO.
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WILL WAS DREADFUL WILL I HAVE
GINNI UP ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
SENATOR ALLEN.
WILL MOVE ON TO THE SECOND PANEL
[inaudible]
I DON'T --
NO WE WILL NOT GO WERE HERE FROM
--
KEVIN GARDNER TO CHIEF.
CHIEF OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
CALLIE EVANS SPECIAL ASSISTANCE
TO ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THEM A NEW LOW --
OVER US JUNIOR WHO'S TAKES
ACTORS DIRECTOR.
AND THE COMMISSION ALL OF BUT
PEACE OFFICERS.
AND TRAINING POST.
WHO WAS THAT --
WHO'S GOING TO OF HERS I WILL
THINK YOU.
ARE GOOD MORNING CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS I AM KELLY EVANS SPECIAL
ASSISTANT TO ATTORNEY GENERAL
HOW THE AIRBUS ERA.
I'M JOINED THIS MORNING BY CHIEF
KEVIN KEVIN GARDNER.
CHIEF GARDENER IS THE HEAD OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE DIVISION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND WE HAVE WITH US TODAY ALISON
LUNETA SHE'S ONE OF THE MANAGERS
IN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
STATISTICS CENTER.
AND MISS LOU DATA IS AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
DATA THAT IS REPORTED TO DOJ BY
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
AS WELL AS PROVIDE AN UPDATE IF
YOU'D LIKE ABOUT SOME OF THE NEW
--
EXPANDED TRAINING AN UPDATED
TRAINING EFFORTS WE'VE TAKEN AS
A RESULT OF THE AUDIT.
SO I'D I'D LIKE TO BEGIN THIS
MORNING BY THANKING YOU FOR
HOSTING THIS VERY VERY IMPORTANT
HEARING --
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SINCE HIS
APPRECIATION AS WELL AND IN
ADDITION TO TAKING THE CHAIRS
AND THE MEMBERS.
AGB SARAH WOULD LIKE TO THINK
AUDITOR HOUSE THE DOLLAR HELD IN
HER STAFF FOR CONDUCTING THIS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AUDIT.
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND
MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE AS WELL
TODAY.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS SAID
THIS BEFORE BUT I IT IT'S WORTH
REPEATING TODAY HE STRONGLY
BELIEVES THAT.
AN ATTACK ON ANY ONE OF US.
IS AN ATTACK ON THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY ITS ATTACK ON THE
ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS WHY ACCURATE
IDENTIFICATION AND RESPONSE TO
HATE CRIMES BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES.
IS SO IMPORTANT AND IT'S SO.
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
MECHANISM.
TO ENCOURAGE COMMUNITY MEMBERS
TO FEEL COMFORTABLE COMING
FORWARD TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES KNOWING THAT THEY'LL
GET AN ADEQUATE AND APPROPRIATE
RESPONSE WHEN THEY DO COME
FORWARD.
PREVENTING AND EFFECTIVELY
RESPONDING TO HATE CRIMES AND
BIAS IS ESSENTIAL FOR ENSURING
THAT ALL OF US ALL CALIFORNIANS.
CAN LIVE FREELY WITHOUT FEARING
THAT WILL BE TARGETED BASED ON
THINGS LIKE RACE NATIONAL RATE
ORIGIN ARE DISABILITY SEXUAL
ORIENTATION --
ETHNICITY RELIGION OTHER FACTORS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL.
EIJI BAZAR BELIEVES THAT ALL OF
US TOGETHER AS A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY.
HAVE TO STRIVE TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA A PLACE.
THAT IS ONE OF INCLUSION AND
TOLERANCE AND NOT WITHSTANDING
THE DIVISIVE RHETORIC COMING OUT
OF WASHINGTON DC.
AND OTHER PLACES.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WANTS TO
MAKE IT ABSOLUTELY CLEAR.
THAT HIS VIEW HAYDEN BIAS HAVE
NO PLACE IN CALIFORNIA AND I
KNOW THAT --
THE CHAIRS AND MEMBERS OF OF
THIS COMMITTEE IN THE FOLKS IN
THIS ROOM AGREED WITH HIM ON
THAT REGARD.
IT AND THAT'S WHY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IS COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE STATE
AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WE HAVE OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED REPORTING AGENCIES IN
THE STATE.
ON TO MAKE SURE THAT AS A
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY THERE IS
EFFECTIVE RESPONSE TO HATE
CRIMES.
WHEN THEY DO OCCUR?
HE ALSO STRONGLY ENCOURAGES
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN VICTIMS WHO
BELIEVE THEIR VICTIMS OF HATE
CRIMES WHO BELIEVE THEY MAY HAVE
WITNESSED A HATE CRIME TO
CONTACT THEIR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT STAFF TO THE THAT TO
THE COMMITTEE ASKED US TO DO WAS
TO PROVIDE A DEFINITION OF HATE
CRIMES BECAUSE IT'S A TERM THAT
IS USED A LOT.
PEOPLE MAY NOT BE ON THE SAME
PAGE I THINK.
THE THE AUDITOR STAFF DURING
THEIR PRESENTATION MADE A VERY
IMPORTANT DISTINCTION ABOUT HATE
CRIMES VERSUS HATE INCIDENTS
INTO.
HATE INCIDENTS AND HOW THERE'S
SOME CONFUSION SOMETIMES THAT
LEADS TO UNDER REPORTING.
SO A HATE CRIME.
A HATE CRIME IS A CRIMINAL ACT.
COMMITTED AGAINST A PERSON A
GROUP OR PROPERTY.
MOTIVATED IN WHOLE OR EVEN JUST
IN PART.
BY CERTAIN ACTUAL OR PERCEIVED
CHARACTERISTICS OF THE PERSON
THE GROUP OR THE PROPERTY.
NOW THE LAW PROTECTS AGAINST
MANY DIFFERENT TYPES OF HATE
CRIMES.
INCLUDING CRIMES COMMITTED BASED
ON SOMEONE'S ACTUAL OR PERCEIVED
DISABILITY [inaudible]
GENDER.
INCLUDING GENDER IDENTITY OR
EXPRESSION [inaudible]
NATIONALITY.
RACE OR ETHNICITY.
RELIGION.
SEXUAL ORIENTATION OR
ASSOCIATION WITH SOMEONE OR A
GROUP THAT HAS ANY OF THESE
PERCEIVED OR ACTUAL
CHARACTERISTICS.
SO AGAIN CRIMINAL ACTS.
COMMITTED BASED IN WHOLE OR IN
OR IN PART BECAUSE OF ACTUAL OR
PERCEIVED CHARACTERISTICS.
THOSE ARE HATE CRIMES ALMOND AND
THOSE ARE WHAT THE ANNUAL REPORT
BY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
FOCUSES ON THAT'S WHAT'S
REPORTED TO THE FBI.
IT ADDITION TO HATE CRIMES THEIR
HATE INCIDENTS.
THEIR APPARENT THEIR OFFENSIVE
AND NO ONE SHOULD HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THEM.
BUT WHAT THEY ARE THE DEFINITION
OF A HATE INCIDENT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT IT.
IS AN ACTION OR BEHAVIOR
MOTIVATED BY HATE.
BUT THAT DOESN'T RISE TO THE
LEVEL OF BEING THE LEGAL --
GENERALLY THAT'S BECAUSE IT MAY
BE PROTECTED BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT TO FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION.
EXAMPLES OF HATE INCIDENTS
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE.
NAME CALLING YOUR INSULTS.
DISTRIBUTING HATE MATERIAL IN
PUBLIC PLACES OR SOMEONE WHO
POSTS ON HATE MATERIAL ON THEIR
OWN PRIVATE PROPERTY.
ABSOLUTELY OFFENSIVE AND APART
BEHAVIOR BUT DOESN'T RISE TO THE
LEVEL OF A CRIME.
AS THE AUDITOR NOTED HOWEVER
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT BE ABLE TO
DISTINGUISH.
AND KNOW THAT WHEN THE WHEN THE
CONDUCT DOES BECOME A CRIME SO
THAT IT ROBUST INVESTIGATION IS
DONE AND THERE ARE THINGS THAT.
THE COMMUNITY CAN DO TO TO MAKE
IT OTHER LEADERSHIP POINT THAT
PROFESSOR LEVIN.
I MADE A MOMENT AGO MAKE IT
KNOWN THAT HATE INCIDENTS ARE
NOT ONES THAT ARE ACCEPTABLE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES EITHER.
I'M GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO MY
DOJ COLLEAGUES TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT DOJ'S SPECIFIC ROLE
WITH RESPECT TO HATE CRIMES
[inaudible]
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND PROVIDE YOU WITH AN UPDATE
ABOUT SOME OF THE ACTIVITIES
WE'VE DONE TO PROVIDE LEADERSHIP
THAT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE IN RESPONSE TO THE AUDIT
FINDINGS --
AND I WILL BE HAPPY ALONG WITH
MY COLLEAGUES TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AT THE CONCLUSION OF
THE PANEL [inaudible]
CHIEF.
SKINNER MORNING I'M KEVIN
GARDNER IN THE CHIEF OF THE
DIVISION WILL FORCE A FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PART OF JUSTICE.
I THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY SPEAK BEFORE THIS
MORNING ON THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC.
I DON'T TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
HOW ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES
OF THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE AS
WELL SOME OF OUR RESPONSES. TO
THE AUDIT REPORT.
AS THE STATE'S AS THE STATE'S
CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS UNIQUE SET
OF ROLES AND RESPONSIBILITIES
WITH RESPECT TO HATE CRIMES.
UNLIKE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES DEAL JAY IS NOT A FIRST
RESPONDER AGENCY.
WHEN IT COMES TO IDENTIFYING
REPORTING RESPONDING TO HATE
CRIMES?
INSTEAD DOJ'S MANDATE IS TO
PERFORM THE FOLLOWING FUNCTIONS.
TO DIRECT LAW ENFORCEMENT LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
REPORT A CRIME CITY OJ.
TRANSMITTED DATA REPORTED TO
FEDERAL AGENCIES INVOLVED IN THE
COLLECTION OF NATIONAL CRISIS.
PUBLISHED NINE REPORT.
ON HATE CRIMES AND POST
INFORMATION ON OUR OPEN JUSTICE
WEB PAGE EACH YEAR.
WITH RESPECT TO THE DATA
PUBLISHED IN OUR AND REPORT AND
TRANSMITTED TO FEDERATION SEES.
DOJ PUBLISHES AN REPORTS THE
INFORMATION REPORTED TO LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ADDITION TO THESE ACTIVITIES.
BECAUSE THE CRITICAL NATURE OF
HATE CRIMES DOJ PROSECUTES HATE
CRIMES WHEN LOCAL AGENCIES
ECOSYSTEMS ARE HAVE A CONFLICT
OF INTEREST.
PROVIDES CRIME LAB SERVICES TO
TO ASSIST LAW ENFORCEMENT ISSUES
WITH EVIDENCE COLLECTION AND
ANALYSIS NAY CRIME CASES.
I WOULD PROVIDE A RANGE OF
RESOURCES FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES ON DEAL
JAYCE WEBSITE.
WE PROVIDES TRAINING AND
INFORMATION TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT ABOUT CALIFORNIA
HATE CRIME LAWS AND DOJ'S SYSTEM
OF REPORTING.
AND DOJ STAFF MEETS WITH
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS.
DOJ HAS ENGAGED IN THESE
ACTIVITIES AND IS MAKING A
CONCERTED EFFORT TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
AND PROVIDE COMMUNITY RESOURCES
DESPITE THE LACK OF ANY MONEY
MANDATE OR FUNDING TO DO SO.
WITH OVER SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY
REPORTING LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WILL ASSIST YOU
JAMAICANS EFFORTS MORE ROBUST
AND SUSTAINABLE.
WE'RE WORKING ON THIS INTERNALLY
AND BE DELIGHTED TO PARTNER WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO HELP BOOST
OUR EFFORTS TO IMPROVE HOW HATE
CRIMES ARE HANDLING CALIFORNIA.
ANY FISCAL YEAR. TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT TWO THOUSAND ON BUDGET
DEAL TO EXPERIENCE SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND BUDGET CUTS.
THE BUDGET CUTS INCLUDING A
REDUCTION OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND DOZENS OF STAFF POSITIONS
FROM DEAL JAYCE BUDGET.
THIS RESULT IN THE REDUCTION OR
ELIMINATION OF A VARIETY OF
TRAINING AUDITING AND COMMUNITY
OUTREACH PROGRAMS.
PRIOR TO THE BUDGET CUTS DOJ WAS
ABLE TO PROVIDE STATEWIDE
LEADERSHIP AND PREVENTION
POLICY.
PROGRAM RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT AND
CRIME PREVENTION AND REDUCTION.
WE PROVIDE SUPPORT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT PUBLIC OFFICIALS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WITH TRAINING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE MULTIMEDIA
RESOURCES DEVELOPMENT AND
RESEARCH SUPPORT SERVICES TO
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES SCHOOLS.
HEALTH SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS
COMMUNITY GROUPS AND ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WERE ALLOW
DOJ TO REINSTATE THESE TYPES OF
PROGRAMS AND HELP.
ENSURE PROACTIVE AND SUSTAINABLE
EFFORTS.
THE EFFORTS WE'VE TAKEN IN
RESPONSE TO THE ART INCLUDES
SOME OF THE FOLLOWING.
THE OTHER IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF
AREAS IN WHICH CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY CAN
IMPROVE THE WAY HATE CRIMES ARE
HEADLINER STATE.
AS I NOTED EARLIER MOBILE G. IS
NOT A FIRST RESPONDER AGENCY.
WE'VE TAKEN NUMBER STEPS IN
RESPONSE TO THE AUDIT.
THESE MEASURES INCLUDE.
THE HATE CRIMES PREVENTION WEB
PAGE WE LOST THEM CALIFORNIA
PART OF JUSTICE HATE CRIMES
PREVENTION WEB PAGE OFFERING THE
PUBLIC AND LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
ONLINE PLATFORM IF YOU HATE
CRIMES WILL BE RESOURCES AN
IMPORT MATERIAL.
THE HATE CRIMES RAPID RESPONSE
POLITICAL WE CREATED.
UPDATED PROTOCOLS FOR CALIFORNIA
PARTNER JUSTICES HAY CRIMES
RAPID RESPONSE TEAM THE TEAM
COMPOSED OF SENIOR OFFICIALS AT
THE CALIFORNIA PART OF JUSTICE.
STANDS READY TO ASSIST LOCAL AND
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITIES IN THE INVESTIGATION
OF POSSIBLE HATE CRIMES.
AND IN THE END IDENTIFICATION
ARREST PROSECUTION AND
CONVICTION OF PERPETRATORS OF
CRIME.
HATE CRIMES BROCHURES WE CREATED
A NEW HATE CRIMES BROCHURE
AVAILABLE IN NINE LANGUAGES THE
BROCHURE INCLUDES INFORMATION
ABOUT THE FOLLOWING.
WHAT CONSTITUTES A CRIME WHAT TO
DO IF YOU WITNESS OR VICTIM OF A
CRIME?
WHAT INDIVIDUALS AND COMMUNITIES
CAN DO TO PREVENT AND RESPOND TO
HATE CRIMES?
VICTIMS RIGHTS INFORMATION AND
WHERE TO FIND HELP.
GREATER LOVE THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
BULLETIN ON HATE CRIMES LAWS AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT TRAINING.
RELEASED INFORMATION BULLETIN
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
OUTLYING STATE LAWS AND THAT
PROHIBIT HATE CRIMES AND OTHER
HATE REALLY LACKS.
S. BULLETIN SUMMARIZE THE KEY
CALIFORNIA CRIMINALIST CIVIL
LAWS THAT PROHIBIT HATE CRIMES
AND OR PROVIDE ENHANCED
PENALTIES.
SPECIFIED HATE RELATED ACTS.
IN ADDITION WE'RE CURRENTLY
COLLABORATING WITH THE FBI TO
HOST HATE CRIMES SPECIFIC
TRAINING TWO POINT AGENCIES.
FINALLY IMPROVE QUALITY CONTROL
MEASURES DOJ'S REVISES QUALITY
CONTROL PROCESS FOR A CRIMES
SUBMISSION FOR THE TWENTY
EIGTEEN CISCO YEAR TO HELP
ENSURE ACCURATE PORTING HATE
CRIMES.
BY LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES.
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WERE LOUD
DEAL DRAPER FOR MORE IN DEPTH
DATA QUALITY CONTROLS IDENTIFY
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES AT THE
AGENCY AND STATE LEVEL AND AS
NECESSARY DEVELOPMENT ISSUE
MATERIALS. TO ASSURE PROPER
INACCURATE POINT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I WOULD NEVER MOVE ON TO THE
POST [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
CHURCHILL AND THE CHAIR LIKE TO
CHEAT --
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND STAFF
MEMBERS OF A OF THESE TWO
COMMITTEES OR THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AT YOUR
HEARING THIS MORNING.
MY NAME IS MANNY ALVAREZ AND I
SERVICE THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE COMMISSION ON PEACE
OFFICER STANDARDS AND TRAINING.
OR POST IS WE ARE COMMONLY
REFERRED.
TO SEATED TO MY RIGHT IS MISTER
HANDELMAN DANSA --
ONE OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT TECH
CONSULTANTS AT POST.
POSTS IS COMPRISED OF HUNDRED
NINETEEN MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVE
THE NEEDS OF THE STATE BY
SETTING HIRING STANDARDS
DELIVERING TRAINING SETTING
REGULATIONS AND CONDUCTING
AUDITS OF THE FORTY ONE POLICE
ACADEMIES.
AND SIX HUNDRED FIFTEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THE
VOLUNTARILY PARTICIPATE OPPOSE
PROGRAM.
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY TWO
THOUSAND PEACE OFFICERS AND
EIGHT THOUSAND PUBLIC SAFETY
DISPATCHERS FALL UNDER.
THE POST PROGRAM.
POST APPRECIATES THE WORK AND
DETAILED ANALYSIS CONDUCTED BY
STATE AUDITOR HOW ON HER STAFF.
IS MEMORIALIZED IN HER REPORT.
THE REPORT LISTED TWO
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR POST.
FIRST RECOMMENDATION YOU HEARD
FROM EARLIER BUT WAS AS FOLLOWS.
QUOTE TO HELP ENSURE THAT
OFFICERS CAN IDENTIFY AND
DOCUMENT THAT HE CRIMES HAVE
OCCURRED.
PUT SHOULD SEND TRAIN INTEREST
ALL POST CERTIFIED LAW ENFORCING
AGENCIES FOR THE STATE. FOR
THESE AGENCIES TO USE IN
REFRESHER TRAINING FOR THEIR
OFFICERS.
INDIRECT RESPONSE OF THE STATE
AUDITOR'S --
FIRST RECOMMENDATION POST
UTILIZE UTILIZES A TWO HOUR DVD
TITLED HATE CRIMES IS THE
PRIMARY VEHICLE FOR EXISTING
TRAINING OF PEACE OFFICERS AND
PUBLIC SAFETY DISPATCHER.
THIS CURRICULUM IN THE TRAINING
CONTENT WAS CREATED IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN BY SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS FROM --
THE FOLLOWING ENTITIES REFINERY
THEM OFF TO YOU.
THE VICTIM COMPENSATION AND
GOVERNMENT CLAIMS BOARD.
DEPARTMENT DISABILITY THE ORANGE
COUNTY HUMAN RELATIONS
COMMISSION.
THE DISABILITY RIGHTS --
KELP DISABILITY RIGHTS OF
CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF CHURCHES.
THE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS THE ANTI DEFAMATION
LEAGUE.
THE ISLAMIC NETWORKS GROUP THE
MUSEUM OF TOLERANCE.
SAN DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE THE SANTA
BARBARA DA'S OFFICE THE SHASTA
COUNTY DA'S OFFICE.
GLENDALE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
LA SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT LA
POLICE DEPARTMENT SAN DIEGO
POLICE DEPARTMENT SAN JOSE
POLICE DEPARTMENT AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE DEPARTMENT.
POST DISTRIBUTED ONE THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED AND SIXTY COPIES OF
THE TRAINING DVD.
INCLUDING TO TRAINING MANAGERS
AT FIVE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE OF
THE SIX HUNDRED FIFTEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
I BELIEVE THE STATE AUDITOR'S
PROVIDED A DVD IS PART OF A
REVIEW.
AND CONTENT AND THE DVD DID NOT
RECEIVE ANY TYPE OF CRITICISM IN
THE REPORT.
I LEAVE COPIES OF THIS DVD --
WITH YOU IN CASE YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN --
REVIEWING IT.
AS PART OF THE RECOMMENDATION BY
THE STATE AUDITOR.
POST REVIEWED ITS RECORDS AND
DETERMINE THAT SEVENTY POST
AGENCIES DID NOT RECEIVE THE
TRAINING MATERIAL.
DUE TO ADMINISTRATIVE OVERSIGHT
BY POST OR BECAUSETHE AGENCY
VOLUNTARY VOLUNTARILY OPTED OUT
OF THE POST TRAINING DVD
PROGRAMS.
ON JULY TWENTY FIFTH OF THIS
YEAR WHOSE DISTRIBUTE COPIES OF
THE OF THE TRAINING MATERIAL TO
THE REMAINING SEVENTY AGENCY.
AS A RESULT ALL SIX HUNDRED
FIFTEEN POSTS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES.
HAVE NOW BEEN PROVIDE THAT
TRAINING DVD.
ALSO ON JULY TWENTY FIFTH POST
ISSUED A BULLETIN TO ALL POST
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES CITING
THE FINDINGS IN THE STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT.
AND REMINDED.
ALL AGENCIES OF THE AVAILABILITY
OF THE HATE CRIMES TRAINING
MATERIAL.
ACCORDING TO POLICE TRAINING
RECORDS AS OF YESTERDAY. FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS AND DISPATCHERS
HAVE RECEIVED A COMPLETION
CREDIT FOR THE HATE CRIMES
TRAINING --
DVD.
POST ANTICIPATES CONVERTING THE
TRAINING DVD TO STREAMING
TECHNOLOGY OVER THE COURSE OF
THE NEXT SIX TO NINE MONTHS.
TRAINING COURSE WILL BE HOUSED
ON THE POSTAL ONLINE LEARNING
PORTAL.
CONVERTING VIDEO VD TO STREAMING
TECHNOLOGY WILL ENABLE IMMEDIATE
ACCESS TO THE TRAINING TO MORE
THAN NINETY THOUSAND PEACE
OFFICERS IN PUBLIC.
SAFETY DISPATCHERS.
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE LEFT TO HAVING
TO FIND THAT DVD SOMEWHERE IN
THEIR AGENCY.
ADDITIONALLY IT WILL ENABLE POST
TRAINING RECORDS TO
AUTOMATICALLY BE UPDATED UPON
COMPLETION OF THE TRAINING.
A COMMON PROBLEM WE FACE IS THAT
MANY INDIVIDUALS PARTICIPATING
DVD TRAINING.
BUT THERE AGENCY FORGET STANNARY
COMPLETION ROSTER INTO THE POST
DATABASE --
WHICH IS A REQUIREMENT FOR
CLASSROOM AND DVD TRAINING.
HOWEVER WHEN ONLINE TRAINING IS
CONDUCTED.
ON LEARNING PORTAL INDIVIDUAL
TRAINING RECORDS ARE
AUTOMATICALLY UPDATED.
THUS CONVERTING COURSE FROM DVD
TO STREAMING ALL IN LATE THE
RECORD KEEPING --
ACCURACY ISSUE.
AND WE ANTICIPATE THE STREAMING
OF COURSE WILL RESULT IN A
GREATER NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
TAKING.
AND RECEIVING CREDIT FOR THE
COURSE.
POST FEELS IT IS FULLY%
IMPLEMENTED THERE THE STATE
AUDITOR'S FIRST RECOMMENDATIONS
WAS NOTED EARLIER THIS MORNING.
I THINK IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT.
THE POST HAS OTHER HATE CRIMES
RELATED TRAINING.
AND NOT JUST WHAT I SPOKE ABOUT
WITH A TWO HOUR DVD.
HEY CRIMES ARE ADDRESSING THE
BASIC POLICE ACADEMY AND WAS
REFERRED TO AS LEARNING DOMAIN
FORTY TWO CULTURAL DIVERSITY --
AND DISCRIMINATION.
WHICH ENCOMPASSES A SIXTEEN HOUR
IT'S INSTRUCTION BLOCK.
WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY FOUR THREE
FOUR THOUSAND CADETS RECEIVING
THAT TRAINING EVERY YEAR.
POST ALSO EMPLOYS A RECURRING
TRAIN CONTRACT WITH THE MUSEUM
OF TOLERANCE.
PORTIONS OF THE INSERVICE
INSTRUCTION OFFERED BY THE
MUSEUM OF TOLERANCE INCLUDE.
A TRAINING ON HATE CRIMES.
POST HAS A TO A POST HAS TO POST
LEGACY COURSES UNDER THE ROBERT
PRESSLEY.
PRESLEY INSTITUTE OF CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION WHICH ALSO INCLUDE
INSTRUCTION ON HATE CRIMES.
PACIFIC WE DOMESTIC TERRORISM
AND TERRORISM INVESTIGATOR
RESPONSE THEY COVERED THE TOPIC.
THE SECOND RECOMMENDATION BY THE
STATE AUDITOR WAS AS FOLLOWS AND
I'LL READ IT. TO ENSURE ITS HATE
CRIMES TRAINING EFFECTIVELY
COMMUNICATES INFORMATION CENTRAL
TO PROPERLY IDENTIFYING AND
ADDRESSING HATE CRIMES.
POTION EVALUATE ITS HATE CRIMES
COURSES PERIODICALLY.
IT'S SEEK RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT
THESE EFFORTS IF NECESSARY.
AS I NOTICE KNOWN AS I NOTED
PREVIOUSLY.
POSTS WILL CONVERT THE HATE
CRIMES TRAINING DVDS SELF PACED
ONLINE I UTILIZING STREAMING
TECHNOLOGY.
AS WITH ALL POST LEARNING PORTAL
SEE SELF PACED COURSES THE TRAIN
WILL INCLUDE A SURVEY AT THE
CONCLUSION OF THE COURSE.
THE SURVEY WILL BE USED BY POST
TO EVALUATE THE CONTENT AND
USEFULNESS OF THE TRAINING.
LASTLY POST IS IN THE PROCESS OF
UPDATING ITS POLICY GUIDELINES
FOR HATE CRIMES.
EXISTING POLICY GUIDELINES WERE
PUBLISHED IN SEPTEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT IN RESPONSE TO
PENAL CODE --
ONE THREE FIVE ONE NINE POINT
SIX AND SPECIFICALLY SP.
ONE TWO THREE FOUR THE NEW
POLICY GUIDELINES WILL
INCORPORATE THE DISABILITY
CATEGORIES INCLUDED AND PENAL
CODE FOUR TWO TWO POINT FIVE SIX
BE.
WHICH OUR PART OF A. B. ONE NINE
EIGHT FIVE WHICH BECOMES
EFFECTIVE JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY
NINETEEN POST WILL CONVENE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS IN A
SERIES OF TWO THREE DAY
WORKSHOPS IN ORDER TO REVISE
THESE GUIDELINES.
ON JULY TWENTY SIX TWENTY
EIGHTEEN POST ADVISES STATE
AUDITOR THAT THE FIRST WORKSHOP
IS SCHEDULED FOR SEPTEMBER
NINETEENTH THROUGH TWENTY ONE
THROUGH THE TWENTY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR.
BELIEVE CENTS CHANGE THE DATES
TO OCTOBER SIXTEENTH THROUGH THE
EIGHTEENTH.
THE SECOND WORKSHOP IS SCHEDULED
FOR MARCH TWELFTH THROUGH THE
FIFTEENTH.
WE ARE CONFIDENT WE WILL
COMPLETE OUR WORK IN PUBLISHING
MODEL GUIDELINES BY MAY THIRTY
FIRST OF TWENTY NINETEEN WE'VE
INVITED HERSELF FROM THE
FOLLOWING ENTITIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN THESE WORKSHOPS.
THE MUSEUM OF TOLERANCE.
THE ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE
ISLAMIC NETWORKS GROUP.
THE MUSLIM PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COUNCIL THE ARC --
CALIFORNIA THE MEXICAN AMERICAN
LEGAL DEFENSE AND EDUCATION
FUND.
STATE DISABILITY ADVISORY
COUNCIL THE AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY
ALLIANCE.
NAPA VALLEY COLLEGE LGBTQ
STUDIES PROGRAM.
PEACE OFFICERS RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA.
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DA'S OFFICE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY DA'S OFFICE
AND INTERLOCKED POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
WHEN WE ALSO INVITED PERSONNEL
FROM THE FOLLOWING ENTER INTO
THESE TO SERVICE ADVISORY
MEMBERS TO THIS PROJECT
[inaudible]
SEE COALITION --
THE NWC P. THE UC DAVIS
SOCIOLOGY DEPARTMENT.
UC IRVINE DEPARTMENT CRIMINOLOGY
AND THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE NOT FULLY
IMPLEMENTED THE STATE'S STATE
AUDITOR SECOND RECOMMENDATION.
AS I'VE NOTED OUR EFFORTS ARE
CURRENTLY UNDER WAY.
WE EXPECT TO FULLY IMPLEMENT THE
SECOND THE SECOND RECOMMENDATION
BY NO LATER THAN MAY THIRTY
FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ALLOW POLICE TO PARTICIPATE AS
HEARING.
I COLLEAGUES AND I ARE HAPPY TO
HER MY COLLEAGUE AND I ARE HAPPY
ANSWERING QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
WE'LL FIGURE VERY MUCH SHOWING A
COMMAND OPPOSE OF YOUR EXTENSIVE
OUR REACH AS YOUR UPDATING YOUR
POLICY GUIDELINE.
I WAS SHADOW OATH LIKE TO
INTRODUCE OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THEY REACH YOU JONES SAWYER HERE
SO IN THE NUTS.
AND THOUGH OPEN FOR ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE DAIS.
THANK YOU AND NOT ONLY THINK
DHEA TO THE CHAIRS ARE BRINGING
US TOGETHER THAT MEETS THE ROAD
COURTNEY ISSUE.
AND UP AND I AM FAR LATE AT
COUPLE THINGS I NEEDED TO DO --
NO PROBLEM MOST OF WHICH WAS TO
TURN DOWN A COLOR IMAGE SUIT
RIGHT NOW [inaudible]
A BOB.
AS I WAS GROWING UP --
A I HAD A COUSIN NAMED JULIUS J.
U. L. I. U. S..
WHO LATER BECAME JUL JD WBO
[inaudible]
AND OF AFTER AMERICANS YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE FISHING MALES WERE
REPUBLIC TRAINED TO BE
HOMOPHOBIC --
AND AND I WORK ON IT EVERYDAY
YOU KNOW BEING HOMOPHOBIC JUST
IBM ALCOHOLIC BEING A RACIST.
IS LIKE DATA ONCE IT'S IN YOU'D
LIKE THE INTERNET IS IS STILL
THERE.
AND YOU HAVE TO WORK EVERYDAY
AND EVEN GROWING UP.
SCREW THAT YOU YOU WERE TAUGHT
THAT.
IF YOU WERE. TO GET INVOLVED
WITH SOMEONE THAT HAD A CHANGE.
DECIDED THEY WANTED TO GO FROM
ONE SEXY OTHER SPECIAL.
MALE TO FEMALE.
IF YOU BECAME ROMANTICALLY
INVOLVED [inaudible]
COM.
IT WAS A TOTALLY ACCEPTABLE FOR
YOU.
TO THE CRAP OUT OF THE CRIME.
AND I THINK A LOT OF TIMES.
WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT GOT
INVOLVED IN THOSE INCIDENTS --
THEY WOULD JUST KIND OF LET IT
GO BY THE WAYSIDE --
MY COUSIN --
WAS BEATEN IT SEVERAL TIMES AND
A LOT TODD LAW ENFORCEMENT WAS
COMPLICIT.
IN THOSE BEATINGS --
MY COUSIN WAS A VERY VERY VERY
ATTRACTIVE [inaudible] ONE AND
I'VE CITIES TO SEE AROUND TOWN
WITH A VERY PROMINENT MEN IN LA
[inaudible]
AND EVENTUALLY SHE WAS KILLED
SODOMIZED WITH A COKE BOTTLE AND
WE'VE NOT TO THIS DAY FOUND OUT
WHO MURDERED HER --
AND I'M [inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE.
THAT IT WASN'T BECAUSE OF THE
ACADEMY TRAINING --
I BELIEVE IT WAS POST TRAINING.
SMALL P. O. S. T. [inaudible]
NOT [inaudible]
PEACE OFFICERS.
STANDARD XIN TRAINING NOT
CAPITOL PEAK PERIOD OLD PERIOD
BEST PURITY PERIOD.
JUST LIKE IN TRAINING DAY.
ALL THE TRAINING THAT YOU CAN
GET.
THAT WHAT YOU GET IN THAT CAR
WITH DENZEL WASHINGTON.
ILL TELL YOU TO FORGET
EVERYTHING YOU LEARNED.
IF YOU WANT TO SURVIVE AND YOU
WANT TO BE ABLE TO DEAL ON THE
STREET YOU HAVE TO BE A CERTAIN
WAY DIFFERENT FROM WHAT YOU'VE
EVER BEEN TAUGHT.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US. TO TO
GO AHEAD AND AND DO THE DATA.
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR US TO SEE WHAT'S GOING ON
AND EVERYONE'S INDIVIDUALS HEAD
ESPECIALLY ALONG --
FOR POST TRAINING AND I DO MEAN
[inaudible]
SMALL P..
O. S. T. THAT GOES ON AFTER A A
YOUNG OFFICER GETS ON IS MUCH
MORE DANGEROUS [inaudible]
THEN ANYTHING --
THAT COULD HAPPEN EVEN IN MY IN
MY CITY.
WHERE WE HAVE A SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT --
WOULD VIKING TATTOOS AND AND
DIFFERENT DATE SOME OF THEM
DON'T BELIEVE.
IT HAS CAUSED SOME RACES PROBLEM
THAT HAPPENED LA COUNTY JAIL.
THEY REALLY DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THEY BELIEVE A PART OF A CLUB OR
GROUP.
AND AND IN SOME OF THE EIGHT THE
ABUSES THAT GO ON IN JAIL.
IS BECAUSE THE CULTURE --
FEEDS INTO IT AND ACCOMMODATES
--
WHICH DEBT HAS RAMIFICATIONS ON
THE OUTSIDE.
AND I KNOW EVERYONE HERE IS
TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE.
STOP THAT ON BUT WE NEED TO DO
MORE.
AND SO I KNOW YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE TRAINING THAT YOU'D
GIVEN WHAT WHAT YOU'RE DOING NOW
BUT I'M REALLY REALLY CONCERNED.
ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT ROLE.
IN HATE CRIMES IS NOT ONLY IN
THE STATE BUT ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY --
SPECIAL WITTY THE ATMOSPHERE
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW --
HOW DO WE?
AFTER SOMEONE GETS SOME THE BEST
TRAINING IN THE WORLD AND I
BELIEVE CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS THE BEST LAW.
A BUS TRAIN IN WORLD.
HOW DO WE KEEP THAT TRAINING
MOVING FORWARD? TO GET RID OF
THAT IN BED IT PREJUDICE IN
THEIR HEADS [inaudible]
THAT [inaudible]
IS REINFORCED.
THROUGH PRACTICES THAT ARE NOT
--
SANCTION.
BY EITHER LOCAL GOVERNMENT THE
CHIEF OF POLICE OR EVEN THE
DEPARTMENT.
BUT IT'S GOING ON ANYWAY.
PERMISSIVE IN THE SYSTEM HOW DO
WE GET.
DID THAT AND THAT'S KIND OF MY
QUESTION HOW DO WE REALLY GET.
INTO STOPPING AND IN OBVIOUSLY
ELITES INTO --
PEOPLE GETTING SHOT.
WHO HAPPEN LOOK LOT LIKE ME?
IN THE BACK [inaudible]
UNARMED.
AND HOW DO WE PREVENT THAT
BECAUSE WHETHER IT'S FEAR.
WAS FAIR BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
TAUGHT.
THAT A CERTAIN SEGMENT OF
POPULATION IS IS DANGEROUS.
NO MATTER HOW LOUD THEIR
SECRETIVE BUT THEY'RE DANGEROUS.
AND SO IT'S OKAY.
IF YOU UNDER SELF PRESERVATION
BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN TAUGHT AND
TRAINED.
THAT YOU NEED.
TO OP DEFEND YOURSELF.
AGAINST ANY ACTIONS HOW DO WE
WORK WITH [inaudible]
THE DEPARTMENT. TO BRING HIM UP.
TO TO A STANDARD THAT WE ALL
WILL BE PROUD OF AND THAT IT
DOESN'T GET UNDERMINE.
BUT WHAT I DID.
LAW ENFORCEMENT DA'S OF ATTORNEY
GENERALS ARE DOING OR IN WHAT
WE'RE DOING IN OUR TRAINING THAT
ALL GETS [inaudible]
GOES WAY.
AND ONE DAY LIKE IN TRAINING DAY
COULD JUST GO AWAY ONE DAY.
AND NEXT THING YOU KNOW.
WE HAVE ANOTHER INCIDENT SO MY
QUESTION IS HOW DO WE GET TO THE
ROOT OF WHAT'S GONE ON IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THAT --
I WILL ECHO SOMETHING YOU SAID
EARLY ON WAS --
CONTINUE TO STUDY --
IS STARTING PLACE BUT I THINK --
AS IN ADDITION --
SOME OF THE ABILITY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
TO INTERCEDE ERA INTERSECT WITH
WITH SOME OF THESE ISSUES.
LAWYER AND MAYBE SOME ASSISTANCE
FROM THE LEGISLATURE TO GIVE US
THE AUTHORITY OF CERTAIN
INSTANCES. TO COMPEL AGENCIES TO
REPORT CERTAIN THINGS TO
SANCTION OF THEM WHEN THEY DON'T
I THINK ONE OF THE SOME OF THE
PROBLEM WITH THE REPORTING IS A
LACK OF ANY ACCOUNTABILITY ARE
ANY ANY ANY --
CONSEQUENCES. FOR NOT BEING
TIMELY WITH THE DATA OF FOR NOT
SUBMITTING THE DATA AND SO
FORTH.
ARM IN REGARDS.
TO CULTURAL.
BEHAVIORS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT I
THINK THAT THE PROFESSOR THAT
WAS UP A NEW.
PANEL MENTIONED --
GUIDANCE FROM THE TOP OR OR OR
OR OR PARDEE SETTING.
AND IT FROM THE OF FROM THE TOP
OF THE ORGANIZATION I THINK THAT
WHEN.
WE TARGET.
THE LEADERS OF THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS AND AND THAT THE
MESSAGE TO THAT ORGANIZATION IS
A CERTAIN TYPES OF BEHAVIOR
WON'T BE TOLERATED WILL BE.
DON'T WITH WHEN NECK TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR IS UNDERTAKEN THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS I THINK THOSE
STARTING PLACES --
BUT I THINK.
AGAIN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AS YOU
MENTION WITH --
THE EXAMPLE WITH YOUR COUSIN
THERE ARE SOME DEEP SEATED
[inaudible]
SOCIAL.
IDEAS THAT GUY THAT COME INTO
PLAY IN SOME THOSE ISSUES THAT
YOU MENTIONED.
AND I THINK THAT --
WE AS A SOCIETY RIGHT NOW
CURRENTLY TRYING TO GET AT THOSE
ISSUES TRY AND MAKE US.
ALL BETTER --
WHETHER WE'RE LAW ENFORCERS OR
ANY OTHER PROFESSIONAL OR WALK
OF LIFE.
UP SO I THINK THAT. FOR US SOME
OF THE MEDIA SYSTEMS WILL BE
WOULD BE ASSISTANCE FROM.
WOULD LEGISLATION THAT GOD WOULD
HELP US TO COMPEL SOME OF THAT
BUT IT'S IT IT'S IT'S ALSO PUT
US IN A POSITION TO CONTINUE OUR
REACH THAT WE USED TO DO MORE
RIGOROUSLY WHEN WE HAD A A
BETTER RESOURCES TO DO IT --
TO CONNECT THOSE COMMUNITIES IN
THOSE LAW FORCE NATIONS WITH
THEIR COMMUNITY SO THAT THEY
ARE.
NOT.
AN OCCUPYING FORCE THAT THEY SEE
PEOPLE FOR UP FOR THE FOR THE
HUMANNESS AS OPPOSED. TO FOR
WHAT THE ACTIVE MAY BE INVOLVED
IN OR WHAT OUTPUT OF THE*
PORTRAYED IN OUR SOCIETY THE
MEDIA WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE
THAT CAUSES ONE TO LOOK AT AND
OTHERS.
AS OTHER AS AS SOMEONE WHO IS
DANGEROUS AGAIN THERE'S BEEN
MENTION ABOUT THE NATIONAL
RHETORIC --
AND SOME OF THOSE THINGS PLAY
INTO ITS IF THE OVERALL PSYCHE
OF OF THIS PROBLEM AND I THINK
AGAIN IT'S A SOCIAL ISSUE THAT
WE ARE WORKING AS A AND
SOCIETIES TRYING TO BETTER AB
BUT I THINK IN THE SHORT TERM
THAT. TO GIVE US SOME OF THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE NECESSARY. TO
GET AT CONNECTING ARC OUR LOW
FORCE NATIONS WITH THE
COMMUNITIES TO GIVE US RESOURCES
TO IDENTIFY TRAINING NEEDS. TO
HOLD THOSE ACCOUNTABLE IN THOSE
POSITIONS TO MAKE SURE THOSE --
THAT THAT THE THINGS THAT WE
WISH TO BE DONE AND THE IN THE
WAY WE PLACE OUR SOCIETIES ARE
DONE ORGANIZATIONS.
I JUST WANT TO SAY I LOVE THE
JACKET MYSELF --
I I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THE
CHIEF GARDENERS BOB SAID I WOULD
I WOULD --
AB I THINK THE LEADERSHIP PIECE
IS CRITICAL ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT.
I HAVE HEARD SAID FROM THOSE IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS THAT ONE OF
THE MOST POWERFUL.
TOOLS IN ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY IS THE PODIUM.
THE WORDS THAT ARE SAID EVERYDAY
BY LEADERS WHO ARE AT THE PODIUM
WHETHER TO SERGEANT LIEUTENANT
CAPTAIN.
CHIEF --
COMMISSIONER.
THOSE THOSE THINGS MATTER AND SO
I THINK TO THE EXTENT THAT.
WE AS A COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT CERTAIN
VALUES ARE BAKED INTO THE WAY
THAT OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES.
AND OUR OFFICERS ENFORCE THE LAW
A RELATE TO COMMUNITY MEMBERS
THAT THAT IT'S IT'S ALL
CONNECTED IT CAN'T BE A ONE OFF
NOT ON THIS TOPIC NOT ON ANY OF
THE OTHER RELATED ISSUES IT'S
ALSO ABOUT ENSURING THAT.
A YOU KNOW WE DO WORK TO THE
EXTENT POSSIBLE TO ENSURE THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
ARE --
REFLECTIVE OF THE COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY SERVE --
YOU KNOW INCLUDING RACIAL
IDENTITY GENDER EXPRESSION AND
RELIGIOUS IDENTITY ON AND ON AND
ON I THINK THAT'S ALSO ONE WAY
TO HELP GET THIS.
THERE'S THERE'S NO SINGLE ANSWER
THERE'S NO MAGIC BULLET BUT I
THINK -- THE
FINAL THING I'LL SAY IS PICKING
BACKING ON THE RHETORIC POINT
THE CHIEF CARTER MADE I THINK
THE MORE THAT.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LEADERS
LIKE YOURSELVES LEADERS LIKE
THAT UP FOLKS IN THE AUDIENCE
TODAY.
WE COUNTER THE DIVISIVE RHETORIC
IT'S COMING OUT OF WASHINGTON
AND MAKE IT CLEAR THAT.
IN THE GOLDEN STATE THIS WON'T
BE TOLERATED AND THE LEADERS IN
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
HAVE TO TAKE EVERY SINGLE
OPPORTUNITY NOT JUST.
IN THE END IN AN ANNUAL TRAINING
PROGRAM BUT EVERY DAY OR EVERY
NIGHT FROM THAT PODIUM TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT THE EXPECTATIONS ARE
AND ALSO TO REWARD.
GOOD BEHAVIOR ON THE AND REPORT
THE THINGS THAT YOU WANT TO SEE
ON HOLD THOSE UP ITS VALUE.
AS OUR TOP VALUES.
SIR IF I MAY ALSO RESPOND ON
BEHALF OPPOSED --
SO WE WE KIND OF LOOK AT THE
QUESTION YOU POSE WITH TWO PRONG
SOLUTION.
OF THE ACADEMY AS I MENTIONED
HAS THREE TO FOUR THOUSAND
CADETS GOING THROUGH EACH YEAR
[inaudible]
IT.
IN IT'S TRAINING ALMOST IN THE
PUREST FORM IT'S NOT PERFECT BUT
IT'S GOOD QUALITY TRAINING.
WE ASK OURSELVES THE SAME
QUESTION YOU POSE.
WHAT WE DO TO ELIMINATE THAT
NAM?
TRAINING DAY THAT MOVIES MOMENT
ONCE THEY LEAVE.
THE ACADEMY SETTING IN THEY GO
ON A FIELD TRAINING AND THEY'RE
TOLD PAY FORGET EVERYTHING YOU
JUST LEARNED AT THE ACADEMY
WE'RE GONNA TELL YOU WHAT IT'S
REALLY LIKE ON THE STREET OR
GOING TO TRAIN YOU THE RIGHT
WAY.
SO WE HAVE TAKEN A VERY VERY
HARD LOOKING MODIFIED OUR FIELD
TRAINING PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
THINGS THAT.
YOU JUST SPOKE ABOUT.
ARM [inaudible]
AND TWO IN IT TO INSTILL THAT
THERE'S A A NICE PASSED THROUGH
FROM THE ACADEMY INTO FIELD
TRAINING THAT IT'S NOT A FORGET
EVERYTHING YOU JUST LEARNED.
THE OTHER COMPONENT IS WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES AT DOJ JUST MENTIONED
LEADERSHIP SO.
AS YOU WILL SEE ALL OF OUR
GUIDELINES IN OUR FIELD TRAINING
PROGRAM THERE IS ALWAYS AN
EXECUTIVE.
MESSAGE THAT'S INSERTED INTO ALL
OF THAT AS TO WHAT THAT AGENCY
HAD WHAT'S.
ARM IN ALL OF OUR LEADERSHIP
TRAINING HIS A LOT OF IT HAS
BEEN MODIFIED OVER THE LAST YEAR
AND A HALF AND WE CONTINUE TO
CHANGE. TO INCORPORATE SOME OF
THESE THINGS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ABOUT.
BIASES AND JUST DOING THE RIGHT
THING IN BEING A PROPER CITIZEN
AND A GOOD HUMAN BEING.
SO IT'S LEADERSHIP AND IT'S IT'S
FOR US THE FIELD TRAINING
PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T
GO AWAY [inaudible]
THINK.
LARRY THANK YOU SENATOR.
ALLEN [inaudible]
YOU HAVE [inaudible]
COMMENT QUESTION.
I DO SO LATER ON ASK YOU GUYS
ABOUT ANY --
INTERACTIONS YOU'VE HAD
[inaudible]
WE'VE PERPETRATORS.
AND ANY STORIES YOU MAY HAVE
ABOUT MAYBE THIS IS MORE PROVIDE
FOR THE NEXT PANEL BUT ANY
STORIES YOU HAVE ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO [inaudible]
AND EVEN ABLE TO TURN AROUND YOU
KNOW WHO MAY HAVE BEEN A OF YOU
KNOW I HATE CRIMES VIOLATOR.
I'LL WHO HAS.
SOME OUR FOREIGN THEMSELVES COME
AROUND MAYBE EVEN JOINED IN SOME
OF YOUR EFFORTS TO TRY.
TO I WORK FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND HOW BLUNT FORCE BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE MINDSET BEHIND.
HE CRIMES PERPETRATORS.
I HOW TO REACH THEM HOW TO
PREVENT --
THEM FROM FROM COMMITTING HATE
CRIMES AGAIN [inaudible]
SO VOTE.
IN THEIR OWN MOSTLY IT'S BEEN --
GANG MEMBERS WHO HAVE DECIDED.
TO COME INTO.
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN ORDER.
TO ADDRESS THE MEMBERS OF GANG
AND BRING THEM OUT BUT I HAVE A
I HAVE THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION --
EXAMPLE OF WHAT I WAS A YOUNG
POLICE OFFICER A YOUNGER OUT
CAUCASIAN.
KATO I MET ON A ON A ON A CALL
TO HIS HOME.
AND THAT THE KIDS ARE.
MOHAMMED WAS GOING THROUGH A
DIVORCE WAS FATHER'S OF
TROUBLING TIMES IN HIS HOME CITY
BECAME A KID THAT I AMID TOWARD
AND THEN I PICKED UP
OCCASIONALLY WITH HIS MOTHER'S
PERMISSION IS A PATRICIA THE
DEPARTMENT TO COME ON RIDE
ALONGS AND TRIED TO TALK TO HIM.
AND MENTOR HIM ALONE.
AND HAS TIME WENT BY I LOST
CONTACT WITH MY RAN INTO HIM
AGAIN ANOTHER DAY AND HE WAS A
SKINHEAD AND  HAD.
HE HAD JOINED OF THE SKINHEADS
AND HE HAD A DIFFERENT RESPONSE
TO ME THAN IT PREVIOUSLY HAD
WHEN I WAS.
I TRIED TO MENTOR HIM THROUGH
SOME OF THE PROBLEMS HE WAS
HAVING HIS WHOLE --
I TRIED TO REACH HIM THEN AND
TALK TO HIM ABOUT --
AND RECONNECT WITH HIM ABOUT
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAD.
BEEN ABLE SPEAK WITH PRIOR --
BUT BUT AT THAT TIME A HE WAS
LOST TO THAT AND SO I DON'T KNOW
I HAVEN'T EPT UP WITH THEM AS
PART NUMBER OF YEARS AGO.
BUT I THINK THAT THE LARGER
SSUE IN THAT CASE WAS THAT THE
SITUATION AT CONNECT KIDS HOME
--
WERE SO UNSETTLED THAT THAT HE
WAS SEARCHING FOR SOMETHING TO
BE APART OF AND AND THAT THAT'S
WHAT HE CONNECTED WITH.
I HATE TO HAVE THE EXAMPLE OF
SOMEONE GOING OF THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION.
BUT THAT'S NOT A SECRET PLACE
MOST PRONE EXAMPLE THAT THAT HAS
STUCK WITH ME THROUGH THAT WAS
THAT WAS OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AGO.
AND WE THINK WE COULD AND BETTER
KNOW WHAT WOULD YOU RISK
ANALYSES THE FACTORS THAT WERE
YOU MEANS IT'S PLAN OUT YOUR
HEAD I MEAN.
I THINK THE ONLY THING THAT UP
WELL I SUPPOSE I HAD I
MAINTAINED CONTACT WITH HIM AND
HAVE MAYBE I COULD HAVE HAD SOME
DIFFERENT IMPACT ON HIS LIFE BUT
I THINK THAT --
IN THAT CIRCUMSTANCE IS MOTHER
WAS GOING THROUGH A TOUGH TIME
IN AND THAT.
HIS FATHER WASN'T THERE IT WAS A
NEW MAN BEING INTRODUCED INTO
HIS LIFE AND SO FORTH AND SO I
DON'T KNOW.
OTHER THAN MAINTAINING CONTACT
WITH HIM WHEN I COULD HAVE DONE
TO TO HAVE IMPACTED HIS LIFE.
MAYBE I COULD HAVE PUT HIM IN
TOUCH WITH SOME SORT OF
RESOURCES THAT TO WOULD HAVE
CONTINUED TO MAINTAIN CONTACT
WITH THEM AND GOT HIM INTO SOME.
POSITION WHERE HE WOULD OF OF
SLIPPED INTO THE LIFE THEY
SLIPPED INTO BUT I SHORT OF THAT
I I REALLY DON'T KNOW WHAT I
COULD HAVE DONE TO ASSIST
[inaudible]
CRIME.
MALE ANNOUNCING YOUR THOUGHTS.
IT'S OKAY I CAN ASSESS THE NEXT
PANEL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SHARE MIRACLE THREE THANK YOU.
SO I WANTED TO FOLLOW UP ON
LAWYERS --
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW DO WE
ACHIEVE A CULTURE CHANGE YOU
KNOW ESPECIALLY --
YEAH WHEN I WAS LISTENING.
TO MISTER ALVAREZ'S TESTIMONY
ABOUT THE TO R. DVD TRAINING ON
ON HATE CRIMES I MEAN IT JUST
SEEMS TO ME LIKE.
PEOPLE THAT WOULD BE
[inaudible]
WATCHING THAT.
DVD AND AND GOING THROUGH THE
TRAINING OR THE PEOPLE THAT
PROBABLY LEAST IN NEED.
THE TRAINING AND AND THAT THE
PEOPLE THAT THAT.
YOU NO ARE THE MOST PROBLEMATIC
--
THAT MAY NEED THE MOST --
IN THERE THAT THAT TRYING THE
MOST WOULD BE THE LEAST LIKELY
TO DID TO BE INCLINED. TO TO GO
THROUGH THAT TRAINING AND SO YOU
KNOW IT IT JUST RAISES THE IN
THE PERENNIAL A CHALLENGE THAT
WE HAVE WHICH IS YOU KNOW HOW DO
WE HOW DO WE TRY TO LEGISLATE
CULTURE CHANGE OR HOW DO WE NO.
I MEAN AS EVANS TALKED ABOUT.
TO YOU KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF OF
LEADERSHIP REFLECTING THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE BEING
POLICED OR I IN AND I I THINK A
CERTAIN THE PARLOR.
THAT THE SOLUTION BUT I I THINK
IT IS HIGHLIGHTS THE THE L. THE
DIFFICULTY OF OF OF TRYING
[inaudible]
TO ENACT IN CULTURE CHANGE AND
AND THAT IT'S SO ALONG AND AND
THE COMPLICATED PROCESS --
BUT I WANT TO THROW OUT THIS
IDEA ESPECIALLY YOU KNOW
HAPPENED THEY THE CHAIR OF OUR
SIMPLY PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
OF HERE -- I
I KNOW THAT.
ONE YOU NO CULTURAL SIGNAL THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT DOES RESPOND TO
IS INCREASE CRIMINAL PENALTIES.
AND SO I MEAN IS THERE A SENSE
--
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT AS TO
WHETHER CURRENT PENALTIES FOR
HATE CRIMES WHETHER THEY'RE
CRIME ITSELF FOR ANY SENTENCING
ENHANCEMENTS.
ARE ADEQUATE IN ORDER.
TO YOU KNOW MAKE.
THE REPORTING AND THE
PROSECUTION OF HATE CRIMES.
A HIGH ENOUGH PRIORITY.
THE WITH THE WAY CALIFORNIA LAW
WORKS IS THAT --
THE PENALTY THAT EXISTS FOR THE
BIT THAT BASED CRIME WHETHER
IT'S AN ASSAULT WHETHER IT'S
HOMICIDE WHETHER IT'S VANDALISM
THAT'S THE PENALTY THAT ARE HATE
CRIMES LAW ALLIED.
AT ENHANCE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
SO.
I'M.
YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE IS MADE
POLICY DECISIONS ABOUT THOSE
PENALTIES FOR THE BASE CRIMES
AYE I THINK.
I I THINK THE KEY TO MAKING THIS
A PRIORITY FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES REALLY GOES BACK TO THE
TO THE LEADERSHIP.
ISSUE GOES BACK TO
ACCOUNTABILITY WE AND REQUIRED
WHETHER IT'S ADMINISTRATIVE WORK
OR OTHER WORK IS NOT DONE
APPROPRIATELY THAT THERE BE AN
ACCOUNTABILITY HOPE FOR THAT I
THINK --
THAT THAT WILL LIKELY PROVIDE --
MAY BE OF A MORE BENEFICIAL
PATHWAY [inaudible]
TO ENSURING THAT.
YOU KNOW THESE CRIMES GET THE
ATTENTION THAT THAT THEY DESERVE
ON HERE RIGHT NOW WE HAVE. FOR
HOMICIDE FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE A
VERY LENGTHY PENALTIES AND WHAT
IF IT'S A HATE CRIME THERE ARE
ENHANCEMENTS ON TOP OF THAT --
THE KEY I THINK OR AT LEAST ONE
OF THE KEYS TO ENSURING PROPER
PRIORITIZATION.
PARTICULARLY IN OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES PARA
MILITARY ORGANIZATIONS IS TO
ENSURE THAT.
THE LEADERS OF THESE AGENCIES
COMMUNICATE THAT MESSAGE UP
POLICE OFFICERS IN MY EXPERIENCE
ARE VERY VERY GOOD AT DOING WHAT
THEY STE [inaudible]
ARE.
TOLD IS EXPECTED OF THEM AND
WHERE THEY KNOW THAT THEY'LL BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR DOING THAT
--
IT'S ALL A CONSTANT FEEDBACK
LOOP.
AND AND THE THE EXPECTATIONS ARE
COMMUNICATED EXPLICITLY OFF FROM
THE TOP AND ALSO IMPLICITLY AND
POST A TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
WAYS THEY TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE OFFICIAL MESSAGE MAIN IS
MAINTAINED IN TERMS OF WHAT'S
REQUIRED BUT I'D I DON'T KNOW
WHETHER.
CHANGING PENALTIES WOULD CHANGE
PRIORITIES AND ENOUGH IT SELLS
LIKE AGAIN GOES BACK TO
LEADERSHIP POINT.
AND AND AND SO.
HOW WOULD WE WHAT WOULD BE THE
BEST WAY TO ACCOMPLISH?
YOU KNOW --
IT IT TO GET LEADERSHIP AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO MAKE
--
THE REPORTING AND PROSECUTION OF
HATE CRIMES I AM A PRIORITY.
IF I MAY UM.
I ATTEND.
QUARTERLY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION MEETING --
USUALLY ALL FIFTY EIGHT SHERIFFS
ARE THERE I TEND ALSO QUARTERLY
THE CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION MEETINGS --
I CAN SAY THAT I'VE BEEN
ENCOURAGED TO HEAR --
THE TALK THEY'RE GOING ON AT
THESE MEETINGS AT THAT.
IT SEEMS THAT --
THAT THE LEADERS IN THE AT OUR
AND OUR ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ALL FORCING
ORGANIZATIONS.
ARE STARTING TO GET IT.
THEY GET THAT THEIR THAT THE
EXPECTATION OF WHERE WE NEED TO
MOVE TO AS A PROFESSION --
I I REALIZE THAT TO WIN ON THEIR
THAN THAT AND THAT NOT ALL OF
THEIR SOME WHO GET IT MORE THAN
OTHERS GET IT AND SO.
I THINK OF THE OPPORTUNITY --
THAT WE HAVE TO ACT AND I CAN
SAY THAT DIRECTOR ALVAREZ IS
FREQUENTLY AT THOSE SAME
MEETINGS WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
OR ACT WITH.
WITH THIS GROUP AND TO IMPART --
THE REASON THAT WE GO TO THESE
MEETINGS IS IS TO UPDATE THEM ON
IMPORTANT ISSUES OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THESE ARE SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT WEARE COSTLY
BANG THE FORWARD THAT.
THAT THAT WE NEED TO MOVE
FORWARD AND AND LIKE I SAID IT'S
BEEN ENCOURAGING TO HEAR.
THE THE TALK AT THESE AT THESE
MEETINGS.
WHERE -- THE
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE.
IS AROUND THE SORT OF ISSUES AND
AND I WOULD SAY THAT
OVERWHELMINGLY --
THEY GET IT THERE THEY
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS BEING.
EXPECTED OF THEM AS A AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS ISSUE --
BUT AGAIN YOU KNOW LIKE ANYTHING
THERE ARE THOSE WHO ARE MORE TO
GET MORE AND OTHERS GET IT BUT
WE THINK.
GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
CONTINUE TO PUSH FOR THESE
MESSAGES BUT ALSO TO HAVE SOME
BACKING FOR COUNT ABILITY --
WOULD BE A GOOD PLACE TO START
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
BOB IS.
ON THE SAME ARM AND THE BE
CAREFUL WHAT YOU WISH FOR
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE HAVE PEOPLE
IF THERE WERE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
PEOPLE THAT CAN CHANGE LAWS SO.
BE CAREFUL WHAT YOU WISH FOR SO
I'M GOING TO ASK YOU TO COME AS
CHAIR PUBLIC SAFETY TO COME TO
MY OFFICE AND WHAT I WANT YOU TO
ADD.
BASED ON CUSTOMER SU CHI'S
SUGGESTION --
THIS SO THE OFFENDED PARTY SET
THE SOUTHERN POVERTY CENTER SUIT
CLAD.
IN BOTH WOULD HAVE THEM ON THE
RUN [inaudible]
IF FINANCIALLY.
IT SEEMED TO BE WORKING.
VERY WELL AND SO --
IF WE COULD.
PROVIDE SOME FINANCIAL
[inaudible]
INCENTIVES. TO STOP HATE CRIMES
THAT THAT WE CAN LEGALLY DO IF
YOU BRING THAT TO MY OFFICE
WOULD LOVE. TO SEE THAT AYE --
I'VE EVEN MENTIONED.
TO ON THE BLACK LIVES MATTER
FOLK [inaudible]
THAT [inaudible]
IF.
IF SOMEONE EVER BROUGHT
LEGISLATION TO ME THAT IF THERE
WAS A A DEPARTMENT THAT HAD A
LAW ENFORCEMENT APARTMENT.
THEY HAD --
EXHIBITED.
COM RACIALLY MOTIVATED
ACTIVITIES FOR QUITE SOMETIME
[inaudible]
THAT -- YOU
SHOULD [inaudible]
AND THAT THE GENERAL FUND AND
BAIL THEM OUT.
THAT THE MONIES COME OUT OF
EVERY OFFICER IN THAT DEPARTMENT
PAYCHECK.
SO THAT EVERY OFFICER WILL THEN
LOOK AT THE OTHER OFTEN SAY.
LOOK YOU KNOW MESS WITH MY
BOTTOM LINE.
CUT THAT OUT BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
DOING IT FROM.
THIS IS THE RIGHT THING DO
[inaudible]
DEPARTMENT.
BUT I'D IS ONE THING ABOUT MONEY
PEOPLE'S MONEY THEY DON'T YOU
MESS WITH THAT MONEY.
AND THAT THAT MIGHT BE ONE
OBJECTIVE THAT WE MAY NEED TO
PURSUE.
AND HOW DO WE GO AFTER A
DEPARTMENT FROM THE LEADERSHIP
ON DOWN.
IF THEY'RE NOT WILLING TO CHANGE
MAYBE THEY'LL CHANGE.
BECAUSE WE'RE NOW TAKING.
BRED AFTER TABLE.
SO I'M JUST PUTTING THAT OUT
THERE IN.
I WANT TO LET YOU CAN BRING IT
TO GREW FROM GOOD NO.
COAUTHORED A BILL.
LARRY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE YET BUT THE PROFESSOR THAT
SPOKE EARLIER TODAY TALKED ABOUT
THE USE OF SOCIAL MEDIA. TO TO
TO PUSH OUT --
RACIST MESSAGES.
AND IF THERE'S A WEAK POINT IN.
CULTURES ACROSS THE COUNTRY THE
WORLD AND IN INCLUDING OUR
COUNTRY IT'S IT'S RACISM.
THAT -- IF
FIVE WE WERE A QUILT.
AND THERE IS A THREAD AND NEED
IS COUPLED ON THAT RACES THREAD
AND IT WOULD UNRAVEL THE ENTIRE
QUILT.
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S PRETTY
SMART OF OUR ENEMIES WHETHER
IT'S RUSSIA WHERE PEOPLE JUST
WANNA SO DIVISION IN OUR COUNTRY
[inaudible]
AND THIS WAS EVIL.
WHAT TUG OR TALK ABOUT CODEINE
HATE CRIMES AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE GET IT RIGHT WE UNDERSTAND
WHAT THOSE TRENDS ARE?
HOW MUCH ARE WE TRACKING WHETHER
OR NOT?
SOME OF THIS IS MOTIVATED BY
MESSAGES THAT PEOPLE HAVE PICKED
UP ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND ISN'T SO
MUCH RACISM BUT THERE'S A VERY
FAMOUS --
OUR INFAMOUS --
CONSPIRACY THEORY ABOUT CHILD
TRAFFICKING A COMET PING PONG IN
WASHINGTON DC THAT ACTUALLY.
RESULTED IN SOMEONE GOING TO THE
PIZZA RESTAURANT A GUN --
WHO BELIEVED THAT THAT WAS
ACTUALLY TAKING PLACE THERE?
AND KNOW HOW MUCH OF THAT TYPE
OF DATA ARE WE TRACKING.
THERE IS NOT AN OFFICIAL
REPORTING IN THAT DEATH BAKED IN
OUR PART OF THE MANDATORY
REPORTING FOR OUR ANNUAL.
HATE CRIMES REPORT YOU KNOW AS
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE ARE LIVING
THEIR LIVES ONLINE OR LIVING
SECRET LIVES ONLINE.
ON YEAH I THINK IT'S
INCREASINGLY SOMETHING THAT CAN
COME INTO PLAY IN TERMS OF AN
INDIVIDUAL LAW ENFORCEMENT'S
INVESTIGATION OF PARTICULAR
ACTION AND MAY PROVIDE.
EVIDENCE --
IN TO INTENT OR MOTIVE --
WHICH YOU HEARD ABOUT EARLIER IN
TERMS OF THE DIFFICULTY OF
PROSECUTING THESE CRIMES BUT
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT.
THE DOJ THAT IS CURRENTLY PART
OF ANY OF THE MANDATED REPORTING
THAT.
THAT WE RECEIVE OFTEN
ALTERNATIVE MY LAW ENFORCEMENT
COLLEAGUES IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING
ELSE TO ADD IN TERMS OF THAT
SOCIAL MEDIA TRACKING OR
INFORMATION IN PARTICULAR.
SO IT'S NOT MANDATED.
AND PERHAPS IT'S NEW THE USE OF
IT TO INCITE [inaudible]
HE IT IS SOMETHING THAT PERHAPS
WE SHOULD BE PAYING MORE
ATTENTION.
TO AND AYE ANDERSON IS DIFFICULT
FOR YOU TO HAVE ALL THESE
DIFFERENT THINGS IT GOT ATTRACT
BUT IS THE SOME OF THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS.
TO GET INVOLVED OR FOR YOU TO
TAKE COME TO US AND SAY THIS IS
A SERIOUS ISSUE THAT'S DRIVING
CRIME AND HE CRIME IN
PARTICULAR.
I THINK IT'S CERTAINLY A
QUESTION WORTH ASKING AND IT'S
AND AS I SAID M..
WHEN THEY'RE WHEN THE EVIDENCE
IN A PARTICULAR CASE LEADS IN
THAT DIRECTION IT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT IS?
CONSIDERED TO BE YOU KNOW FOR
ITS RELEVANCE OR MORE GOING ON
THERE OBVIOUSLY AS YOU KNOW AS A
VALUE IN THIS COUNTRY IN TERMS
OF YOU KNOW FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHT.
TO FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION FREEDOM
OF SPEECH ARM SO THAT'S WHERE
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES THE RUBBER
HITS THE ROAD BUT I THINK THAT.
CERTAINLY CAN BE RELEVANT
CERTAIN PLACES AND CAN --
LEAD US TO POTENTIAL AREAS OF OF
DANGER OR WHERE WE NEED TO BE
ALERT I DON'T HAVE SITTING HERE
TODAY I DON'T HAVE.
A PROPOSAL FOR YOU ABOUT YOU
KNOW WHAT IF ANY PARTICULAR
REPORTING MIGHT MAKE SENSE OR BE
HELPFUL BUT I THINK IT'S
CERTAINLY A QUESTION WORTH
ASKING [inaudible]
YEAH.
ARE A GREAT THANK YOU AYE AYE I
DO HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
OWNED THE BOAT ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE ORANGE COUNTY --
IS A SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT HOUSE
NOT.
RESPOND TO THIS AUDIT REPORT.
AND THE DOJ THE AGE YOU PAN THE
POP LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES OFF
THE STATE --
COULD CHOOSE SOMEHOW HAVE ANY
INFLUENCE OVER DAY ORANGE
COUNTY.
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
ONLY IN AS MUCH AS CONTACT THEIR
MAKING STRONG SUGGESTIONS THAT
THE THAT THEY RESPOND TO THE
AUDIT BUT I DON'T I THINK THAT
THE UP.
THE AUDIT GROUP WOULD HAVE MORE
AUTHORITY TO TO COMPEL THE
RESPONSE AND THEN WE WOULD MISS
OUR AND CIRCUMSTANCE FOR THE
AUDITOR AUDITOR HAVE MORE.
PULL TO REALLY GET THEM TO
RESPOND.
THEN THE TOP LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES OF THE STATE --
KILLING WISH YOU CAN ANSWER
SOMETHING DIFFERENT I DON'T
THINK IS WITHIN --
THE PURVIEW --
TO TO TO FOR IN THIS SENTENCE.
OKAY IT AND AND HELP.
ON OKAY WELL WELL WELL I AND I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IF WE
REALLY HAVE SEE.
TOOK THE POWER ED AND AND ON
TERRORIST SIX OR SEVEN
RECOMMENDATION FULL REPEAL J..
AND TELL AYE I WILL TRY AGAIN
THEN A WAS STRUCK QUICK ENOUGH
--
TO TO TO HOLLY UP HOW MANY HAVE
YOU RESPONDED OR YOU.
ALTHOUGH IF SEVEN OR SIX OR
SEVEN RECOMMENDATIONS THERE WERE
SEVEN RECOMMENDATIONS AND AS OF
THE AUDITOR'S TWO NOTED EARLIER.
ONE OF THEM IS IN FULL
COMPLIANCE --
FOR THEM ARE IMPARTIAL
COMPLAINTS WERE WORKING TOWARDS
COMPLETING THOSE AND THEN TO ARE
STILL PENDING OTHER PENDING ONES
HAVE TO DO WITH SOME.
CHANGES THAT ARE CONNECTED TO
THE THE MATTER WHICH WE COLLECT
DATA AND ALSO TIED TO NATIONAL
CHANGES IN TERMS OF DATA
COLLECTED BY SIMILAR AGENCIES
AND HOW IT'S REPORTED. TO THE
FBI THERE'S A WHOLE NEW SYSTEM
COMING ONLINE IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN THE DETAILS I CAN
HAVE MY COLLEAGUE MISLEAD AT A
TALK WITH RESULT THAT.
CORRECT AGREE AND ALSO DE A
DEFINITION OF THE HATE CRIME IS
IS THAT.
FROM THE LEGISLATURE'S ORDERS
FROM THE EIGHTEEN DEPARTMENT YOU
WERE MENTIONED ABOVE DISABILITY
GENDER NATIONALITY REYES AND I
SAW SO FORCE.
THOSE CATEGORIES ARE FROM THE
LEGISLATURE FROM THE
LEGISLATURE.
LARA ALIKE TO AROUND.
AND I DO LIKE.
TO I SUPPOSE SOCIAL STATUS.
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT --
A LOT OF FOR A HATE CRIME.
WAS THERE COMMITTEE ON THE
HOMELESS PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW AND I OUT BETTER.
SO OH OH DEFINITELY LOOK INTO.
ADDING SOME DEFINITION OR OR IS
H. INCLUDED.
IN.
BUT THAT THE ES EN ROUTE THAT
WILL BE UNDER THE DID TO SENIOR
OF PROTECTION.
RIGHT THERE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU IMAGE --
WE'LL MOVE ON TO TODAY --
TO FIND NO.
WELL HOW.
ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE SIX
SEVEN EIGHT WELL EIGHT PANELIST.
WE'LL NEVER GET TO THE TABLE
FIRST WILL GATHER MARTIN FOR
MICROPHONE
.
I GUESS A DAYS VERY VIALS ARE
ALL IN THE HEAD OUT.
SEE SOME FAMILIAR FACES.
WELL HAVE ROOM [inaudible]
FOR EIGHT OKAY WILL
.
THE NAMELESS THERE'S AGENDAS NOT
IN ANY PARTICULAR ORDER SO.
WHATEVER WALLET [inaudible]
TO ARTIFICIAL [inaudible]
GOJO.
ALRIGHT IF YOU KNOW.
MAYBE MAYBE WE CAN JUST GO DOWN
THE LINE I'M NOT SURE WHAT MAKES
SENSE BUT GOOD MORNING CHAIRS
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M JOE
MICHAEL LEGISLATIVE MANAGER AT
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE AN ORGANIZATION THAT
BRINGS THE VOICES OF ACTUAL
TRANSGENDER AND QUEER PEOPLE AND
ALLIES TO INSTITUTIONS OF POWER
IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES STRIVING TO CREATE
A WORLD THAT IS HEALTHY JUST AND
FULLY EQUAL FOR ALL LGBTQ
PEOPLE.
SO IF YOU HAVE ALREADY HEARD
TODAY WE ARE ALL FACING RISING
RATES OF HATE CRIMES AND BIAS
MOTIVATED VIOLENCE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES.
PEOPLE OF COLOR IMMIGRANTS
MUSLIMS THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
WOMEN PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
AND MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY ARE TARGETED
FREQUENTLY. TO MAKE MATTERS
WORSE MANY INCIDENTS ARE NOT
EVEN REPORTED BECAUSE MEMBERS OF
THESE COMMUNITIES OFTEN FEEL
UNSAFE INTERACTING WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS AND FEAR
BEING IGNORED OR EVEN TARGETED
BY THEM AS WELL.
ACCORDING TO THE MOST RECENT
HATE CRIME VICTIMIZATION REPORT
BY THE BUREAU OF JUSTICE
STATISTICS WHICH I THINK WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER OVER HALF OF
HATE CRIMES NATIONALLY GO
UNREPORTED. TO SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY TO HATE CRIMES AND
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY FOR A MOMENT
HATE CRIMES WITH A SEXUAL
ORIENTATION BIAS HAVE
CONSISTENTLY BEEN THE SECOND
MOST COMMON TYPE OF HATE CRIME
IN CALIFORNIA. FOR MORE THAN TEN
YEARS AND ACCOUNTED FOR NEARLY A
QUARTER OF ALL HATE CRIMES
REPORTED IN CALIFORNIA OVER EACH
OF THE PAST FOUR YEARS.
CRIMES OF THE BIAS AGAINST GAY
MEN IN PARTICULAR INCREASE OVER
40% BETWEEN TWENTY FIFTEEN AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND THEN INCREASE
AN ADDITIONAL 13% BETWEEN TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
HATE CRIMES AGAINST TRANSGENDER
AND GENDER NON CONFORMING PEOPLE
HAVE ACCOUNTED FOR A SIGNIFICANT
PERCENTAGE OF HATE CRIMES.
BASED ON GENDER IN CALIFORNIA
CONSISTENTLY SINCE THAT DATA HAS
BECOME AVAILABLE FOR EXAMPLE
OVER 90% OF THE HATE CRIMES
BASED ON GENDER IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WE'RE COMMITTED AGAINST
TRANSGENDER AND GENDER NON
CONFORMING PEOPLE.
OF COURSE THIS INFORMATION IS
BASED ONLY ON THE CRIMES THAT
ARE BOTH REPORTED TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND IDENTIFIED AS
HATE CRIMES.
THE AUDIT REPORT POINTED OUT
ACCURATE IDENTIFICATION OF HATE
CRIMES HAS A WEAKNESS IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR STATE LAWS
SO THE OVERALL RATES OF HATE
CRIMES IN THE NUMBER SPECIFIC TO
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY.
ARE MOST LIKELY EVEN HIGHER THAN
THESE REPORTS REFLECT.
HATE CRIMES AND HATE VIOLENCE
HAVE UNIQUE REPERCUSSIONS
EXTENDING BEYOND THE INDIVIDUALS
TARGETED TO OTHERS IN THE
COMMUNITIES OF WHICH THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE APART.
CREATING A SENSE OF ISOLATION
AND VULNERABILITY TO HARM AMONG
PEOPLE WITH SHARED CORE
CHARACTERISTICS.
CALIFORNIA'S HATE CRIME LAWS FOR
THE PROVIDE PROTECTION BASED ON
A PERSON'S ACTUAL ARE PRETTY
PERCEIVED RACE OR ETHNICITY
NATIONALITY RELIGION DISABILITY
GENDER IDENTITY AND EXPRESSION
AND SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED BEFORE IN
ADDITION TO PROVIDING LEGAL
RECOURSE FOR PEOPLE TARGETED Y
HATE CRIMES ENUMERATING EACH OF
THESE GROUPS ALSO HELPS TO RAISE
AWARENESS OF THE IMPACT OF HATE
CRIMES.
ON EACH OF THESE COMMUNITIES AND
ON INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE PART OF
MORE THAN ONE MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITY. FOR EXAMPLE LGBTQ
PEOPLE WHO ARE ALSO OF COLOR
FACE HIGHER RISKS OF
EXPERIENCING HATE VIOLENCE.
IS A MIXED IS TRUE OF LGBTQ
PEOPLE WHO ARE ALSO IMMIGRANTS
WHO ALSO HAVE DISABILITIES.
AND CONSIDERING HOW WE ADDRESS
THE RECENT INCREASES AND HATE
VIOLENCE WE WOULD BE WELL SERVED
TO LOOK CLOSELY.
HAD THE EXPERIENCES OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE PART OF MULTIPLE
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES AND
LISTEN TO THEIR STORIES AND
IDEAS.
ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
LAWS STRONG AND INCLUSIVE WE AT
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA KNOW THAT
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE TO ADDRESS
THE INCREASE AND HATE MOTIVATED
CRIMES THAT MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES ARE FACING.
THIS YEAR WE COSPONSORED AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PHILIP TING WITH THE ARK
OF CALIFORNIA AND MISTER ALVAREZ
ACTUALLY MENTIONED THIS LAW JUST
BEFORE.
AND IT WILL SPARK A REVIEW OF
LOCAL HATE CRIMES POLICIES SOME
OF WHICH ARE SERIOUSLY OUT OF
DATE AND DO NOT REFLECT CURRENT
PUBLIC POLICY.
GOVERNOR BROWN SIGNED THAT BILL
INTO LAW THIS SUMMER AND
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR POST TO
UPDATE THEIR MODEL POLICIES ON
HATE CRIMES WERE ALSO ALLOCATED
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT THESE CHANGES
WILL ENHANCE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES ABILITIES TO ACCURATELY
IDENTIFY HATE CRIMES THROUGH
BETTER POLICIES AND IMPROVE
TRAINING WHICH THE AUDIT REPORT
ALSO HIGHLIGHTED AS AN
UNDERLYING CAUSE OF MANY OF THE
SHORTCOMINGS.
OF OUR HATE CRIMES ENFORCEMENT
STATEWIDE.
WE HOPE THAT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO UPDATE POLICIES
WERE BEING BRING TRAINING UP TO
DATE IN TURN.
BUT WE KNOW THERE IS MUCH MORE
THAT NEEDS ATTENTION TO TRULY
ADDRESS TAKE CRIMES IN
CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING OUTREACH THE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES ANOTHER
RECOMMENDATION AND THE AUDIT
REPORT.
WE AGREE WITH THE AUDITOR THAT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS UNIQUELY POSITIONED
TO GUIDELINE FORSMAN AGENCIES IN
OUR OUTREACH TO ENSURE THAT IT
IS BOTH SENSITIVE AND EFFECTIVE.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE POINT
HOPE TO SEE THAT CONTINUE.
IN ADDITION TO POLICY CHANGES
THAT WOULD BETTER ADDRESS HATE
VIOLENCE WE KNOW IT IS CRUCIAL
FOR MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES TO
CONTINUE TO COME TOGETHER TO
SUPPORT EACH OTHER.
AND HELP KEEP EACH OTHER SAFE.
FOR THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY IN
PARTICULAR WE HAVE EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO
PARTNER WITH SERVICE PROVIDERS
AND WITH ORGANIZATIONS THAT
SERVE AN ADVOCATE FOR ALL THE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES OF WHICH
LGBTQ PEOPLE ARE PART. TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARD A FUTURE
THAT IS SAFER FOR ALL OF US.
THANK YOU FIGURE.
GOOD MORNING --
ITEMS SIEGEL CAN ON THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
I'D LIKE TO STARBUCKS R. OF BY
SAYING I LIKE TO THINK THAT
YEARS OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR
THE INVITATION TODAY AND I THANK
YOU ALL BECAUSE IT IS A
PRIVILEGE. TO STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH SUCH GREAT
ACTIVISTS AND LEADERS ON THE
GROUND --
AROUND SUCH AN IMPORTANT ISSUES
TO TAKE CRIMES.
I'M HERE TODAY --
FOR THE MARGINALIZED AND FOR THE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. TO
UPLIFT THEIR STORIES AND TO
HIGHLIGHT THEIR INTERSECTIONAL
VULNERABILITIES.
I'M HERE TO HOLD SPACE AND
GRIEVE --
FOR THE LIVES THAT HAVE BEEN
TAKEN.
CALIFORNIA NOW CALLS FOR THEM TO
BE BELIEVED. FOR ACCURATE
REPORTING FOR THEM TO BE
COUNTED.
AN ACTION TAKEN ON THEIR BEHALF
AND I'M HERE TO EMPLOY THIS CALL
AND HOLD SPACE FOR THESE
VICTIMS.
HATE CRIME IS NOT A NEW IS NOT
NEW FOR THE BLACK COMMUNITY AND
OTHER COMMUNITIES FOR COLOR.
WE KNOW ALL TOO WELL HOW THE
STORY GOES --
AYE WHOLE SPACE TODAY FOR FOLKS
LIKE AND OTHERS WHO WHOSE LIFE
WAS TAKEN ON JULY TWENTY SECOND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AT THE MARK ARE
THERE BUT BART STATION IN
OAKLAND.
JOHN HOW TWENTY SEVEN YEAR OLD
WHITE MALE OF WAS ARRESTED FOR
ME IS MURDER AND POLICE THEN
STATED OF THE COULD BLOCK WILL
CONCLUDE THAT THE CRIME WAS
RACIALLY MOTIVATED --
HIS FAMILY THEN ISSUED A
STATEMENT THAT HE WAS MENTALLY
UNFIT.
AND THIS IS USUALLY WHAT THE
CONVERSATION ENDS --
A A CRIME HAPPENS HE'S DECLARED
MENTALLY UNFIT BY THE END OF THE
CONVERSATION FAIR AND HER DEATH
IS NOT AN ISOLATED INCIDENT.
BIG THEN THE PROBLEM CANNOT BE
FULLY GRASP GIVEN THE MULTIPLE
FAILURES OF AUTHORITIES AND
SOCIETY AS A WHOLE TO CONFRONT
THE RISING TIDE OF WHITE
SUPREMACY.
SEX PHILIP SEXISM AND THAT A
VIXEN A PHOBIA.
HATE CRIMES ARE OCCURRING MORE
FREQUENTLY THAN.
THEN THE NUMBERS WOULD SUGGEST
BECAUSE THE MISTAKEN ASSUMPTION
THAT MENTAL ILLNESS STRESS ROAD
RAGE AND OTHER FACTORS OTHER
THAN HATE ARE REALLY THE ARE
REALLY WHAT'S AT PLAY.
MOREOVER CRIMES AGAINST BLACK
WOMEN MAY BE ESPECIALLY UNDER
REPORTED BECAUSE ANTI BLACK BIAS
ON TRADITIONALLY HAVE BEEN
FRAMED AS CRIMES AGAINST MEN.
THE HORRIFIC ASSAULT AGAINST MIA
AND OTHERS REMINDERS THAT GENDER
HAS NEVER SPARED BLACK WOMEN FOR
RACIAL TERRORISM.
RACIAL HATRED KNOWS NO GENDER
BOUNDARIES.
I WE CALL TODAY ON ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT TO DO BETTER BY
VICTIMS IN THESE COMMUNITIES.
ALL WE CALL FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO PROSECUTORS TO NOT PLAY HOT
POTATO WITH HATE CRIMES.
IN THE ROLE OF US LOCAL
ACTIVISTS AND AND NONPROFITS
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP SAYING THEIR
NAMES ARE WE WILL GET OUT THE
VOTE AND WE WILL ELECT THE RIGHT
LEADERS TO KEEP THIS ISSUE OF
THE FOUR PART FOUR FRONT.
AND GIVE IT THIS IS SERIOUS
ATTENTION THAT IT MEANS I WILL
CONTINUE TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
OF WE MUST WE MUST CONFRONT HEAD
ON THE REALITY THAT BIAS RACISM
SEXISM.
HOMOPHOBIA ANTI SAID SENTENCES
SOME TO THEM TRANSPHOBIA
XENOPHOBIA ARE REAL AND MARGIN
MARGINALIZED GROUPS THROUGH THE
PRICE. FOR THE REFUSAL TO CALL
IT WHAT IT IS.
WE CAN NO LONGER USE MENTAL
ILLNESS ROAD RAGE STRESS
TWINKIES --
AND OTHER CATCHALL PHRASE IS --
FOR THE DENIAL THAT THIS HATE
EXIT.
POLITICS ALSO TO PREVENT US FROM
IDENTIFYING AND ACTING ON THESE
VERY REAL FORMS OF HATE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
BIGGER KALIKA.
NEXT WOULD HAVE.
HELLO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
INVITING ME HERE AND FOR ALSO
HAVING THIS HEARING MY NAME IS
UNIX YES AND I AM.
THE LEGISLATIVE AND GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS COORDINATOR FOR THE
COUNCIL ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC
RELATIONS CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE THE NATION'S LARGEST
MUSLIM SO RIGHTS GROUP AND ALSO
ON THE LARGEST ADVOCATE HERE AT
IN THE CAPITAL FOR THE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY.
SO AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER BY
THE PROFESSOR ACTUALLY
ISLAMOPHOBIA IN HEAT INCIDENTS
TOWARDS MUSLIMS HAS ACTUALLY
INCREASING GOTTEN WORSE SINCE.
NINE ELEVEN AND UNFORTUNATELY
FOR OUR USE.
RIGHT NOW THAT ARE IN THE CASE
OR TWELVE SYSTEM THEY'VE
ACTUALLY NEVER LIVED IN A PRE
NINE ELEVEN WORLD SO FOR THEM
BULLYING ISLAMOPHOBIA AS A VERY
REGULAR THING FOR THEM.
AND JUST GOING INTO A THE
NATIONAL PICTURE AND LOOKING
STATEWIDE.
JUST LAST JUST LAST YEAR --
THEIR THIRTY EIGHT ANTI MOSQUE
INCIDENTS AND HATE CRIMES
TOWARDS HOUSES OF WORSHIP.
AND IN CALIFORNIA AND IN TERMS
OF THE ANTI MUSLIM BIAS
INCIDENTS THEIR EIGHT HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY ONE AS REPORTED BY
US SORT OFTENTIMES HAPPENS IN
OUR COMMUNITY IS THAT --
BECAUSE WHAT WE'VE SEEN AT ON
THE GROUND IS EITHER THE
COMMUNITY HAS A LANGUAGE BARRIER
OR THERE'S JUST A LACK OF TRUST
AT THE LAW ENFORCEMENT ACTUALLY
DO SOMETHING OR OR FOLLOW
THROUGH WITH THE CASE
THEY USUALLY CALL ORGANIZATION
FIRST AND WE USUALLY YOU KNOW I
HAVE TO CALL THE FBI ARE CALLED
THE SHERIFF FOR THE LOCAL POLICE
OFFICERS TO ACTUALLY COME TO THE
SCENE INCOME START.
TAKING EVIDENCE IN CONCERT
TALKING TO THE FOLKS AND I JUST
TO HIGHLIGHT AN EXAMPLE OF THAT
SO -- LAST
YEAR THE DAVIS MOSQUE JUST RIGHT
DOWN THE STREET --
IT WAS VANDALIZE A WINDOWS ARE
BROUGHT.
THE DOOR AND ONE INTERESTING
THING ABOUT THE INCIDENT THE
MOMENT WE HEARD ABOUT IT.
WE WERE AT FIRST WE JUST HEARD
OF THE VANDALISM SO WE WERE. ONE
WE NEED FOR US WE KNEW WAS A
HATE INCIDENT HOWEVER THE MOMENT
WE FOUND OUT IT WAS BE THERE IS
BEACON RAPPED ON THE DOOR WE
ACTUALLY HAD A SIGH OF RELIEF.
BECAUSE OFTENTIMES WHAT WE GET
IS IF IT APPEARS JUST TO BE MERE
VANDALISM OR SO ON INDIVIDUAL IS
ASSAULTED OR ATTACKED IT WILL BE
CONSIDERED JUST A OF A CRIME IT
WILL IT WILL BE CONSIDERED A
HATE CRIME SPECIFICALLY.
SO THE MOMENT WE FOUND OUT THAT
THERE IS BIG AND WE WERE
ACTUALLY REALLY HAPPY.
AND THEN WE ASK OURSELVES.
IS IT PORK WEEKEND BECAUSE FOR
US IT WAS IT WAS KIND OF ONE OF
THOSE THINGS WHERE.
ALTHOUGH IF IT SEEMS LIKE IT NOT
THAT BIG OF A DEAL FOR US THAT
WE NEED TO PROVE.
THAT IT'S A HATE INCIDENT FOR
FOR A FOR THAT TO HAPPEN IN
THANKFULLY I'M NOT THANKFULLY
BUT THANKFULLY THAT THERE WAS
ENOUGH EVIDENCE FOR THE POLICE
TO CONTINUE PROSECUTING BUT
OFTENTIMES O. IN WHAT HAPPENED
ACTUALLY DOWN THE STREET HERE IN
FLORIDA AND IS THERE WAS A
MOSQUE THAT WAS.
ACTUALLY TIE A SORRY THERE WAS A
CURRENT ACTUALLY TIED TO THE
DOOR OF THE GATES AND LIKE
DESTROYED COMPLETELY.
NUMBER BECAUSE THERE IS NO OTHER
EVIDENCE BUT LAKE VANDALISM.
IT WAS JUST SEEN AS A BASIC
VANDALISM.
SO THE COMMUNION MEMBERS ARE
LIKE HAVE BEEN SCARED AND JUST
WITH.
THE INCREASE OF ATTACKS TOWARDS
THE HOUSES OF WORSHIP WE'VE
ACTUALLY HAD TO CONDUCT --
SAFETY TRAININGS AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER TIONS AND FOR US THAT
THAT'S NOT A SOLUTION WERE
THANKFUL THAT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAVE STEPPED UP.
HAVE ACTUALLY DONE --
LOOKED AT THE HOUSE OF WORSHIP
CHO DO SAFETY --
SAFETY CHECK AND KIND OF GIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
IMPROVE JUST THE INNER WORKINGS
OF OUR MOSQUE JUST TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE ENOUGH SAFETY EXITS BUT
FOR US ON A SOLUTION THAT'S
MERELY JUST.
PREPARATION FOR THE WORST CASE
SCENARIO AND FOR JUST LOOKING AT
OUR SCHOOL SPECIFICALLY.
AND SO THE SOUTHERN POVERTY LAW
CENTER ACTUALLY REPORTED NINE
HUNDRED INCIDENTS WITHIN THE TEN
DAYS FOLLOWING THE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN ELECTIONS A MAJORITY OF
THOSE ACTUALLY OCCURRED IN
SCHOOLS.
SO FOR THE MUSCLE COMMUNITY
ABOUT 53% OF STUDENTS ARE
ACTUALLY BELIEVED.
AND IN TERMS OF THOSE THE
SISTERS THAT CHOOSE TO WEAR THE
HEAD RELIGIOUS HEADSCARF.
ACTUALLY THIRTY SIX OF THEM HAVE
EITHER RECEIVE VERY OFFENSIVE
TOUCHING PULLING OR HAVE BEEN
ATTACKS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE NUMBERS THAT
WE HAVE RECEIVED --
OVER THE YEARS BECAUSE WE'VE
BEEN TRACKING IT THERE A BOWLING
OR POOR IS IN 200014402% OF THE
RESPONDENTS.
OF THE STUDENTS IN THIS IS A OF
SURVEY TAKEN ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA --
FROM PUBLIC AND PRIVATE PA ON
SCHOOLS --
FELT THAT AN ADULT [inaudible]
LEARN THE SITUATION AS IT WAS
ALL BY AN ADULT BUT ONLY THIS
YEAR INTO THE ARMED TO ON
SIXTEEN OUR MOST RECENT REPORT
32%.
SO NUMBERS ARE ACTUALLY GETTING
WORSE -- AND
THE STUDENTS ARE ACTUALLY
REPORTING TO US DIRECTLY AND IN
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
NO REPORTS WHATSOEVER OF
BULLYING OR HATE INCIDENTS
TOWARDS MUSLIM STUDENTS BUT WE
HAVE THEM IN OUR REPORT. TO SHOW
IN TO TALK TO THE DISTRICT AND
THIS IS A VERY --
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
LIKE FOR US BUT ALSO --
JUST ONE ONE AND TO NOTE AND
HIGHLIGHT --
SOMETHING THAT WAS SAID EARLIER.
BUT THE SOUTHERN POVERTY LAW
CENTER REPORT MOST ON HATE
GROUPS HAVE INCREASED BY 197%.
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
INTO THE SIXTEEN THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT --
IS GETTING WORSE AND WE REALLY
NEED -- AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE AUDIT
BECAUSE IT GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE FORWARD AND
JUSTICE ISSUE A FEW THINGS THAT
WE RECOMMEND THROUGH.
THROUGH CARE THAT WOULD ALLOW US
TO FINALLY START TACKLING THESE
ISSUES IS REALLY JUST HAVING
IMPLICIT BIAS TRAININGS WITHIN
THE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
IN RECOGNIZING A BECAUSE
OFTENTIMES WHAT WE'VE SEEN.
IS.
SOME LAW ENFORCEMENT HITCHENS
YOU VERY --
ISLAMOPHOBIC RHETORIC AND AND
MAKE THE COMMUNITY FEEL
COMFORTABLE OR JUST DON'T ANSWER
CALLS.
SO THAT'S ONE THING NOTHING IS
--
A CONTINUING OUR COLLABORATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ON OUR REACH SHOWED USE BECAUSE
EACH.
COMMUNITY IT HAS UNIQUE --
CHARACTERISTICS BUT ALSO --
DIFFERENT --
MANNERS OF OUTREACH WORK.
DIFFERENTLY FOR PEOPLE AND ARE
MORE RECEPTIVE SO IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT HAVE TEAM PARTNERS IN
EACH WITH A SPECIALLY WHEN YOU
DOING OUR REGION LA VERSUS
SACRAMENTO IT'S GONNA LOOK VERY
DIFFERENT.
AND THEN WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE --
IN TERMS OF GETTING FEEDBACK FOR
UPDATES IN LIKE POST TRAININGS
OR ANY SORT OF TRAININGS FROM
LAW ENFORCEMENT IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT.
THE OUR REACH THAT'S DONE TO THE
COMMUTERS AND BRINGING THEM IN
TO GET FEEDBACK IS ACTUALLY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WORK WITH THE
COMMUNITY WHAT WE'VE SEEN FROM
THE MUSCLE COMMUNITY IS A LOT OF
WORK.
MUST SOME EXPERTS.
THEY'VE BEEN CALLED ARE ACTUALLY
--
REACHED OUT TO WHO WON HAVE NO
CONTACT WITH THEM OF SOME TO YOU
WHATSOEVER AND ACTUALLY PRESENT
ISLAMOPHOBIC MATERIAL THEMSELVES
SO THAT'S ONE IMPORTANT THING
THAT WE CAUTION BUT ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO SEE MORE OF IS THE RIGHT
ORGANIZATION AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERS.
CONTACTED.
AND LASTLY IS JUST THE
IMPORTANCE OF OUR POLICE
OFFICERS AND AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENTS WHO ARE ACTUALLY IS OF
THE ORGANIZATIONS TO BE VERY
MINDFUL THEIR PUBLIC.
BECAUSE THAT OFTENTIMES WILL
LEAD TO DISTRUST OF THE
COMMUNITY OF THEIR HEARING
SUPPORTER OF WHAT'S GOING ON THE
NATIONAL LEVEL OR JUST IN
GENERAL VERY.
I'M XENOPHOBIC COMMENTS --
THAT MEANS A LOT SIXTEEN XP
LISTENS THANK YOU.
MURRAY THINK YOU'RE VERY MUCH A
MISCONCEIVED ALSO.
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSTRUCTIVE
SUGGESTIONS AND RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK YOU AND NEXT TO HELP.
BREAK.
CHEERS GREG YEAH THANK YOU I'M
GLAD TO HEAR OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ADVOCATE OF THE ART CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS THE STATE'S OLDEST AND
LARGEST.
ADVOCACY GROUP SPEAKING FOR THE
NEEDS OF PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL AT ALL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THEIR AND THEIR FAMILIES --
WE ALSO WERE HAS MENTIONED THE
ON THOSE TWO SPONSORED MISTER
TANGS BILL THIS YEAR TO UPGRADE
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT HEALTHCARE
POLICY THAT.
PERSONALLY --
MY BIOGRAPHY I WAS.
I WROTE A DRAFT [inaudible]
LAW FOR Q. WHO AUTHORED.
WE TELL YOU START. NINE YEARS
AGO SIX CERTIFIED NURSE
ASSISTANTS WORKING THE SWING
SHIFT AT THE VALLEY VIEW SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY IN YOUR PATH.
WERE MAD AT THE NIGHT SHIFT FOR
SOME REASON.
AND WANTED TO TEACH THEM A
LESSON.
SO.
THEY POUNDS SEVEN WOMEN
RESIDENTS AGED SEVENTY NINE
THROUGH.
NINETY THREE WITH MODERATE TO
SEVERE DEMENTIA.
EACH OF THE WOMEN ALSO HAD OTHER
DISABILITIES INCLUDING ANXIETY
DEPRESSION PARKINSON'S DISEASE
AND SEIZURE DISORDERS.
EACH OF THE WOMEN WAS TOTALLY
DEPENDENT ON STAFF FOR ALL THE
ACTIVITIES OF DAILY LIVING
INCLUDING RATING AND PERSONAL
HYGIENE. ONE OF THE CIA'S WENT
WELL A LICENSED STAFF MEMBER AND
ASK FOR ADDITIONAL VITAMIN A IN
THE OIL SO THAT THEY COULD.
QUOTE.
LATHER UP TO RESIDENTS TO MAKE
THEM SLIPPERY FOR THE NIGHT
STAFF [inaudible]
CLOSE QUOTE.
THE LICENSE STAFF MEMBER A PAIR
EVIDENTLY COMPLIED WITH THE
REQUEST.
THE SIX CMA'S THEM GOT THE SEVEN
WOMEN OUT OF BED.
DEFLATED --
NINE THEY STRIPPED THEM NAKED.
THEY APPLIED LARGER AMOUNTS OF
THE ARGUMENT TO THEIR HANDS FEET
ARMS LEGS AND TORSOS.
AND RETURNED THEM TO BED FOR THE
NIGHT STAFF.
TO FIND.
WITH WOMEN'S BODIES COVERED WITH
THIS SLIPPERY OIL IT WAS
DIFFICULT FOR THE NIGHT STAFF.
TO ASSURE THEIR SAFETY TURNING A
MOVEMENT SO THE NIGHT STAFF WOKE
THE WOMEN UP.
GET THEM OUT OF BED GAVE THEM
SHOWERS ALL IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT.
THE NIGHT SHIFT WORKERS REPORTED
THIS TO THE STATE DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH.
STATE INVESTIGATORS CONFIRMED
REPORTS THEY INTERVIEWED THE OF
THE PERPETRATORS TO ADMIT IT
SOME DEAD ANYWAY.
I WIN THE IN THE INVESTIGATORS
TRY TO INTERVIEW THE VICTIMS.
THEY FOUND THEM TO BE LARGELY OR
TOTALLY NON COMMUNICATIVE WITH
NO INDICATION OF WHETHER THEY'RE
AND RESPONSIVENESS WAS CAUSED
ENTIRELY.
BY A BY A PRE EXISTING
CONDITIONS.
OR PARTLY BY WHAT THE STATE
CITATION. ONE DRYLY CALLED.
SIGNIFICANT HUMILIATION IN
DIGNITY ANXIETY OR OTHER
EMOTIONAL TRAUMA.
BECAUSE BY THE*.
THE SIX TEENAGERS WERE CONVICTED
OF MISDEMEANORS.
THERE'S NO INDICATION IN THE
RECORD.
THAT THE POLICE.
THE DA OR ANYONE ELSE EVEN
THOUGHT OF CHARGING THE
PERPETRATORS WITH A CRIME.
WHICH WOULD HAVE.
RAISED THE MISDEMEANORS TO
FELONIES.
I POINTEDLY --
NOTED THAT THE CRIMINALS IN THIS
CASE WHERE SHE HAS BECAUSE
SEEING A UNLIKE MOST
PROFESSIONAL CAREGIVERS.
ARE NOT ALWAYS SUBJECT TO
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECKS.
I'VE ANY --
LESLIE HERE IS A PERSON CARRYING
A BILL TO CORRECT THAT LOOPHOLE
THAT NEXT YEAR WE MIGHT BE
ABSENT SPONSOR INMIGRANTE.
UNIVERSITY RESEARCH SUPPORTS OUR
BELIEF THAT THIS SORT OF CRIME
AGAINST PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
INCLUDING DISABILITIES CAUSED BY
AGING.
AND OUGHT OFTEN COMMITTED BY
CARE.
AND OFTEN WITH WHAT.
WHAT UNIVERSITY RESEARCHER
CALLED?
EXTRAORDINARY ACTS OF SADISM
[inaudible]
IS COMMON.
THESE CRIMES ARE GROSSLY UNDER
REPORTED LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
WHEN REPORTED OFFICERS ALMOST
UNIVERSALLY OVERLOOK THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THEY ARE HATE
CRIMES.
IN THE U. K. CASE.
THAT.
LEAVE THE CRIMINALS WORK AND
ARRESTED AND CONVICTED OF
SOMETHING. TOO OFTEN OFFICERS
OVERLOOK THESE CRIMES AS THESE
ACCESS CRIMES AT ALL AND REFER
THEM TO CIVIL AGENCIES SUCH AS
THE ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES.
I KNOW YOU'VE HEARD A LOT OF
STATISTICS TODAY BUT I I DO HAVE
TO GIVE YOU A COUPLE THAT ARE
SPECIFIC CRIMES AGAINST PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES INCLUDING.
DISABILITY BECAUSE I AGING
ATTENTION NATIONALLY BEAT.
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ARE
SUBJECT OF VIOLENT CRIME AT
ABOUT TWICE.
THE RATE OF THE GENERAL PUBLIC
POPULATION.
THE SUBJECT OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
ABOUT FOUR TIMES GENERATE.
AND THESE ARE CONSERVATIVE
ESTIMATES.
ACCORDING TO ONE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA REPORT.
THEIR TWO MAJOR CATEGORIES AB
MOTIVATIONS FOR THE SCRAPS. ONE
CATEGORY IS THE PERCEPTION OF
PEOPLE THOSE WITH DISABILITIES
ARE ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE.
THIS MAY THEY THESE MAY OR MAY
NOT BE HATE CRIMES DEPENDING ON
THE FACTS OF EACH INDIVIDUAL
CASE [inaudible]
OTHER CATEGORY.
A MOTIVATION IS PURE BY US
[inaudible]
SPECIFICALLY.
HOSTILITY TO PERSONS WHO ROWS
FEAR OR GUILT.
FEAR OF PERSONS WHOSE VISIBLE
TRAITS MAY BE DISTURBING TO
OTHERS.
RESENTMENT OF THOSE WHO NEED
RECEIVE HER AND INCREASINGLY
DEMAND ALTERNATIVE
ACCOMMODATIONS.
OR A PERCEPTION THAT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ARE INFERIOR.
AND THEREFORE DESERVING VICTIMS.
THESE ARE HATE CRIMES EVERYONE
OF THOSE DESCRIBED AS ACRE.
I KNOW THAT IN THE UK CASE THE
CRIMINAL ACTION EVEN WITHOUT ANY
OTHER EVIDENCE.
WOULD HAVE BEEN STRONG EVIDENCE
IN COURT THAT THE SIENESE WERE
MOTIVATED BY THE LAST OF THOSE
THAT LIST OF ABUSES TREATIES
WOMEN'S AS WITH DISABILITIES AS
INFERIOR.
ALMOST SUB HUMAN. TO BE USED AS
OBJECTS AS FAIR GAME. TO GET
EVEN WITH THEIR DAY CHEF WHAT
WITH ARAB NIGHT SHIFT
COLLEAGUES.
IF IF THE POLICE HAD
INVESTIGATED FURTHER THEY MAY OR
MAY NOT HAVE FOUND FURTHER
EVIDENCE OF BIAS BUT EVEN
WITHOUT THAT.
THE THERE WAS A THERE MAY VERY
WELL HAVE BEEN ENOUGH EVIDENCE
TO CONVINCE A JURY THAT THESE.
THAT THIS WAS BIASED MOTIVATION
OF THEIR HATE CRIMES THEY'RE
CERTAINLY NOT TO REPORT TO THE
STATE.
LET ME ADD HERE THAT.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING A LOT ABOUT
REPORTING THIS IS NOT JUST A
STATISTICAL.
PROBLEM THAT THAT THE MUNICIPAL
PROBLEM THAT TO THE WE DON'T
KNOW HOW BIG THE PROBLEM IS.
IT'S ALSO A PROBLEM ON THE
GROUND IN CASES LIKE THIS THAT
IF POLICE THEM DON'T RECOGNIZE
THAT A HATE CRIME THE PERSON THE
PERPETRATORS DON'T GET
PROSECUTED --
ALTHOUGH THAT.
OF FOR ALL HATE CRIMES THIS IS
ONLY CRIMES NOT JUST AND HAD
THIS BILL HE CRIMES THE TERM HE
CRIME IS A BIT MISLEADING. TO BE
A CRIME A CRIME MOST REMOTE AS
YOU HEARD MUST BE MOTIVATED.
NOT NECESSARILY BY HATE BUT BY
BIAS.
ANY BIAS AGAINST A PROTECTED
CHARACTERISTIC.
THE AN ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OPINION THAT LIST MOTIVATIONS
BEYOND HATE OR ANIMOSITY.
THAT DEPENDING ON THE EVIDENCE
IN THIS CASE MAY MAKE A CRIME
HATE CRIMES.
THE AGES LIST OF THESE BY HIS
MOTIVATIONS IS.
RESENTMENT REVULSION CONTEMPT
UNREASONABLE FEAR PARANOIA
CALLOUSNESS.
THRILL SEEKING DESIRE FOR SOCIAL
DOMINANCE OR DESIRE TO FOR
SOCIAL BONDING WITH ONE'S OWN
KIND [inaudible]
CLOSE QUOTE.
AT AGES OPINION ADDS THAT THIS
IS NOT EVERY COOK EXHAUSTIVE
LIST.
THIS PARTIAL IS IMPORTANT FOR
ARRESTING AND CONVICTING THOSE
WHO COMMIT ANTI DISABILITY HATE
CRIMES AND THOSE WHO COMMIT ALL
HATE CRIMES AND TO THE THE
AUTOBLOG PERHAPS.
NOT ONLY GAVE IT A DISABILITY
CRIMES ALL ALL THE CRIMES OFTEN
DON'T RECOGNIZE SOME OF THESE AS
INDICATORS EVIDENCE OF A CRIME.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THAT WERE
NATIONALLY REPORTED [inaudible]
SEVENTY THREE ANTI DISABILITY
HATE CRIMES TO THE FBI.
SEVENTY THREE THAT SAME YEAR US
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SURVEY
ADDICTIVENESS FOR THE PREVIOUS
FIVE YEARS [inaudible]
COUNTED ABOUT. FORTY THOUSAND
PER YEAR [inaudible]
HOUSE AREA. FORTY THOUSAND
VICTIMS OF ANTI DISABILITY HATE
CRIMES PER YEAR. SEVENTY THREE
OF THEM REPORTED [inaudible]
BUT POLICE.
I THINK WE CAN BE REASONABLY
CERTAIN THAT THERE WERE NO
PROSECUTIONS AND MANY BEYOND THE
SEVENTY THREE IF THEY'RE IF
THEY'RE IF EVEN THAT MANY.
THE SAME YEAR IN CALIFORNIA AND
AGAIN LAST YEAR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES REPORTED JUST. FOR FOR
ANTI DISABILITY CRIMES IN THE
WHOLE STATE LAST YEAR AND FOR
AND FOR THE YEAR BEFORE.
I I DON'T HAVE TIME TO GO INTO
OUR DETAILED POLICIES
RESTRICTIONS OF THIS PROBABLY
ISN'T THE RIGHT TIME.
FORM FOR THAT LITTLE DETAIL
ANYWAY I WILL SAY THAT WE
SUPPORT ALL OF THE EIGHT THE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND SOME OF THE SUGGESTIONS THAT
BEEN MADE BY --
DOJ STAFF HERE.
AND WE ASK.
THAT THAT --
IN CARRYING THOSE OUT THAT WOULD
BE SPECIAL ATTENTION PAID TO
HATE CRIMES AGAINST PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES BECAUSE THERE HAS
BEEN SPECIAL LACK OF ATTENTION
UPHILL INCLUDING TODAY.
OUR PRIMARY PLEASE TODAY IS TO
ATTORNEY GENERAL BUT SARAH.
MISTER ATTORNEY GENERAL IF
YOU'RE LISTENING.
WE NEED YOUR LEADERSHIP WE NEED
YOUR CONTINUED LEADERSHIP WE
NEED YOUR INCREASED LEADERSHIP.
THERE ARE. THIRTY NINE MILLION
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA AND YOU'RE
THE ONLY ONE OF THE POSITION.
TO LEAD THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES HAS BEEN AS HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED TO SPEAK OUT PUBLICLY
LEAD THE PUBLIC AND THE SPONSOR
LEGISLATION OFFENSE OR WE HOPE
WILL BE A COMP.
THE PACKAGE OF LEGISLATION NEXT
YEAR IS LARGELY.
AND WE ASK THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
TO WORK CLOSELY WITH ALL THE
CIVIL RIGHTS GROUPS NOT JUST US.
AND THE DISABILITY GROUPS.
WE BELIEVE THAT WITHOUT OUR
BUSINESS.
SPECIFICALLY DISABILITIES BUTTON
PERHAPS SOMEWHAT TRUE ABOUT THE
OTHER HATE CRIMES OF HATE
CRIMES.
TO WITHOUT OUR EXPERTISE.
AND WITHOUT OUR ADVOCACY.
WE BELIEVE LITTLE OR NOTHING
WILL CHANGE.
YOU'RE VERY SECULAR MUCH OF THIS
THROUGH THE SURE.
AND NEXT WILL --
OF ANDREW ANDREW MEDINA HOT HIGH
EDGE MEDINA AYE COMPANY POLICY
MANAGER FOR ASIAN ACTED AS
NURSES CALIFORNIA IT'S A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN.
THAT AND JUST AS ASIAN LAW
CAUCUS ATTEMPT IS GOING AGAINST
INJUSTICE ANALYSTS WELL IT'S ALL
RIGHTS AND A LEGAL CIVIL RIGHTS
GROUP THAT SEEMS THAT.
ASIAN AMERICAN IT WINDS HAVE
GONE TO COMMUNITY SAID AMY
SPECULATING.
I LOOK AT THINK CHAIRS AYE CHIU
MURATSUCHI FROM OF IN THIS WORK
FAR ESPECIALLY FOR STAFF --
FOR ORGANIZING THIS AND DOING
THE BACKGROUND WORK --
ANOTHER LIFE I STOPPED
RESOLUTIONS FOR THAN SOMEONE
PROJECT CHIU WHO HAD MOVED TO HE
COMES AWARENESS I RESOLUTION AS
WELL AS I'VE HEARINGS AS CHAIR.
OF SILICON IN HATE CRIMES SPOCK
AND I OWE --
FOUR OH FIVE HAVE VERY VIVID
MEMORY I HAVE A PRESS CONFERENCE
WHERE -- WE
WERE WITH THE FAMILY OF JOSEPH
LEN TO SHARE THE STORY OF
JOSEPH WHO WAS KILLED.
AND BY ABOUT A WHITE SEPARATIST
LOS ANGELES BY SHOOTING IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE I THE STATE
SHOOTING WHERE THE KILLER SHOT
AND WOUNDED --
FIVE JEWISH YOUTH --
I BRING A LOOK BACK TO THOSE
DAYS I BECAUSE WE PATH FOR TODAY
AND HER SOUL OF CHALLENGE RIGHT.
AT FULLER MERCY SHE HAD PENSION
I'M JUST RECENTLY INFAMOUS
COUNTY --
THERE WAS A SEEK A COMMITTEE
MEMBER WHO IS OUT CAMPAIGNING
PUTTING OUT --
LONG SANDERS THE VERY GENERAL
THINGS MOST PROBABLY AMERICAN TO
YOU PROBABLY DO YOU ACT BEING
PART OF THE CIVIC PROCESS --
CAME UP TO SHOCKING WAS BRUTALLY
BEAT AND I'M WITH SOMEONE
SHOUTING ABOUT YOUR COUNTRY
RIGHT AND AND HAVING HIS SON
CHUCKS BREAKING IT WITH HATE
SPEECH INDEED SYMBOLS --
YOU KNOW THIS IS PART OF A
GROWING KIND OF TREND WHEN YOU
LOOK IT ISLAMOPHOBIA IN THE
UNITED STATES AND WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE MOST SEVERE CASES OF
SHOOTINGS OF INDIAN SICK MAN AND
THAT LOOKING AT CANCER SO
LOOKING WASHINGTON.
AND ONE CASE IN WASHINGTON WHERE
ALLEGEDLY AT THE ILLEGAL ABOUT
YOUR COUNTRY WAS ALSO YELLED
ACHIEVED IN A MONTHS AND SEVERE
CASES OF THE SHOOTING OF A
COUPLE OF THE TEMPLE IN
WISCONSIN JOHNSON.
TWELVE AND GOING TO CALIFORNIA
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE A TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND THERE'S
ACTUALLY IT'S IN RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA --
WERE SEEKING AND WAS STRIDING
HAD ALTERED.
AND KEPT DRIVING STOP AND IT WAS
ATTACKED AND BEATEN REALLY
THROUGH HIS CAR WINDOW HAD HIS
TURBAN RIPPED OFF AND PART OF
HIS HAIR CUT OFF --
PACKED HEARING --
WHERE TWO ASSAILANTS --
WERE CHARGED WITH A FELONY AND I
HATE CRIME HACKNEY --
I DID WANT TO MENTION A QUOTE
FROM AND A SURVIVOR WHO IT SAID
TO RECOGNITION OF THE ATTACK AS
A HATE CRIME.
AS A HARM TO MY DIGNITY AND MY
ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
THE FIRST STEP IN THE PROCESS.
I THINK THIS SPEAKS LOUDLY IN
TERMS OF TO IMPACTS OF HATE
CRIMES FOR COMMUNITIES IN TERMS
OF HOW SUCH AN INDIVIDUAL CLIENT
BUT DEATH AND PACK FOR A LARGER
COMMUNITY --
LOOKING AT SERVE I KNOW WE WE'VE
TALKED THEIR LIVES TO STICKS AND
LOOKING AT MAYBE SOME MORE
LOCALLY.
AND THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
RELATIONS COMMISSION AND RELEASE
IT'S I TWO THOUSAND FIVE HIT HE
COMES UPON --
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND THAT'S
OWES ONE INDICATOR FOR MY LOCAL
PHILLY IN TERMS OF CONCERNS
ABOUT AN INCREASE CHAINED UP
HATE CRIMES.
AND THIS WAS A SEVEN YEAR
DOWNWARD TREND IN LOS ANGELES
AND THE SUPPORT REPORTED A 24%
INCREASE IN --
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN FOLLOW
REPORTED ON SIXTEEN IT WAS SORT
OF A SORT SOMEWHERE PLATEAU --
BUT STILL HAD A SIMILAR HIGHER
NUMBERS THAN PREVIOUS YEARS --
INTO TWO THOUSAND FEET YOUR
POINTED IT SHOWN INCREASE OF
HATE CRIMES ASIAN AMERICANS --
CLEARLY --
FOR PERSONS OF CHINESE DESCENT
--
AND TO WE DO HAVE A SENSE AYE
LOBBYISTS ARE TIED TO THE
STEREOTYPES OF OF FOLKS BEING --
FOREIGN I'M NOT --
BUT THERE'S ALSO LARGE CONCERNS
ABOUT UNDER REPORTING SPECIAL
FOR A IN ITS PICK COMMUNITY
WHERE YOU HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT.
LANGUAGE ACCESS ON FEAR --
AND GOVERNMENT WHETHER YOU HAVE
STATUS --
THINKING THAT IF YOUR PARTNER
THING IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN RIGHT
AND SO WE DO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT.
SO AS A RESULT ASIAN RECOGNIZING
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA PARTNER FOR
AFFILIATES TO CREATE.
A WEBSITE STAND AGAINST FUTURE
DOT ORG TO HELP SHOCKING HAVE
FOLKS WHO GOOD WEBSITE HAS AYE
DIFFERENT TRANSLATIONS AND TO BE
ABLE TO REPORT.
AS SORT OF LOOKING NEED
REPORTING SYSTEM AND I'D BE
MINDFUL THAT THIS ISN'T BEING
APART PLACE AND ALSO FOR FOLKS
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT DO LIKE TO
REPORT -- S.
FOLKS YOU KNOW HAD MENTIONED AND
THERE IS A LOT OF CONCERN ABOUT.
HATE CRIMES INCREASING WHEN WE
HAVE INCIDENTS OF TERRORISM
THAT'S YOU KNOW.
THAT COULD FEED IT ISLAMOPHOBIA
ARE INSTANCES WHERE OUR
POLITICAL LEADERS ARE USING
REALLY HATEFUL RHETORIC --
IT IS ESPECIALLY BASHING FOREIGN
ENTITIES SWEATY KIND OF TIRE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS OF THOSE
FOREIGN ENTITIES --
YOU KNOW GOING TO
RECOMMENDATIONS YOU KNOW I LOOK
AT OUR MERCY CHEAT WITH SOMEONE
UBER MERCY SHE'S SEEN EARLY
ABOUT LIKE THESE CULTURE
DIFFERENCES HOW DO WE TALKED AND
AND MY MY THING IT'S GOING TO
FOCUS MOSTLY ABOUT.
HOW CAN WE SERVE ADDRESSES IN
THE SCHOOL SETTING SINCE AND WE
HAD TALKED EARLIER ABOUT HOW A
LOT OF THESE INCIDENTS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING GRADE SCHOOL --
AND THE SCHOOL SETTING AND LAST
YEAR -- WE
PARTED OF QUALITY CALIFORNIA
CARE CALIFORNIA VESTED PROJECT
TO TRY TO MOVE SQUABBLING
LEGISLATION --
AROUND AYE TRAININGS FOR SCHOOL
AND I FLICKED AND I WAS AND
UNFORTUNATELY NOT ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD --
THIS YEAR REMOVING A BETWEEN
FORTY FIVE I THINK WE DAVID CHIU
THAT WOULD REQUIRE --
BY SHARING OF A TRAINING MODULE
DEVELOP BY CITY E. WITH SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES AS WELL AS FOR AYE
REQUIRING LITTLE THAT
EXCRUCIATING FEES DEVELOP PLANS
FOR BLINK PREVENTION --
OUR HOPE HERE'S THE KIND OF
ADDRESSES GROWING AND OUT OF
BULLETS HELPING OUR COMMUNITIES
AND OUR SCHOOLS.
AND SAID THIS IS A RESOURCE
CENTER ACTUALLY DID --
A YOUTH --
SURVEY AND IN THAT SURVEY IT
FOUND THAT ONE OF TUITION
AMERICANS EXPERIENCE BILLINGS
GREAT SCHOOLS TO CALIFORNIA --
WE APPLIED --
WITH THE LEGISLATURE FOR AND
SUPPORTING GOVERNOR BROWN'S --
PROPOSAL FOR FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND WE CAN FUNDING OF
FOR THE STATE'S MULTI TIERED
SYSTEM SUPPORT FRAMEWORK TO
FOSTER POSITIVE SCHOOL CLAIMING.
IT WOULD SUPPORTING FURTHER
DOLLARS TO HELP YOU KNOW I TRY
SCHOOL CLIMATE.
AND CHATTED TO STUDENTS AND
WHERE THEY'RE DEVELOPING AND
LEARN ABOUT OTHER COMMUNITIES
AND ALSO THAT I AYE.
PURE MISGUIDED MENTION AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN G. BY MEDINA AYE
WHICH WOULD CREATE REQUIREMENTS
FOR STUDENTS TAKE EPIC STUDIES
COURSES --
BECAUSE IDEAS COURSES ALLOW FOR
STUDENTS OF COLOR WHO MAY NOT
LEARN ABOUT IT YOU NEED HELP
BUILD CONFIDENCE AND WITH THE
RELEVANT EDUCATION PROSTITUTE.
OUT LEARN ABOUT EXPERIENCES
ABOUT THE COMMUNITIES I'M SO
THAT -- I
WILL LEAD TO OTHER CONDITIONS IN
OUR CONVERSATION HUMAN NATURE SO
THEY ARE MUCH FOR CAN THAT BE
ABLE TO TEST.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU MR MEDINA NEXT
WE HAVE --
ERIC HARRIS FROM AND AND THE
BOWIE CP WHICH I JUST RENEW MY
MEMBERSHIP.
GOOD MORNING  MY NAME IS ERIC
HARRIS I AM THE LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE CONFERENCE OF THE NAACP.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATT MORRIS
WHERE IT'S SUJI --
FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING.
TO HATE CRIMES OF HAS A DEEP
HISTORY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA --
ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA'S KNOWN
TODAY AS THE MOST DIVERSE STATE.
IN AMERICA AND WE SHOULD BE VERY
PROUD OF THAT --
WE'VE ALSO WE ALSO --
BELIEVE THAT WE ARE VERY
ACCEPTING A VERY PROGRESSIVE --
HOWEVER CALIFORNIA HAS HAD
ISSUES INVOLVING RACISM
DISCRIMINATION AND HATRED SINCE
IT WAS FOUNDED.
HATE INCIDENTS AND CRIMES HAVE
OCCURRED AGAINST AFRICAN
AMERICANS --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE'S HISTORY
AND HAS INCLUDED BEATINGS
LYNCHINGS AND BOMBINGS.
TODAY MORE THAN HALF OF THE HATE
CRIMES REPORTED IN CALIFORNIA
LAST YEAR.
INVOLVED RACIAL BIAS AND MANY OF
THOSE --
INVOLVED HATRED AGAINST AFRICAN
AMERICANS.
IT SHOCKED MANY CALIFORNIANS
THAT TODAY HATE CRIMES AGAINST
AFRICAN AMERICANS CONTINUE TO
RISE.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS DID NOT
SURPRISE MANY AFRICAN AMERICANS.
WHO SEE HATRED A CONSISTENT
BASIS?
AS REVEREND AMOS BROWN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CUP OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO NAACP RECENT RECENTLY
POINTED OUT AND AS OTHERS HAVE
POINTED OUT TODAY.
THE DISCRIMINATION INCREASE CAN
BE WENT TO THE POLITICAL
RHETORIC IN WASHINGTON DC.
THERE ARE MANY INCIDENTS THAT
HAPPENED --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND MANY
THAT HAVE HAPPENED RECENTLY
INCLUDING LAST MONTH.
THERE ARE COUNTLESS INCIDENTS OF
BULLYING DEFACING OF PROPERTY.
BREAKING AND ENTERING VERBAL
ATTACKS AND INTIMIDATION AGAINST
AFRICAN AMERICANS.
LAST MONTH WE SAW TERRIBLE
EXAMPLE OF HATE WHAT THE VIOLENT
ATTACK THOSE SPOKEN ABOUT
EARLIER OF WO SISTERS NEIL
WILSON AND WITH HE FOR WILSON IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
DNIA WHO WAS TRAGICALLY KILLED.
PAT.
THE BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT BART
STATION IN OAKLAND AT MCCARTY
STATION.
AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE CALIFORNIA
AND THE COUNTRY HAVE EXPRESSED
SADNESS AND EVEN FEAR AS A
RESULT OF THIS HORRIFIC TRAGEDY.
THIS WAS IN A PUBLIC PLACE WITH
CAMERAS AND SECURITY.
IF WE CANNOT FEEL SAFE IN A
SITUATION LIKE THIS ONE BEEN
WHERE CAN WE FEEL SAFE.
THE TRAGEDY HAS BEEN CALLED AN
ISOLATED OR A RANDOM INCIDENT.
HOWEVER AS LEGALLY LIVE PEROT
FROM SLATE MAGAZINE STATED.
ABOUT THE STABBING THIS FEELS
ANYTHING BUT RANDOM.
THIS FEELS LIKE PART OF A RACIST
CULTURE WHERE INCIDENTS SUCH AS
THIS ONE OCCUR REGULARLY AND
WITHOUT MUCH ATTENTION STATEWIDE
OR NATIONALLY.
STUDIES FROM PSYCHOLOGISTS HAVE
SHOWN.
THAT RACISM AND HATEFUL ACTS
COMMITTED IN THE NAME OF RACISM
CAN CAUSE PTSD.
WHEN THERE ARE?
MANY OF THESE INCIDENTS
OCCURRING ON A DAILY BASIS THE
IMPACT ON THE VICTIMS CAN BE
EXTENSIVE.
VICTIMS OFTEN FEEL LIKE THEY ARE
GOING CRAZY.
WHILE MOST OF US UNDERSTAND Y.
PTSD COULD BE THE RESULT OF
VIOLENT CRIME VIOLENT HATE
CRIMES.
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT PTSD.
CAN ALSO BE THE RESULT OF MARK
MICROGRAPH SHINS BUILDING UP
[inaudible]
MANY.
ARE BURKE SORRY ALMOST ONE IN.
TEN BLACK PEOPLE IN AMERICA
BECOME TRAUMATIZED BECAUSE OF
RACISM AND HATRED.
THIS LEADS TO PHYSICAL HEALTH
ISSUES HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE
DEPRESSION AND OTHER STRESS
RELATED AFFECTS.
MANY AFRICAN AMERICANS WE'LL TRY
TO COMPENSATE FOR THESE FEELINGS
BY HAVING A STRONGER SENSE OF
AFRICAN AMERICAN IDENTITY.
HOWEVER THIS IS TYPICALLY NOT
ENOUGH TO OVERCOME THE MENTAL
ANGUISH OF CONSTANT HATRED.
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT TRAUMA
CAN ALTER ONE'S PERCEPTION OF
OVERALL SAFETY IN SOCIETY.
HATE CRIMES WITH AN ANIMUS
TOWARDS AFRICAN AMERICANS DOES
NOT JUST IMPACT THAT ONE PERSON
AT THAT MOMENT.
BUT HAS A SUSTAINING IMPACT ON
AN ENTIRE COMMUNITY OF PEOPLE
AND REINFORCES STEREOTYPICAL
IDEAS THAT AFRICAN AMERICANS
HAVE WORKED HARD. TO FIGHT
AGAINST.
IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND.
THAT AFRICAN AMERICANS ALSO
INTERSECT WITH OTHER GROUPS AS
WE SPOKE ABOUT EARLIER AFRICAN
THE LGBT COMMUNITY AFRICAN
AMERICANS WERE ALSO MUSLIM
AFRICAN AMERICANS.
OF WHO HAVE PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES.
I AM ALSO INCLUDED IN OF THE
INTERSECTION.
AND IT IS VERY STRESSFUL AND CAN
BE -- VERY
FRUSTRATING BECAUSE OF AN AMOUNT
OF FEAR WHEN YOU DON'T KNOW
WHETHER YOU'RE BEING
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST BECAUSE OF
THEIR RACE OR BECAUSE WE'RE
DISABILITY OR BECAUSE OF YOUR
GENDER.
OF IDENTITY.
MOVING FORWARD THERE ARE TWO
MAIN POINTS THAT WE HOPE THE
LEGISLATURE --
CONTINUES TO CONSIDER.
AS AN ORGANIZATION WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT COMMUNITIES.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE
EDUCATED ON HATE CRIMES AND
THEIR IMPACTS ON COMMUNITIES.
SECOND IT IS IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT THESE INCIDENTS
ALONG WITH AN ADEQUATE FOLLOW
UP.
AND REPORTING CONTRIBUTE TO THE
FEARS THAT COMMUNITIES CARRY
WITH THEM [inaudible] FOR
GENERATIONS.
I LIKE TO THINK.
BOTH OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR
WORKING WITH COMMUNITY LEADERS
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA STATE
NAACP TO ADDRESS THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE FUTURE.
WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
MISTER HARRIS NEXT UP WE HAVE
THE JANNAT.
THEN THEN THE ULTIMATELY FOR
THEME LEGISLATIVE STAFF ATTORNEY
WITH MALTA SECULAR MUCH FOR
HELPING ME LISTA PRONUNCIATION.
OKAY AND CITIES TO IT I'M SO
GOOD GOOD GOOD MORNING --
I REALLY WANT TO THANK BOTH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
CHIU AND US AND WE WERE
MURATSUCHI FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE. FOR MALTA'S HE NO LONGER
FITS ONE OF THE LEADING LATINO
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES WE ARE
CELEBRATING OUR FIFTIETH HERE.
AND AS I REFLECT ON OUR FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY --
I DO REFLECT ON THE STORIES OF
THE HISTORY THAT --
MY COLLEAGUE HERE ERIC --
HAS MENTIONED IN TERMS OF THE
HISTORY TERMINATION AND OVER
POLICING OF OF OF OUR
COMMUNITIES OF ALL COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR.
BUT IN PARTICULAR BLOCKING
BALCONIES AND AN API COMMUNITIES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A LONG
HISTORY OF BEING OVER POLICE
DOES A COMMUNITY AS YOU KNOW IN
THE FORTIES THERE WERE THINGS I
HAVE.
I HAVE THEIR INCIDENTS KNOWN AS
ON THIS ISSUE RIOTS WHERE.
ON PARTICULAR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WERE TARGETED BECAUSE OF THE WAY
THEY WERE DRESSED BECAUSE OF
PERHAPS THEIR CITIZENSHIP
THEY'VE BEEN INCIDENTS
THROUGHOUT OUR HISTORY WHERE THE
POLICE HAVE.
TARGET OUR COMMUNITIES AND
THEREFORE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THESE
THINGS AND LOOK AT WHAT'S
HAPPENING TODAY.
UM WE KINDA COME FULL CIRCLE ON
SOME OF THESE ISSUES
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE STILL.
IN A PLACE WHERE WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES.
BUT HOPEFULLY --
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA HAS AND CAN
BE A LEAD ON A LOT OF THESE
ISSUES NATIONALLY WERE HOPING
THAT.
THAT WE GET START CHANGING THAT
DIALOGUE AND THAT DEBATE AND BE
MORE INFORMED ABOUT.
WHAT IS GOING ON --
IN PARTICULAR WITH OUR COMMUNITY
SO FOR LATINOS THERE HAS BEEN A
DEFINITE INCREASE IN EIGHT IN
HATE CRIMES.
OVER 50% AN INCREASE IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS --
IT IS NOT SURPRISING THAT I'M A
LOT OF THIS HAD AS A DIRECT
CORRELATION WITH THE RHETORIC
THAT WE'RE HEARING COMING OUT
FROM.
WASHINGTON D. C. AND THIS
FEDERAL AND THE UNITED STATES
CALLING.
THE EMAIL AND LETTING THE
IMMIGRANTS IN TRADERS FUHRMAN
ANIMAL RAPIST YOU NAME IT.
IT IS OPEN SEASON ON IMMIGRANTS
AND IT'S NOT JUST THE
UNDOCUMENTED FOLKS WHO ARE AT
THE SHOULD BE FEELING VULNERABLE
THIS ADMINISTRATION WITH ITS
IMMIGRATION POLICIES IS REALLY.
GOING AFTER ALL LATINOS WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE POLICIES THAT ARE
BEING IMPLEMENTED RIGHT NOW AT
THE BORDER.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT --
POLICIES THAT ARE CHANGING
TOWARDS OF LEGAL IMMIGRANTS
OPENING RE OPENING CASES OF
FOLKS THAT WHO HAVE ALREADY
NATURALIZED FOR POTENTIAL FRAUD
FOR FOR POTENTIAL SHORTCOMINGS
IN.
IN THE APPLICATION PROCESS IT'S
REALLY OPEN SEASON ON ALL
IMMIGRANTS.
OF ALL COLORS AND ARE WE REALLY
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT THAT'S
WHAT OUR COMMUNITY IS FACING
RIGHT NOW.
IN TERMS OF WHAT OUR COMMUNITY
IS FACING THERE IS REAL FEAR
AMONG IMMIGRANTS I AM AN
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY OTHER
PRACTICING FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
I DO.
SEVERAL MILLION RIGHTS
PRESENTATIONS ON THROUGHOUT
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND I CAN SEE RIGHT AFTER THE
ELECTION GOING TO THESE OF
WORKSHOPS AND CAN YOU BE CERTAIN
IS A COMMUNITY BASED --
FORUMS -- I
WOULD GET FLOODED WITH PEOPLE
AFTER I GAVE A PRESENTATION
ABOUT QUESTIONS ABOUT
IMMIGRATION ABOUT QUESTIONS
ABOUT.
ON LAW ENFORCEMENT AND RIGHT
AFTER THE ELECTION WHAT I WOULD
DO THESE PRESENTATIONS I WOULD
HAVE ANYONE COME UP TO ME
BECAUSE THEY ARE SO AFRAID.
TALK OUT LOUD TO ANYONE ABOUT
ANY OF THESE ISSUES THAT THEY'RE
FACING SOARED TO THE TERMS OF
THE FEAR THAT IS GOING ON WITH
IMMIGRANTS.
YOU CAN ALMOST TOUCH IT YOU
COULD FEEL THE FEAR THAT
IMMIGRANTS ARE FEELING THAT THIS
IS THE ENVIRONMENT THAT A LOT OF
FOLKS ARE.
AYE LIVING DAILY ON THERE'S A
FEAR IN REPORTING HATE CRIMES IN
PARTICULAR --
BECAUSE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
ICE POLICE ENTANGLEMENT.
AGAIN CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN THE
LEAD INTO AND PASSING
LEGISLATION LIKE THE TRUCKS DOT
THE TO THAT AND THE SANCTION AND
THE CALIFORNIA VALUES ACT S. B..
FIFTY FOUR THESE ARE ALL
CRITICAL BUT IT IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AS ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES MENTIONED EARLIER.
THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE FROM THE TOP
DOWN TALKING ABOUT THESE
POLICIES AND IT IN A WAY THAT.
INSURERS TRUST FROM COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WE HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OUT THERE VOCALLY SAYING THAT
THEY ARE AGAINST SANCTUARY
POLICIES AGAINST SB.
FIFTY FOUR THAT SPREADS WIDE AND
DEEP INTO OUR COMMUNITIES IN
TERMS OF ENHANCING THAT FEAR.
OF FROM THE CALLING THE POLICE
THE ONLY WAY THAT A LOT OF OF
OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS CAN GET
SOME ASSISTANCE IS BY.
CALLING THE POLICE BUT KNOWING
THAT LEADERSHIP IS --
YOU.
IS NOT WORKING TO BUILD TRUST
WITH THESE COMMUNITIES REALLY
MAKES THOSE PHONE CALLS REALLY
DIFFICULT TO MAKE IT SPECIAL
WHEN YOU HAVE.
SOMEONE WHO'S UNDOCUMENTED OR
FAMILY MEMBERS OF THE THAT IS
UNDOCUMENTED.
SO REALLY LOOKING AT THOSE
POLICIES --
TO ENSURE THAT ICE AND POLICE
ENTANGLEMENT --
DOES NOT CONTINUE THAT WE KEEP
--
ICE AND POLICE COLLABORATIONS.
THAT WE CONTINUE TO HOLD --
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT LEADERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR UPHOLDING THE
LAWS THAT THE STATE HAS PASSED I
THINK THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WE
REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT AND THAT
ALSO STRIKES WITH --
THE TOP DOWN FROM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL DEFINITELY --
ONE EVERY OTHER WAY HOW
IMPORTANT IS FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO PROVIDE I'M REALLY --
AND MEANINGFUL GUIDANCE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO THAT --
SOME OF THESE --
POLICIES CAN PERMEATE OUR
COMMUNITIES MUCH BATTER AND SO
FEET SO THAT INDIVIDUALS CAN
FEEL SAFER COMING FORWARD AND
REPORTING THESE CRIMES --
I ALSO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
AS MENTIONED EARLIER THAT WE DO
PROVIDE PROTECTIONS TO ALL CRIME
VICTIMS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS --
YOU KNOW I OUR ORGANIZATION GETS
CALLS FROM FOLKS ALL THE TIME
ABOUT HATE CRIMES --
WE HAVE SOMEONE TO FOR EXAMPLE
HAS BEEN --
THREATENED AND HARASSED BY THEIR
NEED -- FOR
THAT THEY WOULD THINK THEY WOULD
CALL RICE ON ON THIS PARTICULAR
FAMILY NOW THIS FAMILIES LOOKING
FOR A PLACE TO LIVE THERE TOO
AFRAID TO REPORT THIS INCIDENT.
TO THEIR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THEY REALLY DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER RECOURSE OR ABILITY TO
SORT OF YOU KNOW SPEAK OUT ABOUT
THIS INCIDENT OTHER THAN COMING.
FORWARD TO A COMMUNITY BASED ON
THE COMPONENT OBVIOUSLY IS
LANGUAGE ACCESS --
LATINOS ARE NOT A HOMOGENEOUS
AND IN THE FACT THAT WE DON'T
ALL SPEAK SPANISH A LOT OF US
ARE INDIGENOUS --
THE STORIES THAT I HAVE ACTUALLY
COME FROM SOME INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITIES WHERE FOLKS SPEAK ME
SPECKLE --
AT THE END AND OTHER INDIGENOUS
LANGUAGES ON THE INABILITY FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO CALL
APPROPRIATE INTERPRETERS WHEN
VICTIMS TO COME FORWARD HIT IS
STILL AN ISSUE IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE --
AND IT'S EVEN UP BROUGHT BIGGER
ISSUE FOR THESE INDIGENOUS
LANGUAGES --
WHERE THERE SEEMS TO BE NO
SUPPORT FOR COMMUNITY MEMBERS --
THAT COME FROM THE EAST.
CAN BE IS --
THEY COME FROM THESE LANGUAGE
MINORITIES AS WELL AND SO WE
REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT THE
PROVISION OF LANGUAGE ACCESS
SERVICES AND MAKE IT TIMELY IN
MAKING.
AND REAL TIME SO THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT COULD FULLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THESE FOLKS ARE
FACING ON THE GROUND --
AND THEN --
LASTLY I I JUST WANNA CAN
CONTINUE --
BY SAYING THAT I I DO THINK
CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD ON THIS WE
CAN CONTINUE TO LEAD ON POLICIES
WHERE.
WE DO BILL THAT WERE LAW
ENFORCEMENT DOES TAKE IT THE
LEADERSHIP AND BUILD.
UP BILLS THAT TRUST WITH GOT
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES SO THE
DEMOCRATS CAN FEEL SAFE AND
INCOME FORWARD --
AND I DID ONE HIGHLIGHT THE MOST
RECENT ANECDOTES OF HE CLAIMS
THAT OUR COMMUNITY --
I'LL JUST GIVE YOU ONE THE MOST
RECENT ONE THAT --
HAS BEEN MAKING THE WAYS AND IN
MEDIA HAS BEEN.
THE INCIDENT THAT OCCURRED ON
JULY FOURTH THERE WAS A ELDERLY
GENTLEMEN WALKING DOWN THE
STREET AND HE WAS ACCUSED OF OF
BUMPING INTO.
A LITTLE FOR ALL --
THE MOTHER OF THIS YOUNG GIRL.
HE REALLY GAVE ME AND STARTED
YELLING HUNTING AND TELLING HIM
TO GO BACK COUNTRY.
SHE ASSAULTED HIM WITH THE BREAK
UP OTHER A COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WANTED TO JUMP IN AND HELP BUT
THEY WERE ALSO THREATENED BY
THIS WOMAN.
IF YOU STEP IF YOU TAKE ONE STEP
CLOSER.
BEGIN ALL DO THE SAME HARM TO
YOU AND SO --
EITHER THESE ARE INCIDENTS THAT
ARE VERY REAL THERE ARE YOU KNOW
I'LL.
AFFECTING FOLKS IN THAT
INTERSECTIONAL NOT MANNER THAT
WE TALKED ABOUT IMMIGRATION
STATUS GRACE. EIGHT SHOULD
DISABILITY --
AND SO WE REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT
WAYS TO ENSURE THAT.
I FEEL WHEN VICTIMS [inaudible]
PLEASE TO COURT THIS IN A WAY
THAT IS SAFE.
AND THAT --
REALLY HONORS.
WHAT THE INCIDENT --
MEANS TO THEM AND HOW IT HAS
IMPACTED THEM BECAUSE IT'S IT'S
SO IMPORTANT THAT WE LOOK AT ALL
FACETS.
OF THE STORIES ARE NOT JUST LOOK
AT THEM SO ONE DIMENSIONAL SO
THAT WE DO UNDERSTAND SORT OF
THE ROOT CAUSES OF HATE CRIMES
WE COULD POTENTIALLY.
WORK TOWARDS A MEDICATING IT
HERE FOR THE CIVIC CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LORENA.
ANNOUNCE YOUR NAME AGAIN.
IS THEN NITPICKING FUNNY BUT THE
THEN YOU'RE PUTTING IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH INDEED FOR THE L. BY
LAST BUT NONE OF THESE WILL HAVE
FUN THIS YEAR VOEPEL.
PROFITS ISRAEL WAS ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF HIGH ANTI DEFAMATION
LEAGUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND MY APOLOGIES TO THE EXTENT
THAT I MAY AT TIMES HAVE MY BACK
TO ALL OR SOME OF THE WHO.
SO -- AT
AGAIN THANK YOU TO A ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIU AND WORD SUCI FOR
CONVENING THIS HEARING OF FOR A
PUSHING FOR THIS AUDIT TO TAKE
PLACE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
UP BECAUSE IT'S AYE YIELDED
TODAY'S EVENT THIS DISCUSSION
AND HOPEFULLY A LOT OF POSITIVE
OF WORK BY.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES I MEAN
[inaudible]
BECAUSE SINCE NINETEEN THIRTEEN
THE MISSION OF THE ANTI
DEFAMATION LEAGUE HAS BEEN TO
STOP THE DEFAMATION OF THE
JEWISH PEOPLE AND SECURE JUSTICE
AND FAIR TREATMENT FOR ALL.
WE'RE DEDICATED TO COMBATING
ANTISEMITISM PREJUDICE AND
BIGOTRY OF ALL KINDS AS WELL
DEPENDING DE DEMOCRATIC IDEALS
IN PROMOTING CIVIL RIGHTS.
THE FBI TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
HATE CRIME REPORT IS THE MOST
RECENT FEDERAL HATE CRIME REPORT
THAT WE HAVE.
THAT REPORT DOCUMENTED ONE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THREE RELIGIOUS UP BASED
RELIGION BASED HATE CRIMES WHICH
COMPRISED OVER 20% OF THE TOTAL.
ANTI SEMITIC HATE CRIMES
REPRESENTED ABOUT 53% OF THOSE
HATE CRIMES THAT WAS A SLIGHT
INCREASE FROM UP FROM THE YEAR
BEFORE.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY ANTI
JEWISH HATE CRIMES HAVE
ACCOUNTED FOR ANYWHERE FROM
5285% OF THE TOTAL OF RELIGIOUS
BASED HATE CRIMES ACROSS THE U.
S..
WHICH IS AN ESPECIALLY
DISTURBING STATISTIC WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THAT JEWS COMPRISE LESS
THAN 3% OF THE U. S. POPULATION.
THIS AS SORT OF TRENDS IN
NUMBERS IS ALSO REFLECTED IN
CALIFORNIA STATISTICS.
WE JUST SAW THE RELEASE OF THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN HATE CRIME
REPORT FOR CALIFORNIA.
THERE WERE A TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVEN OF RELIGION BASED TAKE
CRIME EVENTS AND CALIFORNIA.
AND FULLY HALF OF THOSE ONE
HUNDRED AND FOUR WERE ALSO ANTI
SEMITIC.
AND THE EYES I KNOW THAT THIS IS
A AN INCREASE FROM A TWO HUNDRED
SIXTEEN EXCUSE ME TWENTY SIXTEEN
WHEN THERE WERE --
EIGHTY TWO SUCH EVENTS.
AND IF YOU GO BACK IN PRIOR
YEARS AND CALIFORNIA YOU'LL ALSO
SEE THAT ANTI SEMITIC I HATE
CRIMES MAKE UP OF THE BULK OF
THE RELIGION BASED --
HATE CRIMES.
SO AND THAT'S A IT'S IT'S IT'S
NEVER SURPRISING WHEN WE SEE
THOSE NUMBERS UNFORTUNATELY YEAR
AFTER YEAR. EIGHTY EL --
HAS ALSO BEEN KEEPING TRACK OF
WHAT WE TERM ANTI SEMITIC
INCIDENTS --
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE WE
HAVE COMPILED AN ANNUAL AUDIT OF
ANTI SEMITIC INCIDENTS THAT
INCLUDE BOTH CRIMINAL AND NOT I
MIDDLE INCIDENTS.
OF OF ANTISEMITISM SO HARASSMENT
BULLYING --
THINGS THAT WOULD BE.
IT TO USE THE TERMINOLOGY HERE
HATE INCIDENTS OR ACTUAL HATE
CRIMES.
AND WE KNOW THAT FOR EVERY ACT
OF HATE TO BE IT AND AN INCIDENT
--
BE IT BEATIN ACTUAL HATE CRIME
AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT OF MY A
FELLOW PANELISTS AND AND OTHER
SPEAKERS THERE ARE MULTIPLE
OTHER --
JEWS JEWISH FAMILIES JEWISH
COMMUNITIES WHO FEEL THE IMPACT
I'M OF THAT ACT OF HATE AND THAT
MESSAGE OF EXCLUSION THAT SENT
WE TALK ABOUT HATE CRIMES AS
MESSAGE CRIMES.
I'M A LOT OF THE CRIMES THAT
WARNER REPORT THIS YEAR OR YEAH
YOU COULD ARGUE RELATIVELY LOW
LEVEL CRIMES HE NO SIMPLE
ASSAULTS VANDALISM THAT SORT OF
THING BUT THEY MAKE THE TV NEWS.
AND HERE WE ARE TODAY.
AND IT'S BECAUSE THOSE ARE --
THEY SEND A MESSAGE OF TERROR
AND EXCLUSION TO THOUGH THAT
ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
SO IF I SQUALL A SWASTIKA ON THE
SYNAGOGUE VERSES SOMEBODY
SQUALLS NANCY WAS HERE ON THE
SYNAGOGUE.
I AT THAT ROUTE IT'S IT'S
VANDALISM AT THE SAME PAINT ON
THE SIDE OF THE SYNAGOGUE BUT
ONE IS AN ANNOYANCE AND THEN THE
OTHER SENDS AND A COMPLETE
MESSAGE OF TERROR TO TO THAT
WHOLE COMMUNITY.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE FEEL.
AND SO --
HISTORICALLY --
IN THIS COUNTRY AND OTHER
COUNTRIES OVER CENTURIES A ANTI
SEMITISM HAS OFTEN BEEN THE
CANARY IN THE COAL MINE.
I ANTI JEWISH HATE FREQUENTLY
PRESENT IS AS PRESAGES.
ARISE AND OTHER FORMS OF BIGOTRY
AND THREATENS TO UNDERMINE
DEMOCRATIC IDEALS IN COMMUNITIES
AND SERVES AS AN INDICATOR OF
HEALTH OF THE SOCIETY AS A
WHOLE.
SO WE WE COMPILE THIS AUDIT --
USING INFORMATION PROVIDED BY
VICTIMS ON FORCE MEANT --
MEDIA REPORTS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS WE EVALUATE THEM TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE ARE
BELIEVABLE.
UP SIMILAR TO THE HATE CRIME
REPORT THAT REALLY THAT THEY
PROVIDE JUSTICE SHOT OF THE
STATE OF ANTI SEMITISM IN THE
COUNTRY BECAUSE IT WE IT IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY A COMPREHENSIVE.
BUT DATA DRIVE POLICY AND ONLY
THREE YEARS INTO THE DOING THOSE
--
THOSE AUDITS UP MY PROFESSIONAL
FOREBEARS ACTUALLY DRAFTED MODEL
HATE CRIMES STATUTE A IN THE
EARLY NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND
BEGAN SHOPPING IT AROUND TO
VARIOUS STATE LEGISLATURES.
AND LIVE MAY HERCULEAN EFFORTS
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THAT
FINALLY RESULTED IN THE IN THE
SHEPHERD BIRD ACT I IN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE SO I'M ANTI
SEMITISM I IS IT CAN SOMETIMES
BE A LITTLE BIT OF A MOVING
TARGET BUT IT.
YOU EDIT IT INVOLVES AYE AT ITS
ROOT -- AND
IT REALLY A LARGER DISCUSSION IS
FOR ANOTHER DAY BUT A FORM OF
HATRED OR MISS TRUSTS ARE
CONTEMPT FOR INDIVIDUAL JEWS --
JEWISH GROUPS THAT JEWISH
COLLECTIVE USUALLY --
FOCUSED AROUND --
CONSPIRACY THEORIES OF SOME SORT
--
IN YOU KNOW ABOUT --
JEWS INDIVIDUALLY OR AS A
COLLECT [inaudible]
THAT IS I EXERCISE FOR THEIR OWN
PERSONAL.
GAIN [inaudible]
I THE AUDIT --
AND SO THAT'S YOU GOOD
APPROXIMATELY THE DEFINITION
THAT THAT WE USE THE AUDIT DATA
--
THAT WE TALLIED FOR A NEW TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SHOWS AN INCREASE OF
57% NATIONWIDE --
OVER TWENTY SIXTEEN INCLUDING
PHYSICAL ASSAULTS VANDALISM
ETCETERA.
CALIFORNIA HAD --
IT SO THERE ISN'T ONE THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX
INCIDENTS TOTAL CALIFORNIA WE
RECORDED TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
EIGHT INCIDENTS TOTAL SECOND
ONLY A BEHIND NEW YORK STATE
[inaudible]
I'M FORTUNATELY --
WE DID NOT UP THE ONLY CATEGORY
--
WHERE I INCIDENTS WHAT DOWN WAS
AN ACTUAL PHYSICAL ASSAULT --
WE RECORDED SIX AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN ZERO IN IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SOME EXAMPLES
UP FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
A LOTS OF OF VANDALISM OF
SYNAGOGUES UNFORTUNATELY XILED
THE STANDING FOR ZIONIST
OCCUPIED GOVERNMENT THREATENING
GRAFFITI ON THE SYNAGOGUE --
F. YOU I'M DON'T USE THE WORDS
--
JEWISH* --
ON THE AND I GOT --
SMASHED WINDOWS --
OF THAT SORT OF THING ON SEVERAL
OTHERS.
WE'VE HAD --
THREATS AND HARASSMENT JUST THIS
PAST APRIL IN IRVINE MAN WAS
CHARGED WITH FELONY I HATE CRIME
FOR MAKING A CRIMINAL THREATS --
AGAINST JEWS AYE IN HIS
COMMUNITY --
UP WITH HAVING AN ALLEGED KILL
LIST AND A LIST OF STEPS FOR
POPE KILLING MY FIRST JEW --
THIS NEXT INCIDENT HAPPENS UP
FREQUENTLY AND I BELIEVE HAPPENS
FREQUENTLY TO PEOPLE ANOTHER --
COMMUNITIES A MAN IN A CAR TOM
DIDN'T ORTHODOX JEW WHILE HE WAS
WALKING HOME FROM SYNAGOGUE WITH
THINGS LIKE* SALUTES AND AND
OTHER TYPES OF UPSETS --
GENERALLY ANOTHER CERTAINLY OF
THE SORT OF AND THOSE I'M --
GENERALLY.
OF MY OTHER COLLEAGUES OFFICE IN
A LOS ANGELES WAS A TAD WITH NEO
* GRAFFITI.
A LAST YEAR --
IN -- AT A
HIGH SCHOOL --
IN ALAMEDA AND TWENTY PHOEBE I'M
ONE OF THE CLASSROOM DESKS
CHOOSE OUR EVIL SWASTIKAS*
FLAGS A STAR OF DAVID DRAWN NEXT
TO AN IMAGE OF A OF A BAD WITH
DOLLARS.
THE SAME STUDENTS HAVE --
WHO WHO WHO WHO DISCOVERED THE
CONFETTI HAD HERSELF BEEN --
PREVIOUSLY REPORTED BEING SENT
ANTI SEMITIC TEXT MESSAGES FROM
CLASSMATES --
WITH EPITHETS FOR JEWS --
PRAISES FOR ADOLF HITLER IT
SANTORUM.
WHICH BRINGS ME --
TO BULLYING AND THIS IS BEEN A
THEME --
THROUGHOUT --
CERTAINLY WILL BE YOU HAVE
[inaudible]
THAT A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
REPORTS THAT COME TO US OF
INAPPROPRIATE I'M NOT SEE --
AND HOLOCAUST ARE RELATED
COMMENTS LIKE THE BACK TO THE UP
AND THE BACK CONCENTRATION CAMPS
--
BEING MADE A TO A JEWISH
STUDENTS --
ADS --
MOSTLY IN THE MIDDLE --
FLYERS AT A HIGH SCHOOL SAYING
NO SHOES NO PROBLEM AND SOMEBODY
SAYING TO US STUDENT IN ALAMO WE
WILL SLAUGHTER YOUR JEWISH GOD
--
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE HERE TALKING
ABOUT HATE CRIME --
WE'VE HEARD A LOT TODAY A ABOUT
--
AND I WAS ABOUT TO TALK ABOUT IT
BUT I WAS REMINDED OF THIS YOU
KNOW NON A CRIMINAL I'M
INCIDENTS OF HATE.
ABOUT OF A RISE IN JUST IN
GENERAL FEELINGS --
ABOUT --
MORE AYE AT A TIME IN OUR
COUNTRY WHEN --
MAY BE HATE OF MANY SORTS --
IS FEELING NORMAL AND IT REMINDS
ME OF A LEARNING MODULE THAT WE
HAVE THAT WE DEVELOPED AFTER
HOLOCAUST EDUCATION ACTUALLY BUT
WE USE IN A VARIETY OF CONTEXTS
CALLED THE PYRAMID OF HATE --
pAND YOU TALK ABOUT --
THE VERY BOTTOM OF THE PYRAMID
WHERE REALLY ALL OF US HAVE BEEN
--
AT SOME POINTS --
BEING -- THE
BASE OF THE HIDING IT
STRENGTHENED THAT'S PEOPLE'S
JUST BIASED ATTITUDES YOU KNOW
--
ATTITUDES THAT NEO JUDGMENTS
THAT YOU A FORM --
IN THE COURSE OF YOUR LIFE ABOUT
OTHERS OFTEN UNCONSCIOUSLY.
AND IF YOU DON'T AT SOME POINT
CHECK A BIASES AT THAT LEVEL --
WHETHER YOUR IT'S IN SCHOOL IN
THE WORKPLACE OR YOUR YOUR
FRIENDS.
CHECK YOU'RE YOU HAVE MOMENT OF
ENLIGHTENMENT YOU KNOW MAYBE YOU
YOU MOVE UP THE PYRAMID.
AND MAYBE --
YOU KNOW YOU DON'T WANT TO SIT
WITH CERTAIN PEOPLE AT THE LUNCH
TABLE.
YOU KNOW USE YOU DON'T INVITE
THEM TO YOUR PARTIES YOU KNOW
THAT SORT OF THING IT'S MORE
SOCIAL EXCLUSION YOU'RE MORE
OPEN WITH THE SORT OF SO CALLED
JOKES THAT YOU'RE WILLING TO
TELL.
I'M AND WILLING TO LAUGH AT I'M
IF YOU'RE NOT EVEN CHECKED AT
THAT LEVEL AND THEN YOU RISE UP
--
EVEN FURTHER AND YOU REALLY MORE
HARASSING PEOPLE --
BE IT IN THE SCHOOL CONTEXT AND
IT'S BULLYING.
A A WORKPLACE CONTEXT AND IT
WHERE LEGAL LIABILITY --
MAY ATTACH SUDDENLY OR NOT RUN
[inaudible] TO SOME.
YOU KNOW YOU PURSUE IT'S
DIFFERENT TO YOU --
DEVOUT DENYING THEM A JOB
ETCETERA.
AND THEN YOU MOVE UP FURTHER
FROM THERE IF YOU'RE STILL NOT
CHECKED AND THAT'S WHERE YOU GET
INTO HATE CRIMES LOW LEVEL HATE
CRIMES MORE VIOLENT HATE CRIMES
AND ULTIMATELY OF COURSE THE
VERY TOP OF THE PYRAMID
CONSIDERING A WE DEVELOP THIS IN
THE HOLOCAUST EDUCATION IS
GENOCIDE.
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S THAT WOULD BE
THE VERY TOP.
AND THE IDEA IS THAT IT ALL
STARTS AT THE BOTTOM WITH THESE
WORDS.
BUT THESE BIASED ATTITUDES THAT
GO UNCHECKED.
AND YOU KNOW THAT'S WHY WHEN YOU
SEE THESE BULLYING INCIDENTS
HE'S A RELATIVELY LOW LYING
INCIDENTS IT IT IT IT.
IT.
I I THINK FOR ALL OF US IT GIVES
US A SWELLING OF OKAY YOU KNOW
THIS IS OUR IF WE DON'T STOP IT
IS IT'S IT'S GOING TO ESCALATE
--
THIS IS NOW I'M A TIME WHEN.
YOU KNOW IF THE THESE PEOPLE WHO
ARE.
THE PERSON WHO COMMITS THE HATE
CRIME AT A HIGHER LEVEL IN THE
PYRAMID FEELS THE SUPPORT.
THINKS THAT PERSON HAS SUPPORT
AT THE LOWER END OF DISAPPEAR UP
OF OF THE PYRAMID NOT TO COME.
PLEASE LEAP KEEP TORTURING THIS
--
THIS METAPHOR BUT IT REALLY
REMINDS ME OF THAT AND I THINK
THAT'S WHY I'M A WE TALK ABOUT
THEN OF THE MESSAGE OF HATE.
I'VE THAT BULLYING SENDS THAT I
THAT -- THAT
HATE CRIMES AND WHAT YOU KNOW
WHERE LEADERSHIP THAT WE NEED TO
SEE FROM THE LEGISLATURE FROM
THE A. G. FROM OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES --
AND EVEN FOR WHAT MIGHT BE
PERCEIVED AS A RELATIVELY LOW
LEVEL CRIME OR LOW OR AN ACTIVE
YOU'LL SPRAY PAINT VANDALISM OR
SOMETHING THAT'S RELATIVELY LOW
LEVEL AND THAT'S BECAUSE THE
PERPETRATOR NEEDS TO BE TOLD
THIS IS NOT OKAY THE PERPETRATOR
SENTIMENTS SUCH A PAID AN
EXCLUSION.
THAT PERPETRATOR NEEDS TO BE
TOLD THAT IS NOT OKAY HERE.
AND WE WILL STOP YOU FROM FROM
GOING ANY FURTHER --
WITH SANCTIONS WITH WITH
CONDEMNATION AT CETERA --
I I THINK THAT'S AND SO I THINK
I THINK THAT'S PART OF WHAT THE
MESSAGING HOUSE TO BE --
AS AND THAT THAT'S A I DON'T
SPEAK FOR PEOPLE BUT THAT'S BUT
THAT'S WHAT I'M HEARING --
IN THE IN THE VARIOUS CALLS FOR
LEADERSHIP AND HOW IT STARTS AT
THE TOP DOWN AND COMMUNITIES
NEED TO HEAR THAT.
TO BECAUSE IF THEY DON'T HEAR IT
ALSO IN RESPONSE TO THE SO
CALLED HATE INCIDENT WHERE --
IT'S IT'S A IT'S A NON CRIMINAL
ACT IS A VIOLATION OF PENAL CODE
MADE ITS FIRST FIRST AMENDMENT
ACT BUT NONE THE LESS OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF BLACK
LAW ENFORCEMENT --
OFFICERS IV AND THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
CHIEFS OF POLICE OF ALL
DOCUMENTED THAT OF A COMMUNITIES
WILL BE LESS LIKELY TO HAVE
FAITH IN LAW ENFORCEMENT OR TO
COME FORWARD --
AND REPORT ACTUAL HATE CRIME IF
THEY THINK THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
DON'T DON'T CARE ABOUT THE FEES
EVEN NON CRIMINAL INCIDENTS ON
THIS IS PARTICULARLY TRUE.
ON UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES WHERE
SORT OF INCIDENTS HAPPENINGS YAO
WHITE SUPREMACIST FIRING NOW
UNFORTUNATELY WHICH WE'VE
DOCUMENT IT.
SO I. I DIVERGE SLIGHTLY BUT I
WANTED JUST --
QUICKLY I JUST GET BACK --
TO I GUESS --
SOME OF MY NOTES I YOU KNOW
WE'RE COMING UP ON THE
ANNIVERSARY OF CHARLOTTESVILLE.
AND IT WAS --
IT IT WAS JUST --
I THINK A PUNCH IN THE GUT FOR
ALL OF US AND SO --
PEOPLE ARE WHO FELT THE RACISM
PEOPLE WHO FELT THE ANTI
SEMITISM I KNOW I YOU KNOW.
WHAT WHAT WATCHING FOOTAGE OF
THOSE MARCHERS CHANTING JEWS
WILL NOT REPLACE US YOU KNOW AS
THEY MARCH BY A SYNAGOGUE ARE
CONDUCTING SHABBAT SERVICE WAS
WAS WAS JUST CHILLING --
SO WE'RE COMING UP ON THAT IT IS
AN OPPORTUNITY UMD HAS FOR ALL
OF US AT EVERY LEVEL ARE TO SEND
AND ANOTHER MESSAGE OF OF
REJECTION OF OF THAT HATE --
OF COURSE YOU KNOW I SIMPLY.
YOU KNOW THE CHARLOTTESVILLE WAS
AN EXTREME RIGHT WING EVENTS --
BUT THAT'S NOT TO SAY ANYBODY IS
IMMUNE --
FROM A YOUTH FOR IF HATE --
SO I WOULD I WOULD ONLY SAY --
THAT AYE AYE WHEN WE ALL NEED
AND FRANKLY THE TECH OR BIAS
HE'S CONSTANTLY BUT WE CAN'T AYE
IN GENERAL A LEGISLATOR TABULATE
OR ARREST OUR WAY A TO A
HEALTHIER --
SOCIETY WE NEED THAT THAT SORT
OF LEADERSHIP THAT EVERYBODY
HERE HAS COMMENTED ON POST AB
DOES A TREMENDOUS JOB CONSTANTLY
--
OR REGULARLY UPDATING AYE IT'S
MATERIALS GETTING IT OUT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH POST AGAIN --
TO DO THAT WE ARE PROVIDING A
WE'RE POST CERTIFIED TO PROVIDE
A CRIME TRAININGS FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT --
WE ADD THE WHAT THE ONE
ADDITIONAL --
THE SUGGESTION I WOULD MAKE TO
THE MANY FINE SUGGESTIONS IT
ALREADY BEEN MADE.
IS THAT --
TO THE EXTENT THAT AGENCIES --
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES MAY.
BE LOATH TO DO TRAINING --
ALL BURDEN ON THEM WE DON'T
CHARGE FOR THE TRAINING BUT THAT
YOU KNOW MAYBE THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES --
EITHER AS AN INCENTIVE OR TWO
I'M TO COVER COSTS OF FOR THE
TRAINING WE'VE ALREADY TALKED
ABOUT -- YOU
KNOW MAYBE A PENALTIES OF OF THE
OR CONSEQUENCES FOR FAILURE TO
REPORT MAYBE INCENTIVES ALSO TO
REPORT.
I'M SO I GUESS I WILL --
LEAVE IT THERE.
AND HAPPY.
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ALONG
WITH --
EVERYBODY WHO SPOKE HERE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
TURN IT OFF THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND YOUR FEEDBACK
AND TO OUR RECOMMENDATION.
ARE ESPECIALLY VALUABLE ASK YOU
UNDERSTAND.
CLEARLY WHAT --
YOU'RE COMING NEED HE NEEDS.
ESPECIALLY YOU TOUCH THOSE OF US
APOLLO -- TO
AREA THAT WE HAVE NOT COVERED IN
AND EARNED AND THIS AUDIT WHICH
IS DUE TO THE PREVENTION.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE ABOUT OF THE
CRIME PREVENTION THE BULLY IN
AND THE EDUCATION OF OF DE
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN IN IN THE
SCHOOL.
AND I WILL BE HOA HOSTING ON AND
HATE CRIME --
WITH HOUSTON SCHOOL IN OCTOBER
I'VE I AND I WILL CONTINUE
ADVOCATE MORE THROUGH THE THE
RESOURCES FOR MENTAL HEALTH LE.
A SERVICES A MANTLE'S THAT
MENTAL HEALTH --
O. O. COUNSELING AND AND IN THE
SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT SO --
WAS STRAPPED --
MURATSUCHI.
WELL YES THANK YOU I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR COMING OUT
TODAY IT'S TESTIFYING I ONE
ASSURE YOU THAT I HEARD EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU LOUD AND CLEAR
--
WE TALKED ABOUT LEADERSHIP AND
THAT NEED FOR ALL OF US TO STEP
UP I WILL STEP UP I WILL COMMIT
--
TO EXPLORING HATE CRIMES
LEGISLATION FURTHER HATE CRIME
ACTION FOR FOR NEXT LAWS THAT
HAVE YEAR I LOOK FOR TO WORKING
WITH ALL OF YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH [inaudible]
OR THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE ALSO
ON THE THANK YOU --
TO A SIGN LANGUAGE INTERPRETER
WHO ALREADY LEFT THE ROOM BUT
INTO.
WHO FEW RUNNING TO HER IT ON THE
HALLWAY PIZZA EXPRESS MY?
THE SIX ZERO WHO LIVE A
GRATITUDE FULFILL HER THEIR WORK
AS THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I CONCLUDE THE HEARING.
THE STUFF JUST REMINDED ME OF
FAIR ANY PUBLIC THAT WANT TO
MAKE A SHORT COMMENT.
WHAT WERE RUNNING TWENTY FIVE
MINUTES LATE?
ANY PUBLIC WHILE SHARING A
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANKS CLIFFORD
HERE WE HAVE THE JEWS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE.
OF J. PACK.
JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
REPRESENTS THE MOST MAJOR
ORGANIZED JEWISH ORGANIZATIONS
IN CALIFORNIA INCLUDING AID YET
EIGHTY EL AJC JEWS COMMUNITY
RELATIONS COUNCIL JEWISH
FEDERATIONS.
WE WANT TO THANK YOU AND THE
AUDIT COMMITTEE YOUR SELECT
COMMITTEE FEAR WORKING
LEADERSHIP ON THIS --
IMPORTANT ISSUE HATE CRIMES HAVE
BEEN IMPORTANT ISSUE VERGE A
PACK OVER THE YEARS AS WAS SAID
EARLIER THERE HAS BEEN A RISING
TIDE OF ANTI SEMITISM.
AROUND THE WORLD THE COUNTRY AND
IN CALIFORNIA HAS NOT BEEN
IMMUNE TO IT AS WE SEE AN
INCREASE IN HATE CRIMES AGAINST
THE JEWS COMMUNITY.
IN CALIFORNIA PARTICULAR CONCERN
COLLEGE CAMPUSES ANNA CAMP
CAMPUSES IN HIGHER EDUCATION AS
BEING A PLACE WHERE JEWS
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
ARE OFTEN FEEL BOTH UNSAFE AND
ON WHAT.
KING WITH YOU ON MANY OF THESE
CAME OUT TODAY --
PARTICULARLY AS WAS SAID
REPORTING BUT ALSO PREVENTION
AND PUTTING RESOURCES INTO
PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITIES WHERE
THEY BE JEWISH.
I LGBT MOSLEM ARE HISPANIC ALL
OF THOSE COMMUNITIES ARE TARGETS
AND WE NEED TO DO MORE --
TO IN ESSENCE BOTH PREVENT.
AND TO STOP HATE CRIMES THANK
YOU* CHRIS BOWED YORK.
THAT AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I APPRECIATE
YOU STAYING LATE.
MY NAME IS RUSSELL RAWLINGS I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF ADVOCACY
SERVICES AT RESOURCES FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING WE ARE AN
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTER
SERVING PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES IN SACRAMENTO AND
YELLOW COUNTY.
I ALSO AM A SURVIVOR OF VIEWS
AND HAVE WITNESSED LA BOTH
LEVELS OF THE PYRAMID THAT YOU
JUST VERY THAT WAS SPOKE OUT OF
AND CHAIR I JUST REALLY WANT TO
COMMEND YOU --
FOR BRINGING UP HOMELESS STATUS
EVERY DAY IT RESOURCES FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING WE SEE
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS MANY OF
WHOM WHO HAVE EXPAND WHO HAVE --
INTO WORDS SOME FORM OF HATE OR
ABUSE BY THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE
SO I JUST REALLY ENCOURAGE.
YOU TO DIVE DEEP INTO THIS CAR
APPROACHING THIS FROM AN
INTERSECTIONAL.
APPROACH MAKING SURE THAT EVERY
VOICE THAT YOU'VE JUST HEARD IN
THIS ROOM.
IS A PART OF THE CONVERSATION.
TO THAT END I WOULD ALSO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO ENGAGE THE
STATE INDEPENDENT LIVING COUNCIL
HAS IN ADDITION TO THE DB
COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE JUST AS THE VOICES THAT
YOU'VE HEARD AND HAVE A VARIETY
OF EXPERIENCE IN AND OF
SECTIONALISM.
SO TOO DOES OUR COMMUNITY THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY.
SO I JUST REALLY WANTED
ENCOURAGE THAT THOSE VOICES ARE
PRESENT IN THIS CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU THINK CARUSO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AND
BOY I'M A FAMILY MEMBER AND A
FAMILY ADVOCATE FOR MY BROTHER
MARTIN LOUIS.
WHO IS A NONVERBAL AUTISTIC --
ADULT.
AND HE HAD SUFFERED TRAUMATIC
BRAIN INJURY AND I'M HERE ON HIS
BEHALF.
TO PLEAD TO THE COMMITTEE TO
PLEASE I'M REVIEW.
OF WHAT'S GOING ON WITHIN THE
CONSIDER SHIP MATTERS OF ADULTS
WHO ARE NON VERBAL AND I CANNOT
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES THEIR
RIGHTS ARE STRIPPED AWAY.
FROM FAMILY AND AND FROM.
AND BECAUSE I STILL TRAVEL TO
MEET WITH HIM NONE SO I AM VERY
EMOTIONAL BUT I'M STILL FIGHTING
FOR HIS RIGHTS AND TO BE BACK
HOME WITH FAMILY.
AND CONSORTIUM MATTERS HAD
REALLY ON TOOK THIS SITUATION TO
A LEVEL WHERE.
THEY WOULD STRIP AWAY FAMILY
RIGHTS TO ADVOCATE FOR MY
BROTHER AND I HAVE TO TRAVEL
OVER A HUNDRED MILES JUST TO SEE
HIM FOR TWENTY MINUTES
[inaudible]
EVERY WEEK.
AND WHEN MY MOM HAD PASSED AWAY
THAT AND I HAVE TO GO TO COURT
TO SEEK [inaudible]
I'M.
HIS RIGHT TO PAY RESPECTS TO HIS
MOTHER WHO HAD TOOK CARE OF HIM
FOR OVER THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF
HIS LIFE.
SO I BEG YOU TO PLEASE.
LOOK INTO THE TRAINING AND THE
COMMITMENT OF CRIMES BECAUSE WE
ARE.
I'M STILL FIGHTING THE FIGHT
AGAINST HATE CRIMES AGAINST
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WHO
CANNOT SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU THANK YOU THINK YOU
WOULD DO SECURE MISS BUSH FOR
SHARING YOUR PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
WITH US.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JANELLE LEWIS I SERVE ON
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WHERE
CHAIR THE LEGISLATIVE AND PUBLIC
POLICY COMMITTEE.
AND THE STATE COUNCILS
ESTABLISHED BY STATE AND FEDERAL
LAW AS AN INDEPENDENT STATE
AGENCY TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AND THEIR FAMILIES RECEIVE
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
THEY NEED WE DID THAT WE DO THIS
THROUGH OUR WORK AND SYSTEMIC
ADVOCACY EDUCATIONAL CAPACITY
BUILDING.
INCLUSION AND PUBLIC SAFETY ARE
AMONG OUR PRIORITIES --
I WANT TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BRINGING ATTENTION --
TO HATE CRIMES IN THIS STATE AND
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE
MISIDENTIFIED UNDER REPORTED AND
NOT PROSECUTED.
INVOLVED MARGINALIZED IN
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS SUCH AS
THE INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL.
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
COMMUNITIES.
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AND THEIR FAMILIES --
MUST BE SECURE THAT THEY WILL BE
BELIEVED RESPECTED AND HELPED
WHEN THEY REPORT BEING TARGETS
OF HATE CRIMES.
THIS INCLUDES EVERYWHERE IN THE
COMMUNITY.
INCLUDING IN OUR SCHOOLS AND
ACROSS THE LIFESPAN --
AS YOU HAVE JUST HEARD THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE VICTIMS OF HATE
CRIMES WHO DO NOT REALIZE THEY
ARE VICTIMS OF HATE CRIMES.
THEY NEED SUPPORT INCLUDING
SUPPORT FROM THEIR FAMILIES THAT
MUST BE ONTO HONORED.
PLEASE KNOW THAT THE STATE
COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES --
IS YOUR PARTNER IN BRINGING
ATTENTION AND CHANGE --
TO THE HORRIFIC HATE CRIMES
SITUATION IN OUR STATE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOSEPH VERY I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF MANY --
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS --
I FIRST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
ARE COMMAND YOU --
ON THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING I
REGARD HATE CRIMES.
TOWARD MARGINALIZED POPULATIONS
ESPECIALLY PERSONAL DISABILITY
OBVIOUSLY --
TWO THINGS I IMPLORE YOU TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU COMPREHENSIVELY
INCLUDE --
DISABILITY AS A CULTURAL
INDICATOR MARKER OF
IDENTIFICATION.
INDIA.
LEGISLATION AROUND HATE CRIMES.
AND THEN ALSO MOVED FORWARD --
COMPREHENSIVE LEE AND STATE
LEVEL LEGISLATION PERIOD --
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT --
DISABILITY AS AN INDICATOR OF
IDENTITY IS --
INCLUDED ESPECIALLY ITEM AS IT
--
INTERSECTS WITH OTHER
MARGINALIZED --
IDENTIFICATION CRITERIA HAS WAS
--
EXPRESSED EARLIER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND CLOSE
UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU I'M
GLAD YOU HELD THE PRIVATE AND
THE PUBLIC --
COMMENT SECTION A DISTRO FROM
OAKLAND TO REPRESENT THE QUARTER
MILLION SEEK AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR JED THE SAYING
I'M THE COFOUNDER OF THE SICK
AMERICAN LEGAL DEFENSE AND
EDUCATION FUND.
WHICH IS THE FIRST SICK AMERICAN
CIVIL RIGHTS ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION --
WE'RE CELEBRATING OUR TWENTY
SIXTH YEAR.
AND DEALING WITH EXISTS BEFORE
NINE ELEVEN WAYS THAT.
TWENTY FIVE SOMEWHERE ON THE SO
IBM'S SCHOLAR AND I'M IN THE
STORY AND AND I LOOK AT RACE IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
AND MY I PUBLISHED MY FIRST
ARTICLE ON HATE VIOLENCE AGAINST
SICK AMERICANS HISTORY TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AGO.
THE SUMMING UP ENGINE FOR A VERY
LONG TIME [inaudible]
AND SO.
WHAT I WANTED TO GIVE YOU I'M
HERE TO GIVE YOU MAY BE A
PICTURE OF A SICK COMMUNITIES
FEELING IN THE STATE AND HAS
BEEN FOR SEVERAL YEARS IF YOU
CAN BEAR WITH ME IT IS LIKE TO
REACH A PEACE?
THAT I WROTE SOMETIME BACK.
NOW MANY TAKE A NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND JUST LOOK AT
THAT SIX WEEK PERIOD MOSTLY JUST
DECEMBER OF TWENTY FIFTY OKAY SO
GOING BACK A FEW YEARS.
ON NOVEMBER SIX BELINDA GEET
SAYING A SICK AMERICAN BUS
DRIVER IN LOS ANGELES WAS
ATTACKED.
WELL DRIVING THE CITY BUS.
MY PASSENGER CALLED IN BOTH THE
TERRORIST AND A SUICIDE BOMBER.
HE ALSO ACCUSED THE SICK
AMERICAN MEN OF HIJACKING THE
BUS.
THE VICIOUS ATTACK LEFT MISTER
SAYING WITH THE SWOLLEN AND
BRUISED FACE AND JOHN INFECTION
[inaudible]
INSIDE.
NO ONE OF THE REASONS THIS
ATTACK IS REALLY IMPORTANT IS
BECAUSE DESPITE THE OBVIOUS
RACIAL RELIGIOUS BIAS EVIDENCE
IN THE ATTACK THE POLICE THE
POLICE INITIALLY RESISTED
CALLING IT.
A HATE CRIME.
THIS REPLICATES A PATTERN
REPEATED THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
WHEN WORKING CLASSIC AMERICANS
BECOME TARGETS OF HATE VIOLENCE?
IN CASE AFTER CASE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND SLOW OR EVEN
RESISTANT. TO RECOGNIZING THE
HATE BASED ORIGIN OF SUCH
ATTACKS.
IN NUMEROUS CASES ONLY PRESSURE
FROM SEEK ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS
AS FORCE LAW ENFORCEMENT FOUND
HATE CRIME CHARGES.
THIS HAS TO CHANGE.
ON ON DECEMBER SECOND VALERIE
COR A NATIONAL INTERFAITH LEADER
A FILMMAKER A LAWYER AND HAVE TO
SIMPLY BY STANFORD HAS TO BE
SOME STANFORD --
HARVARD AND YALE.
WAS ON A FLIGHT HOME FROM
MEETING OF INTERFAITH LEADERS
WHEN ANGLICAN FIVE BY WHITE MAN
AFTER FOR MOVED ATTACK FROM HER
ALREADY SCREEN TO CARRY ON BACK.
IN THE END THE SICK AMERICAN
MOTHER WAS FORCED TO REVEAL A
BREAST PUMP TO PROVE THAT SHE
WAS NOT A TERRORIST.
A WEEK LATER JOHNSON A SEVENTY
EIGHT YEAR OLD SICK AMERICAN MAN
WAS STRUCK ON THE TURBINE WITH
AN APPLE BY PASSING MOTORISTS
WELL PICKING HIS GRANDCHILD UP.
AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IN
BAKERSFIELD.
THE FRUIT WAS THROWN WITH SUCH
FORCE THAT IT SHATTERED UPON
HITTING THE MAN'S HEAD.
LEAVING THE OTHER WITH PAIN AND
DIZZINESS FOR DAYS NOW IF YOU
HAVE BEEN WEARING A TURBAN.
THE INTEREST OF IN MUCH WORSE IS
KIND OF MIRACULOUS. TWO DAYS
LATER AND I'M GONNA LEAVE THE
STATE ARE MONTHS SAYING TWELVE
YEARS OLD BORN AND RAISED IN
TEXAS WAS HANDCUFFED AND
SUSPENDED FROM SCHOOL AND SPENT
THREE DAYS IN A JUVENILE
FACILITY.
IN ARLINGTON TEXAS BECAUSE
ANOTHER STUDENT USE WITH HAVING
A BOMB HIS BACKPACK.
THE CHILD WAS UNDERGONE THREE
OPEN HEART SURGERIES
INCARCERATED AT HIS PARENTS
BEING INFORMED IS WHERE ABOUT
WHAT THE SCHOOL OR POLICE.
THE SICK WHEN SAYS HE'S INNOCENT
AND THE OPPOSITE EPISODE
RESULTED FROM ANOTHER STUDENT
FALSELY ACCUSING HIM.
BASICALLY FOR BOWLING.
THE INCIDENT GRAPHICALLY
ILLUSTRATES THE VULNERABILITY OF
SICK AMERICAN CHILDREN. TWO DAYS
AFTER THAT A SICK AMERICAN MEN
IN A IN A IN A STORE IN A STORE
IN GRAND RAPIDS MICHIGAN WE SHOT
IN THE FACE.
THE CELL WHO FIRST COLUMN A
TERRACE ALSO SAID HE USED TO
KILL PEOPLE I CAN IN IRAQ. TWO
DAYS LATER ROUNDING OUT A SH
WEEK OF SHOCKING RACISM HATE
AGAINST SICK AMERICANS SYMCOR
SANGHA FROM FREMONT CALIFORNIA.
WAS QUESTIONED BY POLICE AT OUR
HOME.
AFTER SHE'D ASKED ABOUT
AMMUNITION FOR HER RIFLE AT A
LOCAL SPORTING GOODS STORE.
SAID MISTER UNGER WHO IS A
LICENSED FIREARMS INSTRUCTOR
PREPARING TO BECOME.
A LOS ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT
--
OFFICER.
THIS SINGLE ME OUT OF THE WAY
THAT I LOOK.
I WOULD FRIENDS PURCHASE BULK
AMMO AND THEY NEVER HAD POLICE
SHOW UP AT THE DOOR.
THE SAME WEEK OF ANY OF A SICK
AMERICAN MAN FROM CALIFORNIA
SLEEPING ON A PLANE WAS POSTED
TO YOUTUBE THE CAPTION.
WOULD YOU FEEL SLAVE SAFE FLYING
WITH BIN LADEN.
THE DAY AFTER CHRISTMAS SIXTY
EIGHT YEAR OLD SICK AMERICAN
FARM WORKER MIXING BOWL WAS
ASSAULTED BY TWO WHITE MEN IN
FRESNO WHILE WAITING FOR A RIDE
TO WORK IN THE PREDAWN FOG.
AFTER YOUNG OBSCENITIES AT THE
ELDERLY MAN IS A SALES HIT HIM
WITH THEIR TRUCK AS HE TRIED TO
GET AWAY.
AS THEY ATTACKED IN ONE OF THE
SUSPECTS SCREAMED WHY ARE YOU
HERE.
MISTER BALL SUFFERED ABRASIONS
TO THE NOSE IN HAND AND A BROKEN
COLLAR BONE AS WELL AS CUTS
REQUIRING STITCHES ON HIS EAR IN
THE BACK OF HIS HEAD.
WELL IS ATTACKERS WERE CAUGHT
AND CHARGED HATE CRIMES.
THIS RESOLUTION DOES NOTHING
ADDRESS CONDITIONS THAT LED TO
THIS HATE ATTACK.
THEN ON NEW YEAR'S DAY RETURN
SINGLE ALSO SIXTY EIGHT ALSO IN
FRESNO WAS STABBED TO DEATH AT A
CONVENIENCE STORE WHERE HE
WORKED IT WAS THE FIRST HOMICIDE
IN CALIFORNIA.
IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN THIS IS ALL
BEFORE DONALD TRUMP RAN FOR
OFFICE [inaudible]
SO.
YOU KNOW AS A SCHOLAR THE WORK I
WORK I DO AYE AYES AYE ISOLATED
PHENOMENA WHICH I CALL THE
RACIALIZATION RELIGIOUS
IDENTITY.
AND I BELIEVE IT'S BEEN
OPERATION SINCE THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES CERTAIN XCELERATED
AFTER TWO THOUSAND ONE WERE
RACE.
HAS BECOME OPUS OUR RELIGIOUS
IDENTITY HAS BEEN COMING ABUSE
BICU WITH RACIAL MEANING.
THAT'S CERTAINLY CENTRAL TO WHY
MUSLIMS SIX BROWN PEOPLE ARE NOT
ONLY BEING ATTACKED FOR BEING
HARASSED BY POLICE PLAYING.
CARESS OF AIRPORTS.
SO YOU WANT TO KNOW THAT THE
STATE OF THE SICK COMMUNITYIS
ONE OF EMERGENCY IT'S BEEN THIS
WAY FROM MOST TWO DECADES VERY A
GENERATION GROUP WOULD DAILY
TRAUMA. FOR SICK BOY NOT INDOOR
BOWLING IN THIS IN THIS IN THIS
SOCIETY IS ALMOST UNHEARD OF
GIRLS ISN'T MUCH BETTER
[inaudible]
SO.
WHEN EMPLOYED WANT ONE MORE
POINT I WANT TO MAKE SO SICK
COMMUNITY WAS VERY VERY HAPPY
TWENTY SIXTEEN BECAUSE THE FBI
HAD FINALLY AGREED TO TRACK IT
BECAUSE BY RACE?
WHAT THEY CAME UP WITH THE
NUMBER FOR THE ENTIRE YEAR WAS?
SIX SO AS A SCHOLAR AND AN
ADVOCATE I THINK IT'S BETTER FOR
THE FBI TO STOP CRIME COUNTING A
CRIMES.
BECAUSE THE UNDERCOUNTED SO
SEVERE THAT IT MARGINALIZES US
AND IT INVISIBLE EYES IS THE
PROBLEM OF THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
WE'RE TALKING YOU KNOW CLOSE TO
MILLION SIX ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
EXPERIENCE ON A DAILY BASIS AND
IT'S NOT JUST US MUSLIMS SIX IN
THOSE BUDDHISTS.
ARE OUR OUR SLICE OF WORSHIPPER
ATTACKED.
ANDBEFORE WE CAN EVEN BUILD
THEM THERE AND I RIGHT THEN THEY
WANTED TO BUILD.
A MUST HIT THE GROUND ZERO CLOSE
TO GROUND ZERO DOZEN US ANOTHER
MUST OF THE FEW BLOCKS AWAY.
BUT RACISTS FOUGHT IT.
SO THIS IS THE STATE IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S A STATE OF SEVERE EMERGENCY
FOR THOSE WHO I CALL OUR MEN OF
PROFILE COMMUNITIES OF PROFILE
BECAUSE WE ALWAYS FIT THE
PROFILE.
SO I PLEAD WITH YOU THE ENTIRE
STRUCTURE OF THE SYSTEM HAS TO
BE ALTERED A CRIMES ARE BEING
IGNORED WHEN THEY'RE COUNTED THE
BEING COUNTED INSUFFICIENTLY.
AND THERE'S RESISTANCE BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
SO YOU KNOW THE SICK AMERICA
LEGAL OFFENSIVE ARE FINDING ALL
OF THEIR SICK ADVOCACY GROUPS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
STAND READY TO WORK WITH YOU AND
PLEASE CALL US FOR EXPERTISE
WERE MORE THAN HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY ARE MULTI FOR THE
LENGTH OF NO PROBLEM NO EXIT
IMMIGRANT MYSELF I UNDERSTAND.
YOUR PAIN AND FRUSTRATION BUT I
ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY OF AND FOR THE LAST
TWENTY FIVE OR TWENTY SIX YEARS.
I THINK THE IT EVERY LITTLE BIT
OF AFTER THAT THE LOOP WE CAN
DO.
AND IN THE COMMUNITY WILL HELP
TO CHANGE THE SYSTEM SO AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMIN
AND GOT THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
DOES THE HEARINGS OF THE GOING